Previously on Mobile Max.
Wir fangen mit dem ersten Thema an, was auch immer das sein mag.
Wir müssen mal wieder über Max reden.
Wir sind ja kein Apple Podcast mehr.
Das ist Mobile Max, ne?
Na ja, okay, wir können das auch lassen. Ihr hört es, die letzte Mobile Max Sendung. Continuos. Wir können ja mal über was anderes reden.
Wir sind ja in der Freak Show.
Worüber könnte man denn sonst noch in dieser Runde quatschen?
S-Bahn.
Da reden wir doch mal über...
Wir müssen mehr über Nokia reden.
Ach so.
Wir sind ja in der Freak Show.
So, hier, Java. Wir müssen mal wieder über Java reden.
Wenn man keine Ahnung hat.
Einfach mal die Klappe halten.
Wer wollte sich über die Telekom aufregen?
Rikke.
Zum Kotzen.
Alles Verbrecher. Denn sie klauen Arschibächer.
Wir müssen mal über VMS reden. Die Zukunft von gestern schon heute.
Ja, wir sollten mal mehr übers Wetter reden.
Wir sollten mehr über Kalender reden.
Hast du gesagt.
Denke mal, das Thema ist durch.
Lass uns über Mastertexts reden.
Lass uns über Festplatten reden, weil...
Wir sind ja in der Freak Show.
Wir müssen über Fußball reden. Wir müssen wirklich über Fußball und die Computerszene. Wir müssen auch über Abtatt nicht reden.
Must I, Miss Sophie. Wir sind ja in der Freak Show.
Ich will mehr über Quartalzahlen reden. Scheiße. So, worüber wollen wir als nächstes reden?
Wer ist ja der Talkmaster hier?
IPv6.
Genau, wir haben nämlich nicht nur Country, sondern wir haben auch Western.
Da sind wir.
Ja, alles ist anders.
Guck mal, jetzt haben wir sogar ein Bett.
Ein Bett? Der Tisch ist dreckig, oh Gott. Das wollten wir eigentlich ändern. Scheiße, ich spule nochmal zurück. Ein Quatschbett, ein Musikbett, ein Moderationsbett, was jetzt langsam alles so ausfällt. Genau, was so langsam so vor sich hin glucksert und so, weil wenn man ja schon mal die Chance hat, alles neu zu machen, dann macht man halt alles neu.
Hier werden Technologien aufgefahren.
Ja, es ist einfach unglaublich. Ja, willkommen zur Freak Show, denn so heißt dieser Podcast jetzt. Und da gab es schon sehr unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu, ob das nun eine tolle Idee ist oder nicht. Aber wir können das Rätsel aufklären, ist eine tolle Idee. Because we say so und wir haben sowieso keine andere Wahl. Und um mir gleich den Gerüchteküchen im Chat vorzubeugen, so, nee, Clemens hat das nicht erfunden, er hat bloß mal fast verplappert. Ja, ist ja jetzt dokumentiert, ne?
Ja, aber Freak Show ist ja nun auch jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig originell, dass niemals jemand davor diesen Namen in den Mund genommen hätte.
Nee, eigentlich nicht.
Deswegen?
Trotzdem macht es thermik.
Ja, ich meine nur wegen verplappert. Also das ist jetzt so.
Ja, ja, nee, wir haben ja alle auch ein bisschen geschmunzelt.
Das ist ja auch gut, aber es ist auch keiner draufgekommen.
Das fand ich eigentlich am tollsten. Und ja, wir wollen uns jetzt hier auch gar nicht so sehr in der Deutung und so weiter aufgehen lassen, sondern danken erstmal den Leuten, die hier kräftig mitgemischt haben. Abgesehen hier vom Team. Wir müssen mal vorstellen, ne? Huckel ist nicht da, aber Dennis, Roddy, Clemens ist da. Ich bin da.
Ich bin auch da.
Dennis ist zweimal da.
Dennis heute in Stereo. Ich bin sozusagen in Vertretung, der ist gerade im Meer und lernt, wie man Schiffe fährt, nämlich Segeln. Ach, du wolltest ja jetzt noch kompromittierendes Material zeigen. Ja, hab ich auch gerade überlegt, aber wo soll ich denn das hin tun?
Auf den Tisch.
Ach, für euch nur, dann könnt ihr da wieder nicht zugucken.
Ach komm, als Hörer musst du da halt einfach auch ein bisschen Fantasie entwickeln.
Also, er hat hier so ein schickes Panorama gemacht, irgendwie einmal. Das ist aber wirklich blöd für die Hörer. Das ist einmal das da. Hier, kurz mal gucken. Da ist noch dieses Band.
Blau.
Und dann das nächste ist... Ja, wartet.
Hier trocken segeln oder was sitzt da mit so so einem Mocker?
Ist da auf dem Schiffchen.
Das ist ja ein richtig dickes Teil.
Naja, segeln halt.
Krass. Fährt er das alleine? Nee? Ist ja sehr smooth, ne?
Wahrscheinlich darf er Kartoffeln schälen oder die Drehung in die Spirellis machen.
Tja, dann schnitzt man nochmal ordentlich Nudeln.
Ja, wir vermissen ihn schon jetzt.
Vermessen?
Vermissen. Achso. Vermissen.
Immer.
Immer, wenn er nicht da ist.
Nicht zu vermissen, wer vermessen.
Das wäre sehr vermessen. Ansonsten überwachen wir ihn aber natürlich auch rund um die Uhr.
Na jetzt gerade, ich guck mal, wo er ist.
Hast du Checking?
Hab ich ja gesehen, dass er gerade so weit weg ist.
Ja, die Chance mit Leuten, die so richtig weit im Urlaub sind, das ist immer so richtig crazy.
Ja, ein Kumpel von mir ist gerade irgendwo in Jugoslawien heiraten. Ich sag jetzt nicht wer.
Da hat er auch so einen dort irgendwie mitten in Norwegen so irgendwo im Nichts und ein anderer Kollege schippert ohnehin die ganze Zeit durch die Karibik.
Okay, 1568 Kilometer weit weg. Das ist bisher der Rekord hier von den Leuten, die ich so tracke.
Na, solange der Stream läuft, hat er denn Internet?
Ja, weiß ich nicht.
Wie?
Wenn er Netz hätte, könnte er mir eine iMessage schicken.
Meinst du, er fährt irgendwo hin, wo es keinen...
Doch, doch, meine Messages hat er ja bekommen.
Vielleicht noch als SMS.
Was bietest du 1500? Ich biete 9114.
Ach, so ne Leute hab ich auch.
Muss ich jetzt nur noch mal jemand schnell nach Hawaii schicken.
So, wir haben ja auch halt etwas Pause gemacht. Haben wir irgendwas verpasst?
Hängt von deiner Definition von verpassen ab, würde ich mal sagen.
O2 und E+.
Also ist schon doch das eine oder andere, das ist schon das eine oder andere, das ist schon das eine oder andere, das ist schon das eine oder andere, das ist schon das eine oder andere. Die machen sich zumindest da den entsprechenden Humor. Die machen sich zumindest da den entsprechenden Humor. Die machen sich zumindest da den entsprechenden Humor. Die haben doch irgendwann mal so viel Geld investiert in diesen 3D-Penguin. Und damit sich das auch auszahlt, müssen sie jetzt über Jahre hinweg Artikel damit...
Ich meine, Freak Show, der Name ist ja ganz schön, aber wir müssen jetzt nicht über Linux diskutieren. So weit ist es ja noch nicht gekommen.
Solche Freaks sind wir dann auch nicht.
So tief sind wir noch nicht gefallen.
Ich benutze Linux, ja.
Ab und zu schmeiß ich mal so eine Ubuntu-CD rein.
Ich hab diverse Geräte, wo das unten drunter läuft. Unter anderem mein aktueller Lieblingsrouter. Da läuft auch ein Linux drunter.
Wenn die Leute am Anfang meinten, dass das iPhone mit einem Linux-Körner kommen wird oder dass sie es umstellen wollen, und alles so ein Schnickschnack, was die nicht alles erzählt haben.
Also ich verwende Linux auf meinem Download-Server, weil es nicht möglich war, auf die BSD zu installieren. Du erinnerst dich vielleicht an diese Episode?
Ja, da kann ich ja nichts dafür verwenden, da die Wolke und so einen virtuellen Shit haben.
Ich hab dir keinen Vorwurf gemacht. Ich sag nur, das ging halt dann am Ende irgendwie alles nicht.
Timmer, auf deiner Fritzbox läuft auch ein Linux.
Ja, wahrscheinlich läuft überhaupt auf enorm vielen Devices hier auf diesem komischen Nexus 7 läuft ein Linux. Wo läuft denn noch ein Linux?
Ich glaub, da bestimmt auf jedem Scanner, auf jedem Android-Telefon.
Überall läuft mittlerweile irgendwo Linux.
Ja, aber die Frage war ja nach einem richtigen Linux.
Genau.
Wie nach einem richtigen Linux.
Was ist dann ein richtiger oder ein ungefährer Linux?
Naja, wenn du so eine Install-CD einlegst irgendwie, dann lässt du ihn eine Weile machen und wenn er fertig ist, fragst du dich, was tust du hier eigentlich?
Du meinst also eine verseuchte PC-Hardware? Naja, das ist das, was du als richtige Linux bezeichnest. Also nicht so ein Embedded Linux, sondern du nimmst ein PC und überlegst dir jetzt, mach ich ihn mit Windows kaputt oder mit Linux?
Und dann installierst du FreeBSD.
Naja, jeder was er mag, ich hab ja gar nichts dagegen. Man muss ja irgendwie alles machen.
Genau.
Manchmal ist Linux auch wirklich die bessere Wahl.
Ich find zumindest besser, dass es jetzt für diese ganzen Embedded Systeme, dass es da was gibt. Und ganz ehrlich, das Einzige, warum ich Linux nicht einsetze, ist einfach, dass ich zu alt dafür bin, mir zu merken, wo sie in der letzten Distribution wieder alle Programme hin gepackt haben. Oder die Dateien, das nervt mich jedes Mal, wenn ich auf dem Linux-System irgendwas zu tun habe. Liegt das jetzt in ETC oder in Local ETC? Oder in Brusa Local ETC? Das geht mir so auf den Zünder. Aber ansonsten ist das ein System wie alle anderen. Und ich find's ganz gut, wenn das halt jetzt eben auf so einem Badet-System läuft, dann kann man so bestimmte Sachen einfach mal, man kann da mal was eingeben und sich dann über die Fehlermeldungen ergötzen. Ich sag, selbst auf meinem aktuellen Lieblingsrouter, diesem Edge-Router, den ich jetzt übrigens auch auf dem ITF-Meeting intensivsteingesetzt habe, da läuft auch unten DB an drunter oder so.
Hier fragst du mal ernsthaft einer, was FreeBSD ist. Ist ja mal eine gute Frage.
FreeBDS?
FreeBSD ist Unix.
Unix?
Im Gegensatz zu Linux, das ist nämlich Linux. Jetzt wird nicht religiös. Das ist einfach ein Fakt.
Wie war das? Linux war nur der Körner, richtig?
Ja, aber es ist halt nicht Unix, weil es eben nicht auf Unix basiert, sondern es ist halt neu programmiert worden und heißt Linux. Und es gibt halt FreeBSD und es gibt noch diverse andere Betriebssysteme, die tatsächlich ihren Ursprung in Unix, dem Betriebssystem, so wie das damals hieß, und wie es sich über Jahre und Jahrzehnte hinweg entwickelt hat. Und heutzutage ist halt von den freien Ready-to-run-PC-Betriebssystemen, die man so bekommen kann, ist halt FreeBSD so das Unix-artigste. Also das, was am meisten so ist wie Unix. Also wer Unix noch gewohnt ist, ist ja heute kaum noch einer, der fühlt sich dann halt bei FreeBSD am meisten zu Hause.
Und du meinst Open Solaris nicht?
Das gibt's ja nicht mehr. Oder? Wie heißt das?
Open Indiana. Beziehungsweise es gibt da jetzt nochmal...
Ach nee, warte mal, jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst.
Oracle hat's halt verkackt. Und dann hatten die keinen Bock mehr.
Ja.
Und dann haben die Jungs weitergemacht, sind alle gegangen und haben einfach woanders weiter. Bei Illumos. Die Bruder, die das jetzt eigentlich weiter macht. Weil Oracle irgendwie die ganzen Leute verloren hat und die sind jetzt bei Illumos.
Ja, da kann man jetzt wirklich lange darüber streiten, ob das sozusagen das Ur-Unix ist, weil da gab es ja so merkwürdige Verschränkungen. Also so... Es gab mal eine Phase, wo eben... Das muss ich mir gleich mal überlegen. SunOS war ja sozusagen der Quell des BSDs.
Nee, ich glaube SunOS war noch länger auf System 5 als das BSD selber. Aber da müsste man mal in den Unix-Stammbaum reingucken. Da gab es doch mal so ein ewig langes Dokument.
Ich halt lieber nicht klappen, dann kann man es nur noch falsch machen.
SunOS ist die Definition von BSD, von Berkeley gewesen. Später gab es dann eine Phase, wo dann Sun umgeschwenkt ist auf den Unix-System-5-Train. Und ganz viele Sachen umgestellt hat, Streams.
Wo die AT&T-Bildfische so rumstauern haben.
Ist jetzt auch alles eigentlich ziemlich egal. Das ist alles so Papa-Opa-erzählt-vorm-Krieg. Ur-Opa-erzählt-vorm-Krieg ist das schon fast.
Von vorm Krieg.
Na ja, wir auch immer. Man kann sich das mal anschauen. Also diese Unix-Historie ist irgendwie lustig hier. Scott hat es auch gerade in den Chat reingeschmissen hier. So ein unübersichtliches Gestrüpp. Das Ur-BSD ging dann in SunOS über. Also SunOS, die Sun-Büchsen haben ja da eine Uli.
BSD liegt erstmal bei sich selber. 4.2, 4.3, Tahoe, Reno, BSD, weiter unten.
Der totale Inzester auf dieser Karte.
SunOS hat sich sozusagen aus diesen BSDs heraus entwickelt. Na ja, da kann man jetzt viel herumstochen.
Abgründe, möchte ich mal sagen.
Abgründe.
Anyway, brauchen sie alles auch nicht gar nicht weiter zu interessieren. Heutzutage nimmt man halt das, was einem passt und was auf eine Platte kommt. Aber ich finde trotzdem FreeBSD geiler. Ganz ehrlich, für mich fasst sich das irgendwie cooler an. Ich finde das auch gut, wenn so ein Betriebssystem mit Kernel und UserLand aus einem Guss so kommt. Wollt man das schon? Das bleibt hier nicht so richtig. So, jetzt habt ihr die Wahl. Wollen wir über Deutschland reden? Wollen wir über die Welt reden?
Erstmal die Welt und dann ziehen wir den Fokus langsam zu.
Okay, die Welt. Was ist passiert? Die Welt wird überwacht. Jetzt wissen wir es.
Ja, das wussten wir vorher schon.
Das wussten wir vorher, aber wir wussten nicht genau, wie.
Wir wussten noch nicht, wie viel.
Und nicht wie viel. Und jetzt wissen wir das etwa.
Ich durfte seit vier Wochen oder seit, keine Ahnung, fünf, sechs Wochen mit einem I told you so T-Shirt rum.
Wirklich?
Pretty much, ja. Irgendwann muss ich auch mal die Wäsche. Ich hab halt schon immer wie so ein bisschen rumgelästert und gemacht getan über NSA und la la la und die Leute haben halt immer so ein bisschen so Lächeln. Und jetzt. Told you so. Aber dann ist natürlich trotzdem schon interessant so der, das Ausmaß, wie viele Leute da auch alle mitmischen. Wie viele Leute da alle willentlich und wissentlich drin rumstochern, schon seit Jahren, seit Jahrzehnten, lange vor 9-Eleven und jetzt jetzt alle so tun, als wüssten sie von nichts. Es ist also wieder massiv peinlich gerade, was da passiert. Und zwar nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern in allen möglichen Ländern. Ja, aber es jetzt für mich ändert sich jetzt technisch nicht besonders viel.
Weiß nicht. Hast du das Gefühl, dass das irgendwas, also dass das so fürs Business was ändert? Also ich hab so gehört, dass schon so die deutschen Unternehmen oder die europäischen Unternehmen jetzt schon so einen etwas, so einen kleinen Schritt zurücknehmen, was so die Dienste der Amerikaner betrifft.
Ich hab jetzt gerade heute irgendwas was gelesen, irgendwas standart. Weiß nicht, ob bei Herrso oder so, dass die großen Cloud-Provider bei den Amis ihre Fälle in Form von Dollars da hinschwimmen sehen. Weil sie jetzt die Leute da auch kündigen. Die Leute überlegen sich jetzt halt dreimal, ob sie ihren Scheiß bei Google laufen lassen oder nicht. Oder bei Amazon oder sonst irgendwo. Also es wird zumindest lauter darüber nachgedacht. Und ein paar, die sich das leisten können, ihre Plattformen umzuziehen, werden das auch tun. Oder haben das jetzt schon getan? Ob das dadurch besser wird, weiß ich nicht. Das ist natürlich eine andere Frage. Weil es ist ja gerade das Interessante daran, dass die NSA bei allem mithört und macht und tut, was in ihr eigenes Land reingeht. Das war ja ohnehin klar, dass die halt eben auch gehen und einfach mal miesen an das Kabel rumlaufen, das mal frech ins D6 reinstecken, was ja immer wieder ein Teil bestritten wird durch überspezifische Dementis. Das ist natürlich schon nach einer neuen Qualität.
Überspezifische Dementis, du meinst so mit... Nein, es ist nicht so, dass das Kabel genau durch diesen Raum und in den anderen Raum geht und dort in 30 Minuten...
Nächste Woche Donnerstag steckt da kein Kabel um 18 Uhr.
D6 hat gesagt, auf keinen Fall haben hier ausländische oder angloamerikanische Dienste ihr Kabel hier irgendwo drinstecken. Na gut, es ist halt der BND, ist mir egal. Oder die Franzosen oder I don't care. Das ist ja auch schon länger bekannte Praxis, dass gerade zwischen Frankreich und Deutschland eine super Kooperation stattfindet. Das heißt, wenn die Deutschen mal jemanden abhören wollen oder Informationen haben wollen, für den sie keinen richterlichen Beschluss kriegen, fragen sie halt mal Paris nach, ob die Kollegen das nicht für sie machen. Die machen das genauso.
So wie die Amerikaner in Ägypten foltern lassen, lässt man woanders schnorcheln.
Fremdschnorcheln. Das ist ja das Spannende daran, dass sozusagen all die Gesetze, die in allen Ländern, die eigentlich davor schützen sollen, sich immer nur auf die eigene Bevölkerung beziehen.
Ja, ja, jetzt auch dieser Datenabgleich vom BND. So, so, ja, naja, 500 Millionen Datensätze, aber nicht über Deutsche.
Ja, oder was ich da jetzt neulich gelesen habe, auch so lächerlich vor ein paar Tagen, ja, wir hören ja nix ab, was von domains.com mit.de hinten. Oder von Telefonen, die mit 0049 anfangen. Das ist unendlich putzig, dass sie mit 0049 kommen, weil die 00 geht sowieso hier nur bei uns und den EFTA-Staaten und so, aber finde ich trotzdem lustig. Wie Pfeffer so schön schrieb, schade für die Leute, die ein GMX-Net-Account haben oder bei sap.com arbeiten oder so. Dumm gelaufen, aber...
Ja, angenehm, prittlarf.org. Aber ich bin ja eh als Ausländer geführt, von daher dürfte alles gut, wenn du willst.
Du gehörst ja zu den, wie heißt sie, der Achse der Willigen, nein, die... Die Amis, die Briten, die Kanadier, Neuseeländer und die Australier.
Die Fünf Augen.
Klingt wie so ein Kinderroman, die drei Fragezeiten.
Das ist der Pakt seit Anno Dunemars.
Echelon haben sie auch schon gespielt zu Fünf.
Fünf Eyes gibt es schon viel, viel, viel länger. Das ist schon seit Weltkriegszeiten seit 1946 gibt es das.
Das Fünf Eyes.
So genannt, die UK USA Agreement, dem aber sich dann halt auch noch Kanada, Australien und Neuseeland.
Neuseeland, diese drei Millionen Leute, die da leben.
Na ja, kann man gut kabel durch...
Alles untertan ihrer Majestät.
Es ist alles nicht ganz irrelevant für geostrategische Zugriffe. Da hilft am Ende die kleinste Insel. Jedes bisschen Seerecht ist hilfreich. Und ich glaube, an der Stelle ist es einfach dieses, wir sprechen die gleiche Sprache, wir stammen alle vom Briten ab.
Wir sind alle Untertanen der Königin.
Wir trauen zwar... Ja, genau.
Ja, genau.
Es ist eigentlich die Queen und der Präsident. Die beiden, die machen das irgendwie unter sich aus.
Schon ein bisschen krass.
Damit der nicht versehentlichen Premierminister rauskommt, oder?
Was denkst du denn? Gibt ja so ein bisschen lustig.
Das ist gefährlich, ne? Ist das nicht so, nach britischen Rechten ist ja so, was ich...
Was ist gefährlich, dass ich frage, was du denkst?
Nee, nee, nee, Freedom of Speech und so weiter, davor ist ja alles okay, aber das Einzige, was man da nicht darf, ist die Königin beleidigen, oder?
Er war's, er war's.
Ich küm mich da nicht so gut aus.
Zählt für mich nicht.
Ich bin ja nur so ein Papierbrite, ich hab eigentlich keine Ahnung.
Verstehe.
Auf jeden Fall frag ich mich, für wie realistisch hältst du denn diese Full-Take-Nummer? Also dieses, wir überwachen jetzt mal, indem wir da unsere Schnorchel direkt an diese Glasfaser ran schnackeln. Vielleicht beugen wir da auch mal so das eine andere Kabel.
Brauchste nicht. Ist eine tolle Story. Brauchste nicht. Hab mich die Lilo's neulich auch schon gefragt. Brauchste nicht, weil die spannenden Kabel, die haben wir, die landen eh bei denen an. Da gehst du einfach hin und steckst einfach deinen Stecker in das Multiplexer-Link da rein. Brauchste nicht an dem Kabel rumfummeln, das biegen und machen.
Oder? Du wolltest wissen, ob die wirklich komplett mitspeichern.
Ja, ob dieser Fulltake überhaupt technisch machbar ist.
Speicherplatz-mäßig.
Naja, das ja, also auch, ja.
Da gab's doch Artikel, das hier für eine gewisse Zeit alles komplett speichern und dann irgendwie rauslöschen, was sie nicht brauchen und die wichtigen Sachen irgendwie aufheben.
Also du willst jetzt wissen, ob die Briten das packen, alles, was über die Strippen da an ihrer Insel vorbeigeht, nicht einfach mal irgendwo auf eine Festplatte draufzuschmieren.
Die Briten, auch die Amerikaner überhaupt, die wäre auch immer da sozusagen so ein Dickrohr entgegennimmt, wo halt die Daten so schnell wie möglich nach Y wollen, dass du dann auch sozusagen diesen ganzen Traffic immer komplett mitspeicherst.
Warum nicht?
Das heißt aber, dass du auch da...
Ist unsäglich teuer, aber es sind ja nur Steuergelder. Also von daher ist es vollkommen egal. Kann man das machen. Guck mal, die Amis haben ja auch gesagt, weshalb du das mitgekriegt hast, die haben einfach mal 100 Millionen Pfund Richtung Insel geschmissen, damit die Briten den Job dafür machen. Also mit 100 Millionen Pfund kann man schon noch mal eine Festplatte kaufen. Oder zwei. Ich würde ohnehin sagen, also das vernünftigste wäre gewesen, nachdem dieser Skandal rauskam, sofort hinzugehen und Seagate und Western Digital Aktien zu kaufen. Weil da gibt es durchaus ein paar Leute in dieser Branche, die sich echt massiv die Hände reiben.
Ja, eh schon, oder? Macht es das jetzt irgendwie schlimmer?
Also es ändert ja nichts.
Die Flut in Thailand war wahrscheinlich auch nur so ein Cover-up.
Nee, klar kannst du das machen. Es ist wahnsinnig schwer, das auseinanderzufupseln, aber man kann ja erstmal alles speichern. Warum nicht? Die Amis machen das ja auch, die Amis gucken nach dem, was man so lesen kann. Ich weiß dann auch nicht genau, was die da treiben, aber die Idee ist ja, dass die halt eben auch alles angucken, was klarschriftlich lesbar ist und das schonmal vorsortieren. Das, was verschlüsselt ist, speichern sie einfach auf ewig weg. Für den Fall, dass man es irgendwann nochmal anschlüsseln möchte.
Aber dass so etwas wie Full-Tech beim Dezix stattfindet, das glauben wir jetzt mal nicht, oder?
Warum nicht? Da hast du auch nicht mehr Trafik drauf, als auf der Strippe zwischen hier und drüben.
Ja, aber hast du da nicht N zu N-Beziehungen? Dann müsste da alles durch so einen dicken, fetten Stern durchgehen, der sozusagen die Gesamtkapazität der Interconnect darstellt.
Reicht nicht aus, mit einem Firewire-Kabel anzutreten. Oder mit einem USB-2-Stecker, ich hab da mal eine Platte dabei. Das kann sicherlich nicht, aber es reicht ja schon, wenn du drauf schnorcheln kannst. Du kannst ja auf so Switches, die haben ja so Monitoring-Ports. Jeder switch, moderne, manageable Switch hat Monitoring-Ports. Auch der, der da gerade unter deinem Mischpult lauert, hat sowas. Und dem kann man auch durchaus noch ein paar Parameter mitgeben, wenn der von einem ordentlichen Hersteller ist. Das heißt, du kannst das auch schon vorselektieren. Allerdings hat das natürlich die Nachteile, dass du vorher wissen willst, wonach du suchst. Pimadaum. Wenn du das jetzt alles einfach mitspeichern willst, brauchst du natürlich die Gesamtkapazität, die auf dem Backbone von so einem Ding hängt. Und die ist jetzt nicht so einfach rauszukriegen, aber es ist möglich, die rauszukriegen. Allerdings ist es dann wirklich sehr schwer, das unaufwendig zu tun. Also es ist nicht damit getan, dass du ein Gigabit Ethernet dir besorgst und das an die Seite in einen hässlichen Port steckst, den keiner mehr kennt, sondern da musst du dann schon noch ein bisschen mehr tun. Also sag mal so, ich halte nicht für undenkbar, ich halte aber gerade im Falle von D6 für nicht unauffällig denkbar, wenn du den gesamten Verkehr komplett abschneucheln willst.
Ja, aber das heißt ja, dass da auch irgendwelche Leute da sehr wohl eingeweiht sein müssen in das, was da eigentlich wirklich passiert. Ja, und sind das dann auch schon so amerikanische Verhältnisse, das mit so irgendwie du hältst uns das Maul oder wir wissen, wo du wohnst?
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen. Ich arbeite nicht beim D6. Aber es gibt da verschiedene Schnittstellen. Zumal D6, wenn sich die Leute so vorstellen, ist ja nicht bloß ein Switch, der in einem Haus an einem Ort steht, wo man unten einen Wachhund hinsetzt mit ein bisschen Schappi, der dann oft passt, dass da keiner reingeht, der da nicht rein soll, sondern D6 ist ja auch ein verteilter System. Verteilter D6. Und das heißt, es gibt verschiedene Standorte, wo du überall gucken musst, wer da irgendwie wo drauf geht und musst natürlich auch gucken, die Verbindungen zwischen den Orten. Da ist jetzt keiner vom D6 selber persönlich mit einer Glasrolle und einer Schippe durch Frankfurt gerannt und hat die da verbuddelt, sondern die mieten sich natürlich was an.
Der wird hier aufgekauft von Colt.
Der wird gemietet, gekauft, was auch immer. Wer da jetzt dazwischen noch drin hängt und sich da noch was für Spielchen einbaut, da haben natürlich die Betreiber vom D6 keine Ahnung oder keine Handhabe. Man kann durchaus ein Szenario konstruieren, wo die durchaus sagen können, wir wissen davon nichts. Auch gerade wegen der verteilten Natur von dem Ding. Da sind Hunderte von Leuten dazwischen, Leute, die da Zugriff drauf haben oder auch nicht. Das reicht ja schon, wenn du jemanden hingehst zu Colt und sagst, ich hätte gerne mal den Plan, wo er kabellang geht. Dann sagt er, das darf ich dir aber nicht geben. Dann zeig dem das Bild von seinen Kindern vor der Schule und gibt mir den Plan. Dann nehme ich mir eine Schaufel als NSA oder BND oder sonstiger Mitarbeiter, kauf mir einen ordentlichen Multiplexer und buddel den da rein. Der andere Blast dran und fertig, zack. Das kann man schon machen. Soweit kann man konstruieren, aber wie gesagt, das ist jetzt nicht ganz unaufwendig. Und D6 ist ja beileibe nicht das einzige Ding, was es da gibt. Was ja in Europa auch noch sehr spannend ist, ich glaube sogar, das hören die Deutschen nicht so gerne, aber ich glaube sogar spannender ist Amsterdam.
Amsik ist auf jeden Fall der größte Knoten.
Ja, wonach bemisst du Größe? Nach Anzahl der Ports oder nach Volumen? Ja, das kann durchaus sein, weil es natürlich auch viele Großfuzzis gibt, die da ihre ganzen Rechenzentrum dranstecken, wie Ackermeyer oder sonst wo.
Ja, und das ist ja auch so das Sprungbrett des Kontinents. Also da sammelt sich halt schon immer alles.
Da gibt es noch ein bisschen was in London, da spielen sie auch noch, und diverse andere Zikse noch. Übrigens für die Hörer, die jetzt nicht wissen, wovon ich immer rede, Zikse ist ein kürmerischer Internet-Exchange. Also sozusagen ein Punkt, wo sich Internet-Provider alle treffen. Fast alle treffen.
Alle außer der Telekom.
Und wieder mal alle außer der Telekom. Mit denen hatte ich jetzt auch ein bisschen zu tun, das war sehr lustig. Ich hab ja letzte Woche das ITF-Meeting in Berlin. Das ITF ist die Internet Engineering Task Force. Das sind die Leute, die...
Das Internet designen.
Ja, die vom Prinzip das Internet designen. Die die Protokolle dort designen und umdesignen und kaputt machen. Oder auch nicht. Und damit so diversen Suborganisationen wie dem IAB, dem Internet Architecture Board oder ITF Architecture Board oder wie auch immer. Und ja, die treffen sich dreimal im Jahr. Nehm ich eigentlich der Vereinbarung nach einmal in den Amerikas irgendwo, was in der Regel bei denen bedeutet in den USA, einmal in Europa, wo dann irgendwo in Europa ist und einmal in Asien. Wobei jetzt witzigerweise die Definition von Asien...
Alles was nicht Amerika und Europa ist.
Ja, zum Beispiel der nächste Asien-Punkt ist im November glaube ich in Vancouver. Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht, aber egal. Und die brauchen natürlich auch massiv Internet dort und da gab es dann auch ein Sponsoring eines größeren deutschen ISPs, der dort mal...
Wo jetzt hier in Berlin?
Ja, hier in Berlin. War im Hotel Interconti. Und da haben die dann mal zwei Glasfaser in den Keller von dem Hotel reingeschmissen und da ein bisschen Licht drauf gegeben. Also zweimal einen Gigabit. Und das war sehr lustig da mit den Kollegen. Die waren total nett, aber denkst du auch manchmal so, ey, hallo, könnt der mal diese Sache mit der Ex-Behörde und den Beamten mal vergessen oder so? Das war schon ein bisschen komisch. Ja komm, die waren jetzt Sponsoren. Ich kann jetzt nicht komplett über die Leder ziehen, weil sie, wie gesagt, sie waren auch sehr nett, aber die haben so Prozeduren. Also zum Beispiel, wenn man dort neue IP-Adressen einträgt in diese sogenannten Routing-Registries, wo man sozusagen verzeichnen muss, dass einem ein IP-Netz gehört und so weiter und fort. Wenn man das macht, dann braucht diese spezielle ASP, von dem wir gerade reden, teilweise bis zu acht Tage, das in sein Netz aufzunehmen. Und da denkt man sich auch so, 2013? Schicken die da Kartellkarten mit Brieftauben durch die Gegend? Na ja, aber das ist irgendwie egal. Wie kamen wir darauf? Also wie gesagt, da gibt es diverse Player in diesem Spiel und es sind wahnsinnig viele Daten. Es ist aber auch irrelevant, ob sie in der Lage sind, die komplett alle abzuspeichern. Das reicht ja schon, wenn sie überhaupt eine Strippe dran haben an so einem Ding. Und dann entsprechend sich da draus selektieren können, was sie brauchen. Das ist ja auch schon lustig genug. Schöner Monolog? Dennis Vader hat es schon wieder.
Also du meinst, es geht alles.
Ich sage, man kann nicht bauen, ob das sinnvoll ist oder wie auch immer, weiß ich nicht. Das ist auf jeden Fall teuer. Wenn man unbedingt wollte, könnte man das bauen. Wenn man unbedingt wollte. Aber der Aufwand ist extrem.
Also mit anderen Worten, in Deutschland gibt es das in der Form so nicht. Die Amerikaner und die Briten sind da noch alleine vorne weg. Ich sage nicht, dass es das nicht gibt.
Vielleicht sind die Deutschen auch so unglaublich spannend, dass sie sich das geben. Ich meine, am Ende des Tages sind alle Steuergelder, das heißt, es ist egal, was das kostet. Und am Ende des Tages, wenn du das bezahlen kannst, kannst du das kriegen. Das ist in dem Sinne nicht die unglaubliche Herausforderung. Wie ein Marsflug oder ein Fusionsreaktor oder sowas.
Man muss es ja nicht ewig aufheben. Man muss es nur eine Weile zwischenspeichern und dann kann man Sachen rausfiltern und wegschmeißen.
Das ist echt ein krasses Wort.
Also wie gesagt, es wird da auch viel James Bond drum herum gemacht. Ich glaube schon daran, dass es möglich ist, mit beliebig viel Aufwand unter Laborbedingungen auch irgendwie Unterseekabel anzuzapfen und zu biegen und zu gucken, ob vielleicht da mal ein Proton an der Seite raus schubbert. Aber man muss sich das mal vorstellen. Das ist allein schon für die Leute, die reguläre Endstellen betreiben, unglaublich aufwendig, da einen stabilen Betrieb hinzukriegen. Und jetzt machst du das so, dass du dir von diesem Kabel irgendwie ein paar Nanometer abschubberst in der Hoffnung, dass da mal ein paar, ein, zwei, drei Photonen von versehentlich rausklöppeln und versuchst, die dann noch in dem Highspeed zu dekodieren. Und das bitte schön, alles in einem U-Boot auf Meeresgrund. Ja, kann man machen, aber warum? Denen gehören die Endstellen.
Nein, nicht wenn es um irgendwelche Verbindungen zwischen China und China geht.
Oder zwischen Russland und Russland. Die haben ja ihre eigenen Unterseekabel unter der Arktis durch, weil das kürzer ist, als sie über das Land zu legen. Ja, die Russen haben jetzt eh damit aufhört. Die haben sich jetzt Schreibmaschinen gekauft, Mechaniken bei einer deutschen Firma und erzeugt damit ihre geheimen Dokumente.
Tja, weiß nicht, fällt noch irgendjemand was ein zu diesem ganzen Überwachungsdrama?
Also die eigentliche Frage ist jetzt, muss man da jetzt drauf reagieren?
Ich finde die Frage ganz spannend, was sich eigentlich für Konsequenzen daraus ergeben. Weil, wenn man sich das jetzt anguckt, ich meine, man kann jetzt den Aluhut aufsetzen und sagen, diese ganzen Daten dürfen eigentlich gar nicht entstehen. Und man hat da vielleicht bei irgendeinem zentralen Gesundheitswesen wie unserer Gesundheitskarte Recht. Man hat vielleicht bei diesem komischen Mordbrückensystem Recht. Aber sobald du mobil Daten übertragen willst, überhaupt sobald du irgendwelche Punkt-zu-Punkt-Kommunikation machen möchtest, fallen halt Verkehrsdaten an. Und es ist einfach, also mir ist kein System bekannt, wo du mit jemandem kommunizieren könntest, ohne dass Metadaten anfallen. Und da muss man sich halt mal überlegen, wie geht man denn damit um, dass eigentlich diese Katze aus dem Sack ist. Dass man sie auch nicht mehr zurück in den Sack kriegt. Dass das jetzt quasi, das ist jetzt so. Also soziale Netzwerke, wie sie existieren. Die Leute, mit denen ich telefoniere, oder wann ich mich wo aufhalte, durch mein Telefon, das ist halt jetzt bekannt. Und die Frage ist halt, wie gehen wir damit um? Weil wir kriegen es nicht mehr zurück.
Ja, je nachdem, die Schere im Kopf macht jetzt Schnapp. Das ist schon, denke ich, das wird passieren. Dass die Leute sich jetzt ernsthaft überlegen, ist auch das, wo bei den Verfahren, beim Bundesverfassungsgericht, auch was da Thema war immer, dass die Leute gesagt haben, es geht gar nicht darum, ob du jetzt konkret überwacht wirst. Aber allein die Tatsache, dass du weißt, dass du überwacht wirst, führt dazu, dass du bewusst oder unbewusst deinen Verhalten änderst. Dass du überlegst, ruf ich jetzt den arabischen Nachbarn an, frage ihn, ob mein Kind mit seinem spielen kann oder lasse ich es doch lieber, weil wer weiß, wenn der in seiner Moschee kennt und ob der nicht einen Bruder hat, dessen Enkel irgendwo tralalala bei Akeiler ist, nachher springt man mit dem SEK durchs Fenster. Also ich ruf den arabischen Nachbarn mal lieber nicht an. Diese Geschichte, und das betrifft jetzt noch viel mehr Leute. Vorher hatten wir die Aluhüte und jetzt hat jetzt sozusagen jeder, auch selbst Tagesschaugucker, haben das ins Gesicht gedrückt gekriegt. You are being watched.
Trotzdem hab ich das Gefühl, dass diese ganze Nummer überhaupt nicht auch nur im Ansatz ankommt in diesem Land.
Sie peilen das nicht.
Das kommt aber in Deutschland, wenn man es so hört, immer noch am Meistern von der ganzen Welt.
Ja, aber schlimm genug.
Das liegt aber auch daran, dass wir Gestapo und Stasi hatten, wo so ein paar Leute sich mal ein bisschen sensibilisieren konnten.
Ja, aber auch trotzdem, also ich hab nicht so die Eindruck, dass die Bevölkerung TM das irgendwie begreift. Oder dass sie auch nur bereit ist, es begreifen zu wollen, oder sich selber mal ausrechnen kann, welche Konsequenzen das hat.
Oder es ist halt auch ein Verwergen. Und wir sind doch die Guten.
Aber sollen die Leute auch machen?
So was wie in Ungarn kann bei uns nie passieren.
Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn du da wirklich drüber nachdenkst, dann kannst du ja auch schon mal die Gummizelle buchen. Also das ist natürlich, es ist schon böse.
Ja, vielleicht ist es nur eine Frage des Pitchings. Irgendwie Hickgespein hat vorhin einen schönen Post abgeschickt, so ja, wie wär's denn jetzt mal die totale vollständige Überwachung sämtlicher Geschwindigkeitsbewegungen der Autos komplett erfassen. So, dass man jetzt immer genau weiß, wer wann wo wie schnell fährt.
Ist ja auch gar kein Problem, weil keiner von denen hat was zu verbergen.
Ja, besser noch. Wenn damit auch nur ein Menschenleben gerettet werden kann, dann muss es ja die Sache schon wert sein. Auf der Ebene hat aber diese Diskussion bisher noch nicht stattgefunden. Weil genau das konkret würde natürlich jetzt auch keiner fordern. Weil beim Auto, naja, aber es ist schon interessant. Also du kannst sozusagen die Überwachung deiner Kommunikation kannst du fordern, aber die Überwachung deines Autos nicht. Also ich sag nur so, so ist es. Und es gab hier auf der... Auf feld.de gab es auch eine interessante Replik von so einem angeblich einem ehemaligen ungenannten BND-Mitarbeiter, der irgendwie auch so aus seiner konservativen Logik heraus das Ganze im Kreis dreht. Kannst du überlegen, was so die These war, die du da vorhin bei mir noch verfangen hat. Was denn alle hätten? Früher hätte man eigentlich nur Post und Telefon überwachen müssen und dann hätte man im Wesentlichen die komplette Außenkommunikation gehabt. Und heute wäre ja alles viel komplizierter, wo die Leute ja auf so viele unterschiedlichen Kanälen machen. Da müsste man ja, um überhaupt noch der Sache herzuwerden und so weiter. Das ist auch so ein bisschen diese Geheimdienst-Security-Logik, in der sich sozusagen alles immer nur aus Sicherheit heraus erläutert. Ja, aber das ist doch das super Grundrecht. Das Schlimmste, was es gibt, sind halt Terroranschläge. Und das ist auch irgendwie...
Wie viele Terroranschlagstote hatten wir doch gleich in diesem Land in den letzten zehn Jahren?
Naja, weniger. Und deswegen kannst du ja auch sagen, siehst du mal, was das alles gebracht hat, was wir alles schon wieder verhindert hätten. Weil sonst wären es ja aber Millionen gewesen.
Wenn jetzt noch die fünfstelligen Verkehrstoten, die wir ja produzieren, durch diese Geschwindigkeitsüberwachung reduzieren können, haben wir das auch schon gewonnen.
Mit dem Argument kann man den Leuten auch gleich einen Alkohol-Sensor und einen Geschwindigkeitssensor ins Auto einfallen.
Ich hab gerade jetzt vor drei Tagen in Schweden so ein Auto gesehen mit dem Alkohol-Sensor.
Ja, in den USA gibt es sowas schon lange. Da müssen die Leute reinblasen, bevor das Auto überhaupt angeht. Das gibt es auch seit 20 Jahren. Also ich weiß nicht, wie leicht es sich vor 20 Jahren umgehen ließ. Und ich weiß nicht, wie leicht es heute ist. So, anderes Thema. Aber solche potentielle Because we can und wir scheißen auf die Freiheit, wenn wir nur retten können, das sind einfach solche Gedankenexperimente, die sind kein Science Fiction mehr.
Das ist aber jetzt schon fast alle zu sozialkritisch hier.
Jaja, aber es war ja Roddys Frage, wie gehen wir damit jetzt um?
Ich denke, auf technischer Ebene haben wir da jetzt keine Schnitte. Das ist meine Meinung. Ihr könnt mich vom Gegenteil überzeugen, aber wenn ich heute mit meinem Umfeld umgehe, dann tue ich das in einer Art und Weise, dass ein potentieller Überwacher erstens weiß, mit wem ich umgehe und was ich so mit diesen Leuten so tue. Der Zug ist aus der Halle, deswegen ist die Frage meiner Meinung nach technisch einfach nicht mehr zu lösen.
Kriegen wir ihn überhaupt wieder rein? Kriegen wir ihn überhaupt wieder rein?
Den Zug in die Halle?
Und wenn nicht, schalten wir dann alle in den Modus der Scheiß drauf.
Es ist interessant, dass in dieser ganzen Aluhut-versus-Spakaria-Diskussion, die sich in den letzten zwei Jahren ja so ergötzend vor unseren Augen abgespielt hat, im Prinzip ja beide irgendwie recht behalten haben. Also die Aluhüte mit, das ist alles ganz furchtbar und es findet statt und es müsste ja eigentlich verhindert werden. Und die andere Seite mit, ja, Ihr könnt ja doch nichts machen. Genau.
Seid mal ein bisschen cooler.
Genau, lass uns mal lieber darüber nachdenken, wie wir dann damit umgehen, wenn sowieso alles öffentlich ist. Obwohl ich jetzt auch keine bestechenden Rezepte gesehen habe, wie man denn das jetzt zur Hand haben sollte, aber wir werden auf jeden Fall in irgendeiner Form damit umgehen. Weiß der Geier? Ich meine, vielleicht ist die Zukunft dieses Planeten so eine Art Superschweden.
Superschweden?
Ja, wo einfach alle...
Polizeistaat, wo so alle cool damit sind.
Ja, Singapur. Also irgendwie so ein, ja, jeder hat eine Nummer, alle sind irgendwie registriert. Wir hüpfen auf diesen Planeten rum. Es gibt da so ein paar... Man läuft so im OS mit.
Ich finde es echt krass, wenn ich jetzt kurz mal wieder was... Weil du Schwedenerachtest, kann ich noch mal zwei Sachen einsteuern. Eins hatte ich ja schon mal mitgebracht. Diese Zeitungseiten, wo du nachschlagen kannst, in welchem Wohnviertel, welcher Junggeselle dort wieviel verdient. Nachgehalten aufgestaffelt öffentlich in der Zeitung. Und das andere ist die eben erwähnte Nummer. Die Schweden nutzen das nahenlos, die sogenannte Paar-Schon-Nummer. Deine eigene Unique-ID, da greift auch Kreti und Pleti drauf zu. Wenn du zum Beispiel umziehst, musst du nicht hingehen und deiner Telefongesellschaft, deinem E-Werk oder sonst irgendjemand Bescheid sagen, dass du umziehst. Nein, du meldest dich einfach um. Weil die greifen eh alle auf das Melderegister dauernd zu, um dir die Rechnung zu schicken. Oder wenn du das, äh, oder, keine Ahnung, egal was du machst, du brauchst immer nur einmal. Es gibt eine so eine Behörde, da sagst du, ich ändere jetzt was, ich hab jetzt hier ein Kind mehr oder weniger, oder ich ändere meinen Familienstand, und das warte ich, speichere die ab. Und alle anderen auch Privatunternehmen, mit denen du zu tun hast, ziehen gnadenlos aus dieser Datenbank. Also gerade wie gesagt bei Telefongesellschaften, das krasse, also Mobilfunkgesellschaften, klar, die Telefongesellschaft, die dir in der Leitung liegt, weiß schon, wo sie die Strip hingezogen hat. Aber wenn jetzt wie viele von denen da unten nur noch schnulllos unterwegs bist, ja, dann ziehst du halt einfach um, meldest dich um und innerhalb von Stunden, nicht nach drei Monaten, sondern innerhalb von Stunden, weiß deine Telefongesellschaft, dass du jetzt woanders wohnst. Kann man jetzt so oder so sehen, wie gesagt, bei jemandem...
Ich meine, wir regen uns irgendwie höllisch auf, dass wir, je nachdem, wie unser Business so strukturiert ist, einmal im Jahr bis zu zwölf mal im Jahr, wenn nicht häufiger oder permanent, dem Finanzamt immer wieder sagen muss, was man so getrieben hat wirtschaftlich. Und was ich dann auch denke, habt ihr mich jetzt nicht ausreichend durchleuchtet und überwacht und kann man das nicht sowieso gleich mal bei euch alles einbuchen, damit ich jetzt nicht auch nochmal immer wieder eure Datenbanken mit drin und dann Informationen füttern muss? Und am Ende mit eurem Direktzugriff aufs Konto widerlegt ihr mir das, weil ich technisch, handwerklich nicht in der Lage war, das in der Form durchzuführen, wie es eure Software eigentlich von vornherein hätte machen können.
Das ist ja sowas wie bei Höhenes gar nicht möglich. Und das wollen die sich ja natürlich offen halten.
Was bei Höhenes? Ihnen kriegen oder Ihnen walten lassen?
Ihnen walten lassen.
Ja.
Das heißt, sie brauchen ja so den gewissen Graubereich. Die wollen zwar alles wissen, aber sie wollen es nur benutzen, wenn sie die an Karren wollen.
Die wollen Kompromat.
Genau.
Das ist, glaube ich, das eigentlich schwieriger da dran ist der Begriff Kompromat. Also wenn der Überwacher was über dich weiß, von dem du nicht weißt, dass der Überwacher das weiß von dir. Also wenn die Daten wirklich alle tatsächlich offen wären. Wenn ich jetzt morgen zur, wie heißt die Behörde heutzutage, Birtler Behörde, keine Ahnung, gehen könnte und sage, geben sie mir mal mein Prism-File, was da so alles drin steht, dann hätte ich da vielleicht gar nicht so ein Problem mit, weil dann wüsste ich, was die anderen wissen und dann könnte ich mich vielleicht auch an die entsprechende Stelle wenden und sagen, diese Information ist aber falsch, bitte schön. Das ist so einer der Ansätze, der funktionieren könnte. Aber ich meine, dass das halt irgendwo...
Du benutzt gerade 20 Gigabyte in der NSA Cloud, bitte updaten.
Nur, dass es halt unter irgendeinem Schlapphut verschwindet. Das, was da irgendwann mal irgendwie passiert ist, ich kann mich selber nicht dran erinnern und dann wird es möglicherweise gegen mich verwendet, ist natürlich irgendwie schwierig.
Ja, das ist das, was auch meisten anstinkt. Dass sie irgendwie in fünf oder zehn Jahre später mit irgendwas kommen können. Suchst du einen Job oder willst du irgendwas machen oder sonst wie? Oder Kreditkarte oder Darlehen, Kredit, was für sie kindlich erwartet alles gibt, wo sie irgendwie ein bisschen mehr über einen wissen wollte, dann ziehen sie irgendwelche alten Kamellen aus deiner Vergangenheit, wo du dachtest, das hast du mit abgeschlossen.
Auf der anderen Seite, wir leben in einem Land, wo sich der Wutbürger irgendwie an Google Street View gerieben hat. Also ich meine...
Ja, ist eine tolle dabei.
Das ist wirklich lächerlich.
Ja, da ist halt irgendwie, ich hab's auch nicht so richtig verstanden bis heute.
Das sind auch die selben Typen, die dann rausgehen, wenn du dir erstmal Google Earth zeigst und dann rein soos von oben, die dann fasziniert sagen, oh ist ja geil, warte mal, ich geh mal raus, ich wink mal.
Ja, vielleicht sollte man solche Sachen jetzt nochmal streuen.
Meinst du, man sollte die Leute jetzt richtig wurschtig machen? Weil du vorhin sagtest so geheim und tralala und ex und pipapo und so. Das Tolle ist ja, dass jetzt alle in diesem Geheimdienst paranoia sind mit einem Dienst und einer schlimmer als der andere und einer geheimer als der andere. Mir schon echt ausgemalt habe, wenn mich mal irgendjemand bei irgendwo was anhält oder so ein Polizist, werde ich ihm sagen, ich bin im Einsatz, ich arbeite für einen Dienst, der ist so geheim, dass ich ihm nicht mal sagen kann, wie der heißt. Geh mir aus dem Weg und gröchte mir da Chancen für einen. Nee, ernsthaft, ich meine, guck dir das mal an, es gibt jetzt so viele Player auf dem Markt und einer geheimer als der andere. Also in Amülant geht das bestimmt. Die haben das ja schon seit Jahren, dass die spielen dann immer so, immer so geheimdienst Trumpf.
Du musst es wahrscheinlich eleganter einleiten. Ja, wenn der Polizist kommt, schaust du ihn einfach an und sagst, äh... Kuhren! Die blaue Maus auf dem Berg. Die blaue Maus auf dem Berg! Bewegen sie sich! Mit was für Anfängern müssen wir hier zusammenarbeiten? Wie sollen wir unsere Mission erfüllen? Sie gefährden den Einsatz.
Es gab übrigens, du wirst lachen, es gab übrigens...
Bleiben wir hin, haben wir jetzt ein Sendungsziel.
Es gab wirklich sowas. Vielleicht haben wir Polizisten unter unseren Hörern, die zumindest mal den grundsätzlichen Ding akten können. Also gab es auf jeden Fall Ende der 18er, Anfang der 90er Jahre. So fall der Mauer rum und man weiß noch nicht, wer, wo und immer. Es gab dort zivile Fahrzeuge, also in Deutschland, die bestimmte Güter transportiert haben, zum Beispiel Kryptomaterial und so. Unter anderem im Dienst des Außenministeriums, daher weiß ich das. Und die hatten eine Markierung drauf auf dem Auto. Und wenn so ein Ding in einem Unfall verwickelt war und die Polizisten das gesehen haben, dann gab es strengste Anweisungen, weder das Auto noch sonst etwas anzufassen, das Gelände abzuriegeln und bestimmte Leute anzurufen. So nach dem Motto Finger weg. Meinetwegen darfst du ein paar Verletzte rausziehen, aber das Auto fasst du nicht an, sondern rufst da und dort diese Nummer an und dann machen wir das klar. Ich weiß jetzt, das kann ich jetzt sagen, das ist jetzt so viele Jahre her. Ich hatte damals auch mit Krypto-Zeugs zu tun aus dem Ostenministerium. Die haben halt so Krypto-Maschinen mit diesen Autos durch die Gegend gefahren. Und kennen die Markierungen nicht, aber irgendwie muss die bekannt gewesen sein. Wie gesagt, vielleicht gibt es ja Polizisten, die das bestätigen können, diese Nummer. Also jetzt kommt es in dieselbe Richtung, dass es so für bestimmt, ich kann auch für Gefahrgute, es gibt bestimmt Markierungen an Autos, die auch bekannt sind. Aber es gibt halt eben auch eine für Finger weg, geheimdienstliches Material. Ruf mal jemanden an, der Ahnung davon hat.
Du meinst auch mit so einem orange Ding und dann so zwei Nummern, 99 0.
Oben ein Schlapphut, unten eine Lupe.
Genau. Aber das fand ich ein bisschen creepy.
Na ja, also, Gott sei Dank haben wir ja die Piratenpartei, die uns vor größeren Auswirkungen retten wird. Voraussichtlich, hab ich gehört, jetzt total hip, auch irgendwie in der Hacker-Szene. Ich war ja auch in Holland irgendwie, da war das auch ein Gesprächsthema. Crypto-Parties, und jetzt müssen wir allen erklären, wie GPG funktioniert.
Wo ist diese Taste für Crickets und Tumblemeats? Ihr wollt so eine Taste haben, bitte. Ist geil, oder?
Ich meine, seit 30 Jahren bin ich irgendwie mehr oder weniger Teil dieser Szene.
Darf ich ein bisschen angeben?
Das ist das wiederkehrende Mem. Bitte, immer, Dennis.
Mein PGP-Schlüssel ist von Oktober 94.
Du meinst, du bräuchst mal einen neuen Schlüssel?
Ich hab auch neue Ressorts, nicht? Aber mein erster ist von Oktober 94. Ich hab eine Amiga erstellt mit PGP.
Und wie viele verschlüsselte Nachrichten hast du so geschickt seitdem?
Nicht mal ein Dutzend.
Also eine alle zwei Jahre sozusagen.
Ja, also nicht mal ein Dutzend.
Ja, das ist das Problem. Weil mit verschlüsselter Mail ist es so ein bisschen wie mit Mail an sich so am Anfang. Also ich hatte auch schon sehr früh eine Mail-Adresse, aber es hat halt viele Jahre gedauert.
Nicht am Anfang. Es funktioniert für manche Leute heute noch nicht.
Funktioniert für heute nicht. Heute noch nicht.
Ja, also meine Schwiegereltern zum Beispiel haben da immer wieder Probleme mit dubioser Natur.
Womit jetzt? Mit Mail an sich?
Ja, dass sie nicht verschicken können oder dass sie nicht empfangen können.
Ja, aber ihr wisst ja, was ich meine. Und jetzt kommt halt immer wieder so dieses Ding mit, na ja, wenn man es den Leuten nur erklärt oder wenn dann endlich mal eine Software daherkommt, mit der es dann einfach genug ist oder noch schlimmer mit, die Leute sind ja zu doof dazu. Was schreist du da hinten? Ja, ich weiß, dass es alles nichts nützt.
Nützt nichts, hat er ja gesagt.
Das ist alles Quatsch und irgendwie Blödsinn und das wird halt auch nichts dazu beitragen, dass irgendwas besser wird. Die Frage ist, was könnte denn dazu beitragen, dass irgendwas besser wird? Weil es ist ja jetzt nicht komplett unmöglich, sich Systeme zu denken, in der Verschlüsselung tatsächlich allgegenwärtig wäre, wenn denn nur die Infrastruktur dafür aufgebaut werden müsste. Also ich appelliere jetzt nicht an das Wissen des Einzelnen.
Ja, aber der Einzelne muss auf seinen eigenen Schlüssel aufpassen. Damit fängt es schon an. Wenn ich lese, dass es Leute gibt, oder Zertifikatshersteller oder Webmail-Betreiber, die DNS-Mime-Key generieren, und Zertifikat mit Key dazu generieren, dann ist das schon, die Leute darauf abfahren, ist das schon vorbei.
Ich hab's auch nicht verstanden.
Denn Key generierst du immer selber. Auf gar keinen Fall lässt du jemand anders einen Key für dich generieren. Du lässt dir das Zertifikat von irgendjemanden unterschreiben. Lässt dir auch gerne das Zertifikat ausstellen. Aber deinen Key erzeugst du selber. In dem Moment, wo dir jemand anders einen Key erzeugt, dein Webmail-Betreiber, woher weißt du, dass er sich dir nicht noch abspeichert? Was du wahrscheinlich sogar noch tun in dem guten Glauben, ihnen dir wiedergeben zu können, falls du deinen verbummelst, damit du deine alten Mails noch lesen kannst.
Deswegen kauft man seine Haustürschlüssel ja auch nicht beim Schlossladen, wo der Typ weiß, wo man wohnt, aber fährt irgendwo hin, wo man dich bekannt ist.
Ja, ne, aber auch dann. Also wie gesagt, damit fängt es schon an. Und das Problem ist, dass du solche, dass du die grundlegenden Ideen, die dahinter stecken, irgendwie in den Autonormalbürgers Kopf rein kriegen musst, und das schaffst du nicht. Die ganzen Mechanismen, die installieren und so, das gibt es alles. Und wenn du in dem Apple-Universum lebst, wirklich mit S-Mime zu arbeiten, das ist ein fucking No-Brain-er. Aber es macht alles keinen Sinn, wenn irgendwelche Dienstleister hergehen, die dir Keys und Zertifikate generieren und die dir mit noch so lustigen JavaScripten auf deinem Rechner installieren oder sonst irgendwas. Dann ist der Drop schon gelöst, dann kannst du das auch sein lassen. Und die Infrastruktur, wie gesagt, dafür gibt es nur, was es nicht gibt, ist ein ordentliches System, um Keys zu generieren, Keys aufzubewahren, weil das Desaster ja auch groß ist, und normal war, kriegt man ja nicht mal geregelt, seine Urlaubsfotos ordentlich abzuspeichern, ohne dass jeder Fünfte von denen irgendwie die gelegentlich verbummelt. Wenn du diesen Private Key, der so wahnsinnig heilig ist, verbummelt, es denn wartet auch, dann kannst du deine ganzen alten E-Mails nicht mehr lesen, und all so'n Scheiß. Das heißt, die Leute fangen wieder an, Infrastrukturen zu bauen und darum rumzugehen, oder nur an bestimmter Stelle zu verschlüsseln und dann wieder Trust-Relationships zu machen. Man ist ja jetzt schon so, da guckst du, dass dein Mail-Verkehr von dir zu deinem Provider geht in der Regel verschlüsselt. Ich wüsste jetzt keinen mehr, der einen SMTP-Server hat, der nicht Start-TLS kann. Das heißt, also dein Mail-Client geht ja hin und spricht ja mit einem Mail-Server, glaubt dem sowieso erstmal, jeder Zertifikat, was der vorweist, ist auch vollkommen egal, macht ein bisschen Krypto auf der Leitung und das heißt, du kannst ja sagen, meine Mail geht verschlüsselt zu deinem Provider. Der nimmt sie auseinander und schickt sie eventuell wieder über eine verschlüsselte SMTP.
Die Mail selbst nicht, ist verschlüsselt, sondern der Transportweg.
Aber du weißt, dass es ja diese Cisco-Switches gibt, die per Default einfach da an der Stelle, wo Start-TLS steht, einfach das Sternchen hinmachen und deswegen keine Krypto-Verbindung zustande kommt?
Das gibt es auch, das sind nämlich nicht Switches, aber das kannst du auch spielen. Man kann sowas auch verhindern, weil es ja zum Beispiel auch so, dass die E-Mail Clients stehen in einem Default-Modus, wenn man sie aus der Kiste nimmt, stehen die so, dass sie sagen, wenn der drüben verschlüsseln kann, mach ich's, aber wenn der nicht kann, dann ist mir das auch egal. Das heißt, man muss nur über wie auch immer geartete Methoden dafür sorgen, dass der Client nicht glaubt, dass der Gegenüber verschlüsseln kann, dann ist gut.
Ich meinte jetzt die Kommunikation zwischen zwei.
Ja, sag ich ja, aber du kannst aber dein Client auch sagen, ich möchte, dass es auf jeden Fall verschlüsselt ist. Wenn es nicht verschlüsselt ist, dann machst du das nicht. Aber Client Mail-Server ist genau dasselbe. Ich könnte auch meinem Ex-Mail-Server auch sagen, du redest nur mit Leuten, wo du TLS kannst. Aber auch dann, wie gesagt, ist wieder die Frage, woher kann ich denn dem drüben mit seinem Zertifikat glauben. Weil diese ganze Struktur ist ja nur auch schon tot. Auch lange vor Prism und Schieß mich tot. Nachdem jetzt reihenweise die CAs hier fallen sind. Und das ist übrigens auch ja passiert in den letzten Wochen, diese nette kleine Idee, dass man entdeckt, dass Microsoft Windows schon seit Jahren RUT-Zertifikate, die man nicht kennt, einfach bei Microsoft nachlädt. Ungefragt. Und sie auch ungefragt installiert. Und selbst wenn man sie rauslöscht, sie auch ungefragt immer wieder neu installiert. Spätestens damit ist diese ganze Zertifikatsgeschichte mit RUT-CAs, also mit vertrauenswürdigen Zertifizierungsstellen, komplett für'n Arsch. Ist jetzt schon länger, aber jetzt muss es auch jedem Horst auffallen, dass du jetzt in die Dornen treten kannst. Die Technik, die Kryptotechnik, die da drunter liegt, mag immer noch okay sein, aber diese ganze wem traue ich und wem traue ich wie und wem lasse ich welche Zertifikat wie unterschreiben oder sowas ist leider ein bisschen...
Das war jetzt die Langfassung von, also technisch sehe ich da jetzt keine Möglichkeit, sich gegen den Scheiß zu wehren.
Ich denke mir halt immer noch, habe ich glaube ich in der letzten Sende schon gefragt, gesagt, solange ich, solange die höchstwahrscheinlich sowieso Zugriff auf meine Hardware haben, also auf, ja, OS X ist wahrscheinlich offen wie ein Jointor, iOS auch, also für die NSA jedenfalls, dann kann ich auch mit Streamer so viel verschlüsseln, wie ich will, dann kann es vielleicht unterwegs keiner lesen, weil da ist alles perfekt, aber zur Not hüpfen die auf mein Gerät und lassen sich alle meine Keys...
Na du machst halt deinen Backup eh in die iCloud irgendwie, da sind sie dann deine ganzen...
Aber ich könnte jetzt, weil es sowieso egal ist eigentlich, weil sie haben es ja eh.
Was ist denn das hier eigentlich? Was ist das jetzt neu? Ja, ich weiss, aber das ist irgendwie...
Das ist geil, oder?
Gummibärchen mit Bruddel.
Vostok heißt das.
Ich kenne dieses andere, das war du da, was da so ein bisschen komisch aussieht, aber diese Gummibärchen-Variante Doppelgranatapfel kannte ich noch nicht.
Gummibärchen, ich hab Tannenwald.
Das kann ich aber halt, das ist Gummibärchen hier.
Schmeckt auch ein bisschen nach Tannenwald.
Komisch, heißt Tannenwald und schmeckt danach.
Steht ja auch drauf. Naja, mit so einem modernen russischen Rotkäppchen da vorne drauf.
Ich auch, die guckt mir aber ein bisschen zu böse.
Russkäppchen.
Die schaut einfach sehr entschlossen, ne? Das ist der Blick des Russ, wenn der Amerikaner kommt.
Zum Thema Russen auf den Weg hierher, bin ich an einem Laster von einer Spedition namens Vodka vorbeigefahren. Im Transport ist ja klar, was die transportieren.
Ich finde den Gedanken an sich ganz interessant, dass man eigentlich... Naja, ich will es nicht so sagen, hat ja alles keinen Sinn mit dem Verschlüsseln. Soweit würde ich jetzt nicht gehen, weil es gibt ja auch noch ein paar andere Feinde als immer nur die Geheimdienste. Und wenn die halt dann doch mit mir selbst jetzt nicht so beschäftigt sind, dann kann ich ja gegen die anderen immer noch was machen.
Ja, aber die Frage war ja nicht, ob man überhaupt verschlüsseln kann, sondern du hast ja angefangen, gibt es Krypto for the masses?
Genau.
Die Leute, die ohnehin schon zu doof sind, meistens Mails zu schreiben oder ihren Mails aber richtig einzustellen, denen wird es jetzt noch überhelfen, wie sie das mit der Krypto gebacken kriegen.
Okay, lass mir mal ein anderes Szenario machen. Angenommen, gehen wir mal davon aus, DNSSEC, also kryptografisch abgesicherte DNS-Auskünfte, gibt es überall. Ich gehe davon ausgehend. Weil die Zeit wird kommen, ich weiß nicht, wie du das jetzt so einschätzt, wie weit das so ist.
Ich hab gerade eine Woche ITF-Meeting hinter mir zu diesem Thema, aber erzähl mal weiter.
Ja, okay, gut. Also gehen wir mal davon aus, das wäre jetzt, sagen wir mal, so ganz normal, wie ich da überhaupt Adressen eintragen kann, kann ich jetzt im Prinzip auch sagen, so hier verschlüssel mal diese ganze, also wer das nicht weiß, DNS ist ja dieses Auskunftssystem, wo man halt Namen in irgendwas anderes auflösen kann, unter anderem auch in Adressen. Meistens Adressen, aber eben auch andere Sachen. Und so könnte man ja unter seiner Domain auch mal andere Sachen bereitlegen als nur IP-Adressen. Weil wenn jetzt zum Beispiel jemand mit mir HTTPS machen möchte, also mir im Sinne von mit meinem Server, dann fragt er ja ohnehin schon DNS, gib mal die Adresse. Und dann verbindet er sich mit dieser Adresse und dann wird so over the wire in einem mühsamen Protokoll da irgendwie ein Key-Exchange gemacht. Man könnte ja dann sozusagen diesen Key, um den es geht, auch gleich im DNS hinterlegen. Und sagen so hier, das ist mein Public Key.
Wird aber nicht gemacht.
Nö, wird nicht gemacht.
Kannst du auch nicht machen derzeit mit den derzeitigen Protokollen, die da envisiert sind. Das ist doch nicht im Plano.
Ja gut, das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage gewesen. Wo geht die Reise hin? Aber ich könnte mir das jetzt technisch durchaus vorstellen, dass man sowas bauen kann. Es muss Technologie sein, die in Browser eingebaut wird, dass Browser einfach auf eine andere Art und Weise verschlüsselte Verbindungen herstellen, als sie das bisher getan haben.
Aber nicht nur Browser, auch dein E-Mail-Client, dein Chat-Client, dein Fire-Transfer-Client, dein Dropbox-Sync oder dein Xbox-Sync.
Also jegliche Internetkommunikation müsste grundsätzlich eigentlich immer verschlüsselt sein. Gehen wir mal davon aus, dass sie immer verschlüsselt wäre. Oder ich zumindest problemlos, ohne mich jetzt auf irgendwelche obskuren Zertifikatsautoritäten, irgendwelche Briefkastenunternehmen in Südafrika einlassen müsste, die mir dann, obwohl sie mich gar nicht kennen, mir irgendeine Originalität attestieren. Sondern ich erzeug mir einfach, wie du so schön sagtest, Schlüssel erzeugt man selbst, ich erzeug die selbst, beziehungsweise das Paar, tu halt meinen privaten Schlüssel so sicher, wie das irgendwie geht, auf meinen Server. Das ist ja auch noch mal so ein Angriffsvektor. Aber vor allem nutze ich eben diese DNS-Infrastruktur, um einfach alle verbindungsgradig zu machen.
Aber mit DNS, das heißt, da muss die Antwort immer vom originalen DNS kommen oder vom authoritative DNS oder wie läuft das? Weil cache'n geht ja nicht mehr wirklich, oder?
Doch, cache'n kannst du.
Woher weißt du, dass da der richtige Key kommt?
Weil das natürlich die Unterschrift mitcached.
Weil das signiert ist.
Und woher kennst du die schon?
Von dem Root wird das halt...
Das ist das Problem. Das heißt, du fängst jetzt nicht mal an irgendwelche südafrikanischen Booten zu trauen, deren Root-Zertifikat in deinem Browser rumlungert, sondern das heißt, du fängst jetzt an, der Root-Authoritative zu trauen.
Die tendenziell in Amerika ist und damit 100% vertrauenswürdig.
Das sind schon irgendwelche Icon-Fuzzies, die da rummachen. Gibt jetzt auch demnächst wieder eine Key-Signing-Procedure. Die machen voll den Affen. Könnt ihr euch übrigens angucken? Gibt es denn Live-Web-Streams, wo ihr dann sehen könnt, wie sich denn irgendwelche Leute in irgendwelchen Räumen versammeln und obskure Sachen auf irgendwelchen Laptops tippen? Weil das sind alle die Keys, die dafür machen. Das sind Rechner, die nie am Netz waren und auch nie ans Netz gehen, sondern die generieren dort irgendwelche Keys und transferieren die mit irgendwelchen anderen Methoden dann in ihre Server rein und dann verstecken sie den Laptop wieder irgendwo. Da gibt es ganz lustige Key-Signing-Procedures, Key-Signing-Parties, findet jetzt demnächst wieder statt, weil es demnächst wieder einen Root-Key-Rollover gibt. Aber ja, dann musst du dem trauen. Dem Root-Key-Betreibern.
Ja gut, aber das ist schon mal...
Und allen dazwischen, ne?
Ja gut, aber das reduziert sich sozusagen dann auch wirklich auf diese eine Infrastruktur, wo sich dann ja vielleicht mal die Welt ein wenig kümmern könnte, dass man die möglichst transparent hinbekommt.
Das versuchen sie ja.
Ja gut, aber da gibt es natürlich Leute, die...
Worauf ich nicht hinaus will, ist ein Weg, wie wir jetzt dann doch eine Methode finden, wie wir allem entgehen können. Ich will jetzt hier nicht auf die Zauberformel hinaus, ich bin total verschlüsselt und ihr nicht, Edge-Batch, ihr kriegt mich gar nicht, sondern ich wollte eigentlich nur darauf hinaus, dass es, ob es nicht vielleicht anstrebt oder sich abzeichnen könnte vielleicht, dass es eine Möglichkeit gäbe, dass man so eine Art Default-Krypto von allen macht, mit nicht allzu wackeligen Strukturen, die einfach in so einer massiven Nutzung von Kryptographie resultiert, dass das eben so mit diesem Full-Take nicht mehr jetzt so ein easy-peasy-Game ist, wie das derzeit ist.
Das war ja mal die Vision, diese IPSEC, was ja heute benutzt wird, also IPSEC, was ja in V4 für diverse VPN-Geschichten benutzt wird, ist ja mal eine Erfindung gewesen, die aus der IPv6-Entwicklung mitkam. Und das war ja mal die Vision mit, dass wir sagen, wir bauen mal so was mit ein, dass jeder hier mit jedem direkt peer-to-peer verschlüsseln kann. Über Schlüsselaustausch machen wir uns dann hier und da und dort Gedanken. Es gibt verschiedene Proposes, es gibt auch Proposes, wie man IPSEC Keys oder sowas auch über DNS verteilt. Sind alle in welche Drafts oder sowas, die nie irgendwie Früchte getragen haben. Das heißt, die Idee gab es schon mal. Aber es wird auf der anderen Seite übrigens auch gerade wieder kaputt gemacht. Ein großes Thema war jetzt auf dem ITF-Meeting DNSSEC natürlich mit allen seinen Varianten. Es gab auch Leute, die schöne Hacks vorgeführt haben, wie man mit derzeitigen Infrastrukturen DNSSEC betrügen kann. Also da andere Schlüssel vorgeben kann und so weiter und so fort. Okay, das kann man jetzt nochmal wieder fixen, war jetzt nicht dramatisch, aber derzeit haben sie auch schon mehr Löcher eingepallert. Und das nächste Problem ist, dass es derzeit sehr, sehr wichtige Aktionen gibt, die gerade anlaufen, nämlich zur Ablösung von V4 durch V6, die das derzeitige DNSSEC Schema umbringen. Es gibt nämlich zum Beispiel durchaus Gründe, warum dich ein Nameserver belügen können muss in der Transitionsphase von V4 nach V6. Und in dem Moment wurde DNSSEC drauf, fast kann er dich nicht mehr belügen. Das heißt, das Netz funktioniert nicht mehr. In dem Moment geht wieder Convenience vor Security und die Leute werden wieder DNSSEC sagen, dass die ignorieren mal und weg ist. Es gibt einen Mechanismus, einen Transitionsmechanismus, der teilweise auch schon praktiziert wird. Nämlich der berühmte NAT64. Das heißt, du gibst dem User nur noch eine V6-Adresse. Und wenn er auf die dumme Idee kommt, auf eine Webseite zuzugreifen oder auf irgendeinen Dienst zuzugreifen, der nur V4 hat, dann lügt man ihm dafür DNS, anstelle der V4-Adresse, also dieses A-Rackord im DNS, lügt man ihm eine Quad-Adresse vor, damit er die erreichen kann, weil dieser besagte User nur noch V6 hat und dann gibt es ein großes Carrier-Grade-Nut-Device, das diese V6-Verbindung, die der User eröffnet, in eine V4-Verbindung umsetzt. Und da muss man im DNS rumlügen. Haben wir ausprobiert, auf dem ITF-Medien gab es da ein Wireless-Laden, das so betrieben wurde. War sehr lustig, mal sein iPhone oder diverse Geräte darauf einzubuchen. War auch teilweise echt peinlich. Gerade für die Firma Apple dramatisch peinlich. Ja, also das iPhone macht so ein paar Sachen und Browser geht, aber ein paar andere Sachen, zum Beispiel iMessage geht gar nicht. Und zwar so auf ganz obskure Weise. iMessage zum Beispiel sagt nicht, dass es nicht geht, oder nicht will, oder nicht kann, sondern der Send-Button ist einfach nicht mehr drückbar. Du gehst in deine iMessage rein, tippst da eine Nachricht ein, willst die absenden und der Send-Button ist grau.
Interessant, auf der Omen hast du übrigens auch einen Nade 6.4 W-Laden, das hab ich auch mal ausprobiert.
Wenn du mal so ein paar Sachen ausprobierst dort. Manches ging nicht. Und das ist wirklich echt peinlich, weil man muss sich richtig anstrengen dafür, um das kaputt zu machen. Und da ist noch ein bisschen Bewegung. Und wie gesagt, derzeit geht convenience for security. Das heißt, all diese Mechanismen, die ganzen Dienste, Facetube muss gehen. Ich hab ja immer schon mal den Ausspruch gebracht, solange RTL noch sendet und McDonalds noch Futter ausliefert, findet keine Revolution statt. Inzwischen muss man das erweitern, um solange Facebook noch erreichbar ist. Aber das heißt, du ernsthaft?
Naja und YouTube natürlich.
Ich glaube ernsthaft, es gab vor ein paar Jahren...
Wenn YouTube nicht mehr funktioniert, dann geht bei uns zuhause mein Sohn an die Wand.
Wie gesagt, und Facebook.
Die Farbe fällt nicht weit vom Stamm.
Nur um mal zu erklären, wie der Mensch draußen so ist.
Das iPad.
Vor ein paar Jahren hat mal irgendjemand ein Glasfaserkabel in der Herrstraße ausgebuddelt mit einem Bagger, wo er nicht hätte sollen. Dadurch war der West-Starken in der Hochausiegelung.
Dann ist die Kriminalitätsrate gestiegen in der Zeit.
Die Leute haben in ihrer Panik, weil ihr Kabelfernsehen nicht mehr ging, den Notruf angerufen. Die haben echt 112 angerufen. Weil sie haben die Störungsstelle der Telekom über Stunden weg. Wenn 30.000 Leute versuchen, alle zu melden, dass ihr Fernsehen nicht geht, geht dann natürlich nichts mehr. Dann waren die Leute so kaputt, dass ihr Fernsehen nicht ging und dass sie sich nirgendwo beschweren konnten. Und das ernsthaft, massenhaft, und zwar nicht bloß einer, sondern richtig so hunderte Packweise 112 angerufen haben. Und genauso wird es enden. Wenn hier mal Facebook ausgeht oder sonst irgendwas, dann werden die Leute die Feuerwehr anrufen. Da warte ich drauf auf die Meldung.
Die geht ja dann auch nicht.
Sogar die Döner am Cotty haben geschlossen. Auf den Straßen wird geschossen. Zitat aus dem wunderbaren Lied. Wie heißt das? Der Untergang? Nein, nicht der Untergang. Das verwechsel ich gerade. Von Icke und er ans großes Kino. Da wird geschildert, wie Berlin untergeht. Das ist ganz, ganz toll. Sogar die Döner am Cotty haben geschlossen.
Dann weißt du, dann ist alles zu spät.
Ich finde das ja cool. Die Artdiskussion hatte ich mir auch in etwa vorgestellt, auch wenn ich dachte, man würde nicht ganz so früh scheitern.
Geht ja noch was, man kann die immer noch ärgern.
Ja, aber warum hat so ein iPhone nicht serienmäßig für mich ein S-MIME-Zertifikat, das ich verschlüsselt E-Mail automatisch mache?
Mit welchem Schlüssel? Es hat die S-MIME drauf, aber mit welchem Schlüssel? Und den zu deiner Sicherheit erstmal in deinem iCloud-Account abspeichern.
Naja, es wäre schon was anderes. Tatsächlich tut das iPhone das ja für iMessage. Nein, ist so.
Das erzeugt dauernd irgendwelche Schlüsse. Aber wer weiß wo die hin speichern.
Das wäre durchaus auch machbar, zumindest für Apples iCloud-Service könnten sie das tun. Ich meine Vertrauenswürdigkeit und so eine andere Frage, aber...
Meinst du nicht, dass die NSA auch Lobbyarbeit macht?
Macht das mal nicht? Ich frage mich eh noch mal, was Apples Rolle in dem Spiel gerade ist. Ich meine, Google, Facebook haben wir jetzt viel gehört. Bei Apple wird nur viel gemunkelt.
Da Apple, würde ich jetzt mal behaupten, die Smartphone-Welle losgetreten hat. Klar gab es schon vorher und so weiter. Aber ich würde schon sagen, die Androids kamen doch ein bisschen später, haben die meisten Leute diese iOS-Devices benutzt. Und natürlich, das was am meisten benutzt wird, da haben die doch ein Auge drauf im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und dann haben die dann irgendwie gesagt, ey Jungs, hier gibt es keine Fördergelder mehr, wenn er da zu sicher macht oder so. Kann man ja ganz legal erpressen.
Ganz legal erpressen.
Oder sie gehen da zum Obama und sagen, ey, hier...
Samsung-Patent.
Genau, ist doch so. Ihr macht uns schön irgendwie, lasst schön unseren Zugang offen und macht die Krypto, sodass wir da noch mitlesen können, für einen guten Zweck und wir machen mal ein bisschen Veto für euch.
Du kannst auch deine Krypto total heavy machen, aber machst halt einfach deinen Zufahrtszahngenerator ein bisschen schwächer, als er sein könnte.
Na wieder soll Krypto bis zum Abwinken machen und am besten soll er sich auch noch was eigenes zusätzlich einfallen lassen. Weil es ist vielleicht nicht voll sicher, aber dann muss er trotzdem erstmal fummeln.
Und sie zukacken. Ich glaube, das ist momentan die einzige Chance, aber das macht natürlich keiner und das erzeugt natürlich auch diversen Kollateralschaden in den Netzen. Aber ich glaube, das wäre noch eine technische Möglichkeit, sie so sehr mit falschen Daten oder irgendwelchen Quack zuzuhämmern, dass sie halt wirklich nicht mehr abspeichern können bzw. dass sie dann halt wirklich Nadel im Steck... Stecknerhaufen?
Naja, man bräuchte eigentlich so Software in seinem Router, der wenn sozusagen das Netz gerade für nichts benutzt wird, die ganze Zeit irgendwelche verschlüsselte Kommunikation an irgendwelche Orte schickt.
Wird sich die Tierkommnummer freuen.
Ich würde gleich so ein Tor-Exit-Lot aufmachen.
Ich würde schon die Maße gab, dass die Drottel-Line nur deshalb erforderlich ist, weil sie irgendwann den Traffic nicht mehr mit dem Arm abkommen soll. Aber das hast du ja schon eingangs überlegt. Daran liegt es nicht. Das ist wahrscheinlich doch eher die Doofheit.
Also nochmal, man könnte hingehend die Leute wirklich, man könnte in der Schule zum Beispiel Kids mal grundsätzlich was beibringen. Und zwar nur die Grundprinzipien, gar nicht das mathematische Tralala, sondern die Grundprinzipien von Verschlüsselung. Was ist ein privater Schlüssel? Was ist ein öffentlicher Schlüssel? Das habe ich auch schon ganz anderen Leuten nochmal beibringen. Ja, nicht eingehen darauf, wie die berechnet werden oder wie auch immer. Aber dass die Prinzipien dahinter klar sind. Was kann man damit machen? Welche Reihenfolge, was mit dem verschlüsselt wird, kannst du nur mit dem entschlüsseln und andersrum. Und die Reihenfolge ist egal.
Ja, aber die Mathematik, die verstehst du doch sowieso nur nach 20 Jahren Mathematik studieren.
Deswegen musst du den gar nicht erzählen. Sondern du gehst halt eben hin und sagst, pass mal auf, das sind einfach nur die Properties von diesen Dingern. Das müsste mal jetzt ein paar Mathematiker auf dir glauben, dass das so ist. Sorry. Aber das sind die Eigenschaften von Public Key Encryption. Und achtet bitte darauf, dass wenn ihr das benutzt, und euch würde taktiklich irgendwo begegnen, wo kommen die Keys her, wer hat die erzeugt, wer hat die Kontrolle darüber. Das sind schon mal ganz simple Sachen. Ich finde, das müsste noch möglich sein. Ob man das jetzt noch Leuten wie mir oder meinem Vater noch eingeprügelt kriegt, weiß ich nicht. Aber so weit kann man den Kids in der Schule erzählen. Könnte man. Wenn es da Lehrer gäbe, die auch nur einen Funken einer Ahnung davon hätten.
Mach nicht noch so ein Fass auf.
Oh, ja stimmt, sorry.
Ja gut, das kann man ihnen schwer vorwerfen.
Nicht das Fass aufmachen, bitte.
Ja, das wäre aber jetzt trotzdem, wie gesagt, da gäbe es Möglichkeiten.
Aber ich gebe dir Recht, also gerade dieses grundsätzliche Verständnis, was ist ein Krypto und was ist asymmetrische Krypto, was ist asymmetrische Krypto, wie ist das mit den Schlüsseln und so, das ist schon was.
Diffy Helm & Key Exchange zum Beispiel ist eine ganz simple Methode, kann man in drei Sätzen sehr lustig erklären. Ja, aber okay, muss man halt mal machen. Und wie gesagt, gar nicht in die Mathematik rein, das will keiner wissen. Ja, das alte RS-ALS, das verstehe ich noch, aber die Russen mit ihren elliptischen Kurven, das geht mir jetzt auch so ein bisschen ab. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, bin ich zu alt für. Des übrigens noch das Interessante dabei, das gibt ja immer eine Gegenbewegung dazu, die meisten Krypto-Geschichten kommen ja mehr oder weniger aus den USA oder aus so einem israelischen USA-Gemenge irgendwie. Es gibt aber auch die Kollegen...
Na, hier ist es aus Belgien...
.in Russland.
Aber wer hat zugelassen und gesagt, das ist okay?
Gibt noch die Kollegen in Russland, und da muss man wirklich sagen, die sind ja da auch knallhart. Putin und Co. haben ja zum Beispiel gesagt, ja, ihr dürft weiterhin welchen Techno-Quatsch nach Russland importieren, aber wenn das Krypto kann, muss das auch unsere Krypto können. Also elliptische Kurven. Wenn ihr mir eine Kiste anbringt, die nur RSA kann, dann lasst das bitte draußen.
So wie mit GLONASS. Ja, das war die andere Nummer. Ich finde ja, die Europäer sollten das mit Galileo auch so machen.
Also vielleicht auch, aber ich glaube, die Europäer haben Angst. Egal, anderes Thema.
Die haben Angst. Siehst du daran, dass die Präsidentenmaschine von den Bolivianer da runtergekommen sind?
Was ich noch nicht ganz verstehe, ist, warum sich immer noch die Industrie, die Wirtschaft da nicht beschwert. Weil es geht ja auch im großen Stil um Wirtschaftsspionage. Weil es geht ja auch schließlich ums Geldverdienen. Weil es kostet ja auch alles, was die Amis da machen. Weil die machen das ja nicht zum Spaß. Also nur um Terroristen geht es ja wohl kaum, weil da muss halt Geld reinkommen.
Also was ich so höre ist, dass sie das tun.
Das beschweren?
Naja, das Dumme ist, wir haben halt jetzt gerade Wahl. Und da werden halt alle Karten, oder nicht alle Karten, aber manche Karten werden halt neu gemischt. So wie wir wissen.
Manche.
Na klar, manches hängt einfach davon ab, ob nun die CDU an der Macht bleibt oder nicht.
Wir haben keine Wahl in Deutschland diesbezüglich.
Manche Karten werden neu gemischt.
Ja, aber die Karten, über die wir gerade reden, werden nicht neu gemischt. Egal ob die Konservativen oder die Verräterpartei, die machen alle den SEM-Scheiß. Und die Einzigen, die vielleicht eine Idee hätten, das anders zu machen, haben nicht den Hauch einer Chance, auch nur irgendwas zu gewinnen davon.
Es gibt aber bestimmt Firmen, die bei der SPD 20% weniger Schnitte machen als bei der CDU. Und das ist dann halt auch relevante Kohle. Wie auch immer. Ich sage ja nur, hinter den Mikrofonen, jenseits der öffentlichen Bühnen, sozusagen hinter den Kulissen, wird da schon das große Fragezeichen in den Raum gesetzt. Sag mal, hier irgendwie Industriespionage, Abschnäucheln von Patentinformationen, von geheimen Plänen, von Expansions- und Auslandsstrategien. Geht's noch?
Ja, also das darf nicht zulassen werden. Das ist ja alles für den Kampf gegen Terrorismus.
Ja, aber dann sagen die, wir scheißen.
Terrorismus, weil die kaufen auch unsere Autos.
Ja gut, aber Terrorismus ist jetzt nur für Privatmenschen als Argumentation. Der Industrie ist Terrorismus scheißegal. Wahrscheinlich. Ja, sondern da geht's einfach um pinke. Und Geld ist einfach mal wichtiger. Ich meine, beim Terrorismus geht's auch nur um Geld. Ist auch nur eine Industrie. Und diese Tendenz gibt es nicht. Naja, ist ja so.
Titel für die Sendung. Terroris-muss. Kannst du doch gar nicht schreiben denn. Ist auch nur. Was hast du gesagt? Scheiße.
Geht's auch nur um Geld. Ist kein Titel. Du bringst mich ganz aus der Spur. Was soll ich denn jetzt eigentlich noch mal. Jetzt wollte ich das gerade zu Glorios zu Ende führen. Ich sage nur, wenn man die Debatte noch ein bisschen mehr auf diesen wirtschaftlichen Aspekt bekommt, dann ändern sich da auch schon die Vorzeichen. Nur, dass derzeit halt wegen Wahlkampf keiner daran wirklich jetzt ein Interesse hat, die Vorzeichen grundsätzlich zu ändern, weil halt alle so ein bisschen in ihrem Machterhaltszwang. Fest getackert sind. Naja, ich wollte auf irgendwas hinaus, aber ich habe jetzt vergessen, was es war. Wollen wir jetzt mal über praktische...
Vielleicht wollten Sie Alterssinnidität ins Spiel bringen.
Bitte? Ja, wollen wir mal irgendwie konkretere Maßnahmen...
Müssen wir mal wieder über Max reden. Nein, gibt eh nichts zu reden. Guck, wir können alle in den Urlaub fahren. Nichts passiert in Appeland.
Gut, ich meine, man kann ja schon diverse Dinge tun, um jetzt nicht zu sehr nackt da draußen rumzustehen. Habt ihr jetzt auch schon von so verschiedenen Lösungen was gesehen, die sich jetzt hier anbieten, einem sozusagen das Dropbox-Verzeichnis zu verschlüsseln, bevor es irgendwie zu Dropbox geht? Ich glaube, dass hier Systeme inherent irgendwie problematisch sind.
Dann gibt es schon länger diese Dinge, die einfach einen TrueCrypt-Container da abschmeißen, also die alten Methoden.
Ja, dann wird das aber so sicherlich nicht mehr so ohne weiteres so einfach zu bedienen sein, alles, oder?
Ja, das stimmt. Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie sich so ein TrueCrypt-Firesystem da fühlt oder so ein Container fühlt, wenn man ihm unter am Arsch die Blocke weg ändert.
Ja gut, aber der neue Trend ist sozusagen gar keine Cloud mehr benutzen. Man ist sozusagen seine eigene Cloud.
Ich hätte immer noch gerne meine eigene Cloud. OS X Server mit Cloud-Feature, wo man dann im iPhone sagen kann, ich gerne jetzt hier meinen eigenen. Von mir aus, den man gleich für eine kleine Firma, für seine zehn Kumpels oder wie auch immer macht, aber dass halt immer so ein Dutzend Leute sich ihre eigene Kisse teilen.
Mit dünn DNS. Und den dünn DNS-Eintrag, DNSSEC signiert. Ich sichere meine dynamische Zone mit DNSSEC.
Die mit Apple funktioniert?
Hast du mal OwnCloud mal angeguckt?
Nein, ich will das alles integriert haben.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich es nicht installiert bekommen. Ich wollte es mir mal angucken, aber das war alles, ja.
Das ist alles noch halb gar was da draußen umschwört, ja.
Also es war keine Point-and-Click-Installation.
Genau. Und dein iPhone möchte immer noch gerne nach Hause telefonieren. Und zu Hause ist für dein iPhone nicht bei dir, sondern ein Glück bei Tino. Ja, ich weiß.
PHP als Befreiungsmaschine.
Ach, seufzt. Jetzt sind wir alle ziemlich abgeturnt hier. Also lass uns mal ein neues tolles Thema suchen.
Dann rede ich mal über den File-Transporter. Über den Transporter. Und zwar, draufgekommen bin ich über den Martin von Instacast, der irgendwann twitterte, ja, und er hat jetzt diese beiden Dinger da gekauft. Und das sah irgendwie spannend aus, aber es war nicht klar, was es ist. Also hab ich mal so nachgeguckt. Und es ist so, dass die Jungs, die ursprünglich mal Data Robotics gegründet haben, die, die diesen Drobo gebaut haben, waren irgendwie mit der Richtung der Firma nicht mehr zufrieden und haben sich abgesetzt und haben eine neue Firma gegründet. Und haben sich dann gedacht, wir wollen mal dieses ganze Dropbox-Thema, Clouds-Thema mal in Griff kriegen. Und man kann jetzt von denen so ein Gerät, das sieht so aus, wie sieht denn das aus? Das sieht irgendwie strange aus. Also die Basis, das ist so ein Gerät, das ist so groß wie, naja, da passt halt eine 2,5 Zoll Festplatte rein, stehend. Unten ist es rund, vielleicht so groß wie ein Bierdeckel und oben ist es so ein bisschen länglich und so futuristisch, ja so futuristisch rund alles.
Das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie so ein überdimensionierter Midi-Drehschalter.
Ja oder so ein Mac Pro, wo einer am einen Ende drauf gelatscht ist und jetzt ist er verbogen. Irgendwie so. Und dieses Teil ist so eine Art nass.
Wie groß ist denn das?
Na es ist so groß, dass ziemlich genau eine 2,5 Zoll Festplatte reinpasst. Also so, naja, kleiner als eine normale Bierflasche.
Also ist das hier so wie auf diesen Fotos, so hoch wie ein Laptop-Bildschirm so?
Ja, so ungefähr.
Warum hast du das denn nicht mitgebracht?
Weil es zu Hause am Netz hängt. Nein, aber das Ding soll ja transportieren. Es soll ja nicht selber transportiert werden.
Erzähl doch mal.
Also es ist so eine Art Nassbüchse, die aber irgendwie internetweit erreichbar ist. Aber das Coole an dem Ding ist, du kannst dir mehrere von den Teilen hinstellen und dann unterhalten die sich untereinander und sünden untereinander die Dateien.
Du stellst einen auf Arbeit hin und einen zu Hause.
Per, das ist alles Hochnotproprietär.
Toll.
Ja, manch einer von uns wird da gleich die Augen gebrauchen.
Also nochmal langsam, du stellst einen auf Arbeit, einen zu Hause hin, schiebst auf Arbeit irgendwie einen 5 Gigabyte File drauf, weil nach Hause würde das ganz schön ewig dauern, fährst nach Hause und in der Zeit, während du fährst, hat der das dann schon in Ruhe zu dem anderen Ding bei dir nach Hause geschoben.
Genau, der tröpfelt das dann irgendwie nach Hause. Wenn er leer ist, kostet er glaube ich 200 Dollar und dann muss er mal irgendwo klicken. Und dann ein Terabyte 300 und zwei 400, irgendwie sowas, keine Ahnung. Also er ist jetzt nicht super billig, aber er ist auch nicht super teuer. Also ich hab das...
Die Dinger reden nur untereinander miteinander.
Die reden nur untereinander miteinander. Beziehungsweise, wie gesagt, ist alles hochnotproprietär. Du kannst dann auf dem Mac oder unter Windows eine Software installieren, die dir so einen Ordner zur Verfügung stellt, ähnlich wie Dropbox, wo das Zeug gesynkt wird. Aber du kannst halt zu jedem Ordner sagen, synkt mir das mal nicht auf den Rechner, sondern gib mir das nur, wenn ich es wirklich anfordere. Weil das ist ja im Netz und du kannst dann halt quasi, wenn du zu Hause bist, über das Netz auch an die Dateien flott ran.
Schön, jetzt die wichtige Frage nochmal. Wie finden die sich? Kann ich auch Sachen mit anderen Leuten scheren?
Das Ganze, das Ganze, ja. Ist das verschlüsselt? All diese Antworten kann ich immer nur schwammig beantworten, weil ich sagte, es ist Hochnotproprietär. Also da ist nix open. Da müsste man erstmal richtig reingucken, was da dahinter ist.
Erstmal verklagen, jede Menge, jede Wette hat eine Linung drunter.
Du kannst jeden Ordner, den du da drauf, da ist bestimmt eine Linung drunter, ja, jeden Ordner, den du da drauf machst, kannst du zu einem anderen Transporter sinken, wenn du jemand anders mit seinem Transporter einlädst. Also das hab ich schon gemacht.
Also es gibt auch dritte, Drittpersonen. Also jetzt nicht, dass du nur deine eigenen Transporter unter einander sinkst, sondern nicht wie bei Dropbox, dass du auch andere Leute irgendwie einladen kannst, oder so da mitzuspielen.
Genau, das kannst du machen. Und du kannst halt dann sagen, den und den Ordner möchte ich gerne mit dem scheren, der hat nämlich auch einen Transporter. Dann wird der Ordner inzwischen dem geschert. Da gibt's irgendwie komischerweise in der derzeitigen Software keine Möglichkeit zu sagen, ich möchte dem den Ordner aber nur Read-Only geben.
Oder?
Keine Ahnung. Die sind da irgendwie an 1-2-0-Software-Versionen am Basteln. Die soll in den nächsten Wochen rauskommen. Wenn sie das tut, können wir das Thema gerne noch mal haben. So, wie finden die sich? Das ist ein bisschen ein Problem. Es gibt dann nämlich so eine Webseite. Du musst nämlich bei dieser Firma in den Account machen. Und der Transporter hinterlegt dann bei denen seine eigene Existenz. Ob er auch die Daten hinterlegt, weiß ich nicht.
Weil das ist ja für dich, da du als Amal-User ja beschützt werden musst, falls du deinem Privatkeeper gehst, damit du an deine Daten noch ankommst, müssen wir natürlich sicherstellen, dass das noch geht. Das heißt, wir stellen dir einfach eine Sicherheitsfrage. Wie hieß dein erster Hund? Und schon kannst du es beantworten. Zack, können wir dein Ki wieder restaurieren. Das ist doch toll.
Stichwort Markt-Puddle-Test, ne?
Ja, aber nochmal, das ist also jetzt komplett, das weißt man nicht, du wederst übrigens wieder.
Ich weder auch.
Wie ich weder?
Ich habe noch gar nicht, ich habe das doch eingestellt.
Es sind jemanden, der wedert hier. Niemand weiß, wie das geht, und vertrauen sie uns, wir sind die Guten.
Im Zweifelsfall, ja. Im Zweifelsfall, ja.
Sorry, ich bin heute so drauf. Bisschen definitiv drauf, aber das muss jetzt mal sein.
Naja, ich will das jetzt auch nicht groß verteidigen. Ich wollte es halt einfach mal ausprobieren, ob das Produkt als solches überhaupt funktioniert. Wie gesagt, weil es ist ja von den ehemaligen Drobo-Jungs. Und mit dem Drobo habe ich jetzt auch unter nicht Security, sondern mehr so unter Data Safety Aspekten Kopfschmerzen gehabt. Also ich habe da nicht wirklich Daten verloren, aber es war kurz davor und insofern...
Ich habe da Daten mit verloren.
Ja, ich habe es noch schnell runter kopieren können alles. Insofern wollte ich es halt überhaupt erstmal probieren. Ich habe da nur WWDC-Videos drauf getan und weil dann irgendwie die Developer-Seite von Apple komplett down war, die hatten ja da dieses komische Problem, dass sie ihr gesamtes Angebot für Developer runternehmen musste, fragte da jemand, ob nicht jemand so ein paar WWDC-Videos hätte. Und dann habe ich halt mal dieses Transporter-Syncing ausprobiert.
Ah, verstehe. Zufällig dann wahrscheinlich auch das selbe Produkt dann auch schon.
Und das hat gut funktioniert. Also, ja, an andere Entwickler, von denen ich weiß, dass sie Entwickler sind. Das ist ja vielleicht okay.
Die zwei Tarre bei zweieinhalb Zoll kosten nur noch 183 Euro.
Also du kannst die Festplatte auch tauschen. Das ist so ein bisschen der Ansatz, den auch die Drobo-Jungs haben. Das Ding ist ein Bajonettverschluss, machst du auf und ziehst die Festplatte raus, dann sind allerdings die Daten weg. Wenn du eine andere rein tust natürlich, weil keine Ahnung, was die da von vorausspringen.
Und File-System und so weiter ist auch alles nicht klar.
Ist nicht klar. Ist wahrscheinlich irgendein Standard Linux Zeug. Und wenn du weißt, wie man X4 oder X5 oder was die da inzwischen verwenden, mountet, dann kommst du bestimmt auch irgendwie an deine Daten. Aber das ist möglicherweise dann auch auf Black-Block-Level in einzelnen Dateien gespeichert oder so. Also, Juratec Bremsscheiben?
Ja, fand ich auch gut. Ihr sucht da Transporter, Social Drive, welche Bremsscheiben.
amazon.de gibt es das nicht. Ja, hab ich auch gerade festgestellt.
Dennis hat nur gerade Dollar als Euro-Preise, deswegen wollte ich jetzt gerade mal.
Auf der Transporter-Seite gibt es einen Distributor in Deutschland angegeben und da kostet das Ding fast doppelt so viel. Also wenn du die Dollars nach Euros umrechnest und guckst, was die verlangen, dann kostet das ungefähr doppelt.
Wie zu guten Apple-Zeiten, ne?
Deswegen hab ich mir das in Amiland an eine amerikanische Adresse schicken lassen. Und das dann von dort aus probiert. Im Großen und Ganzen ist nicht so ganz klar, was sie für ein Protokoll schreiben. Und es geht auch nicht durch jede Firewall durch, wie ich schon feststellen durfte.
Haut mich nicht um.
Nee, ich...
Ich auch nicht.
Wie gesagt, ich wollte es halt ausprobieren, weil ich fand es im Prinzip eine interessante Idee. Aber was halt so ein 1.0 Produkt ist, ne? Keine Ahnung, wie gesagt, wollen die 2.0 Versionen jetzt von der Firmware Software demnächst raushauen. Ob die dann besser ist und dann mehr kann, keine Ahnung. Es gibt noch eine IOS-App dazu, wo du dann auf die Dateien vom Transporter über IOS zugreifen kannst. Die sieht so ähnlich aus, ein bisschen schlechter als die Dropbox-App und tut ungefähr das Gleiche. Also tut erstmal, ja, ich würde da aber wahrscheinlich dann auch nur verschlüsselte Disk-Images drauf tun, wenn ich dann sensitive Daten hätte, weil da das ja nur wirklich nicht so ganz klar ist, wie das tatsächlich funktioniert.
Was ich ja hier schon mal vorgestellt hatte, was ähnliches tut, bloß ohne so ein dediziertes Gerät, ist ja BitTorrent Sync.
Ja, das hab ich auch ausprobiert schon. Was ganz interessant ist, also der FreeBSD-Client funktioniert auch erstaunlich gut. Also ich hab es tatsächlich geschafft, den BitTorrent Sync mit dem FreeBSD-Server zum Laufen zu kriegen.
Kann man auch davon ausgehen, dass es auch mit der Linux-Variante genauso gut gehen würde?
Davon würde ich mal ausgehen, ja. Also bei BitTorrent Sync hab ich immer das Gefühl, es dauert eine ganze Weile, bis die sich finden. Und es dauert auch eine ganze Weile, bis er merkt, dass neue Dateien da sind oder sich Dateien geändert haben. Also da ist Dropbox deutlich flotter.
Ja, es gibt auch Environments, wo irgendwie die Verbindung nicht hergestellt werden kann. Also es kommt noch nicht irgendwie überall durch. Hatte das jetzt in einem Environment, wo ich aber nicht wusste, wie das Netzwerk-Setup war, kann durchaus sein, dass die da versucht haben, den BitTorrent vorzugehen, wo man es an der Stelle mal wirklich voll legal mit den eigenen Daten nutzt, aber es hat ja noch nie einen interessiert.
Wahrscheinlich sind das so Leute, die irgendwie alles sperren, was nicht HTTP auf Port 80 ist. Und dann funktioniert natürlich so was wie BitTorrent SYNC nicht und dieses Transporterzeug läuft wahrscheinlich auch nicht über Port 80. Also insofern, ja, richtiges Netz ist schon gut, wenn man es hat.
So, bleiben wir noch so ein bisschen im Bereich Sicherheit.
Hättest du gar nicht gehört, hättest jetzt nichts gesagt.
Du kannst doch mal sagen, wie das heißt. Wie wär's von Cadbury, diese Curly Wurly?
Ich sag euch, das hieß früher vier Muskeltiere oder so was.
Curly Wurly von Cadbury, ein fieses Zeug. Ein fieses Zeug.
So ein Plombenzieher.
Zahnkiller.
Ja, aber irgendwie auch fies lecker.
Na, leider. Es gab diesen, ich weiß nicht, worüber wollen wir reden? Über O2 und E+, oder über diesen Karten?
Was willst du über O2 und E plus erzählen, dass die Mergen werden?
Wollen.
Ja, was das bedeutet.
Erst mal Leute im Netz losschrieben, ja, jetzt das beste Netz in Deutschland und nicht so... Bitte? Nee, erstens wollen sie das nur. Minus und Minus macht immer noch einen Plus.
Die zwei schlechtesten Netze tun sich zusammen und sind immer noch das schlechteste Netz.
Was Abdeckung angeht, könnte das passieren, ja. Ein bisschen davon durfte man dieser Tage auch lesen, dass die Regulierungsbehörde da wenig Begeisterung verhegt und dann sagt, ja hallo, wir haben euch die Frequenzen gegeben, aber nur für unabhängige Netzbetreiber. Und wenn ihr euch jetzt zusammen schließt, dann nehmen wir euch die Hälfte der Dinger wieder weg.
Aber trotzdem haben sie doch noch doppelt so viele Stationen dann rumstehen oder nicht?
Ja und, wenn die alle am selben Mast hängen, was hast du davon gewonnen?
Die hängen am selben Mast, da wo die anderen auch hängen.
Also du meinst, wenn die beide auf dem gleichen Haus sind?
Da wo drauf ankommt. Guck mal, hier wo sie gute Abdeckung haben, wo auch jeder seine eigene Türmschule auf verschiedenen Häusern hat.
Warte, warte, warte, wo haben die gute Abdeckung?
Wenn überhaupt dann da. Wenn überhaupt dann da. Bei anderen Geschichten, bei da draußen, leisten die sich den Luxus schon seit Jahren oder seit Ewigkeiten nicht mehr, sich nur allein im Mast hinzustellen, sondern es gibt immer einen Betreiber, sozusagen einen Führenden an einem Standort, der baut sein Mast, händelt das Häuschen und die anderen ziehen mit drauf. Nicht alle vier immer, aber sehr häufig sind es mindestens drei Leute, du kannst ja angucken, in Brandenburg.
Du meinst, die Synergieeffekte, die wären gar nicht so groß?
Das ist das Einzige, was sie dürfen. Das ist das Tolle daran, dass irgendjemand mal gesagt hat, hier Kartell, Amt, Regulierungsbehörde, ihr dürft überhaupt gar nicht miteinander kooperieren. So war das am Anfang. Deswegen konnte man am Anfang, als es mit SMS losging, so Mitte der 90er Jahre, konnte man vom einen Netz nicht jetzt andere Messages überschicken. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch, da gab es mal was. Da gab es dann nur so dritte Anbieter, wie diese komische Firma Dr. Materna an Dortmund, die ein eigenes SMSC betrieben haben, worüber man dann ein Messages vom einen ins andere Netz schießen konnte. Die alten Vodafone- oder Mannesmann-Kunden erinnern sich vielleicht noch daran, das war das SMSC, das hinten mit 333 endete und nicht mit 000. Aber das kam, wie gesagt, daher, dass man eine strenge Auflage hatten, dass die Netzbetreiber vielleicht Wettbewerb zu betreiben haben, das heißt, man darf nicht miteinander kooperieren. Irgendwann hat dann mal jemand gesagt, ein Wodafone-Kunde oder ein Mannesmann-Kunde kann ja auch einen D1-Kunde anrufen. Und dann haben sie so lange auf denen eingehämmert, bis dieses Problem mal gefallen ist, dass man zumindest mal SMS an Leute in anderen Netz schicken konnte.
Der Wettbewerb muss so weit gehen, dass man sich auch nicht anrufen darf.
Ja, das wäre noch die Krönung gewesen. Und dann gab es natürlich jetzt auch wieder andere Themen, wo kooperiert man. Und dann ist man hingegangen und Kartellamt, Regulierungsbehörde, ist ja eh alle deine Soße da. Die kamen auf die tolle Idee, haben gesagt, ja, ihr dürft gerne zusammen Masten betreiben und Häuser mieten und so weiter und so fort, aber wie, ihr schaltet eure Netze da zusammen oder ihr betreibt nur eine Basisstation. Das ist bis heute so. Das ist das Problem, dass sie sich sozusagen Infrastruktur teilen können, aber immer noch ihre eigene Basisstation überall hin nageln müssen. Das war zum Beispiel jetzt, dir Tim hatte ich es ja auch gezeigt, das ist auf der Inner Station da, wo die Republik ja stattfand.
Das ist wirklich so, dass das Dokument des Scheiterns.
Ich kann dann noch mal kurz diesen Raum beschreiben. Da gibt es einen Raum, wo jetzt kurz vor der Republik alle angerückt sind bis auf E+, die ja ohnehin schon seit Jahren nicht mehr investieren im Netzausbau. Und dort unter der Führung von O2, das war dort der sogenannte Standortführer, Antennen angebracht haben in den Hallen von der Station, die alle zurückgeführt wurden auf einen wahnsinnspassiven Multiplexer. Das ist eine riesengroße blaue Kiste, so groß wie so ein Kleiderschrank, wiegt 450 Kilo, hat dort alle Antennen aus allen Hallen dran und alle Basisstationen von den anderen und hat sogar noch Knöpfe, dass ich E-Plus da anschließen könnte, aber das machen sie jetzt schon gar nicht mehr. Und jeder hat dort seine eigene Basisstation abgeschmissen und zwar jeder davon drei. Also O2, Telekom und Wodafone haben jeder eine GSM-Basisstation, eine UMTS-Basisstation und eine LTE-Basisstation dort abgeschmissen. Zwölf. Neun.
Aber waren nur drei?
Ja, E-Plus spielt ja nicht mit. So, die gehen alle in diesen Riesenteil, weil sie dürfen sich die Antennen teilen, sie dürfen sich auch die Kabel teilen, aber sie dürfen sich nicht die Basisstationen teilen. Was technisch gesehen vollkommen problemlos möglich wäre. Aber übrigens war es sehr lustig, die eine Basisstation von dem einen Operator, die haben sie irgendwo rausgerissen. Das hast du gesehen, die kamen nämlich angerollt, mit abgeknipsten Coax-Kabeln drauf. Das heißt, die hatten noch nicht mal jemand ordentlich abgeschraubt, sondern die haben sie irgendwo rausgebissen und die da hingezerrt, damit sie noch rechtzeitig zur Republik da ist. Und wie gesagt, das Ärgerliche daran ist, das kann man ja sagen, das ist ja nicht mein Geld, aber das Ärgerliche ist, dass natürlich das Investitionsvolumen, das die da reingesteckt haben, jetzt woanders fehlt. Wenn du mir die Frage stellst, warum in Klein Coup Kakarote immer noch kein UMTS sagt, weil die Scheiß-Basis-Station dafür in der Station steht. Weil die könnten ja auch kooperieren, wie das in anderen Ländern der Fall ist zum Beispiel.
Vor allem in diesem WLAN-Bereich ist das ja eigentlich gang und gäbe. Ich meine, da hat man ja mittlerweile eingesehen, dass es vollkommen inakzeptabel ist, wenn du jetzt, was weiß ich, fünf Hotspot-Betreiber am Flughafen hast, dann bauen die ja nicht alle noch mal ihr eigenes Netz auf. Sondern du hast da halt irgendeinen Master-Hotspot-Ausbauer, der da so das Metanetz, das eigentliche technische, physikalische Netz macht und dann vermietest du da entweder verschiedene SSIDs oder du machst halt so ein gemeinsames Portal, da ist ein scheiß Dreck. Aber zumindest werden die Frequenzen so halbwegs sinnvoll genutzt, sofern man das bei den zwei mal fliegiger hat. Ja, und der Hardware-Einsatz und der Kosteneinsatz und überhaupt, wenn du halt ein System upgradest, sind dann alle geupgradet und so weiter. Also das ist wirklich total Hanebüchen und ich glaube wäre das nicht so. Ich meine, du hast ja auch mal dieses schöne Beispiel gegeben, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt hier war oder im CAE wahrscheinlich, beides mit irgendwie Schweden.
Da machen sie das.
Wo da in den Outskirts einfach nur noch ein GSM-Netz ist, was einfach nur Schweden heißt. War doch so, ne?
Ja, da hab ich jetzt auch wieder gefunden, da gibt da ein Netz, wenn du das auf dem Telefon dir anzeigen lässt, in der Netzliste steht da Schweden und du denkst dir so, hab ich noch nie einen Laden für gesehen? Mal die Webseite suchen, gibt es nicht. Kann man gar keine SIM-Card dafür kaufen. Das Rätsel des Lösungen ist, es ist ein virtuelles Netz, was von mehreren Netzbetreibern betrieben wird, deren Kunden alle darauf rohmen und damit ist der Dropsy Lutsch. Das heißt, du stellst in den Wald nur noch eine Basisstation und dann wartet.
Ja, eigentlich könnte man doch mal an Herrn Westerwelle herantreten. Westerwelle? Ja, es ist Deutschland hier.
Ach so, so schlimm ist es schon.
Es hat auch das Netz einfach Deutschland zu heißen. Du boostest dich einfach in Deutschland ein. Da ist das auch mit der Überwachung dann klar geregelt.
Siehst du, das muss man den Behörden nur einfach klarmachen. Sagen, ihr braucht nur noch eine Abhörschlitzstelle. Eine von den teuren Abhörschlitzstellen. Dann braucht ihr nicht, das ist überhaupt die geile Idee. So muss man das verkaufen. Stimmt.
Das ist doch alles viel zu teuer. Warum bei so vielen Providern? Damit könnte man auch das Glasfasernetz in Deutschland dann irgendwie mal klar machen.
Ein Stern für ein Glasfasernetz von ganz Deutschland auf einen Switch. Ein paar dicke Stöpsel dran für GCHQ, NSA, BND, wie sie alle heißen.
Ganz einfach, da schließt ihr eure USB-Platten an und das war's.
Genau.
Ne, aber zurück, also O2, E+, ja, schön. Und ich weiß nicht, ob die da so viel Spaß dran haben werden. Als erstes wird natürlich die Service-Qualität dramatisch steigen, weil sie natürlich als erstes aus kostenspare Gründen erstmal die Leute rausschmeißen, die sie doppelt haben. Ist doch vollkommen logisch, dass die Leute diese doppelt haben.
Du hast gesagt, steigt.
Ja, und?
Welche Leute?
So werden sie das verkaufen. Nein, Leute, Leute, die da arbeiten.
Ach, Mitarbeiter.
Ja, Netzplaner.
Ach, so die.
Abrechnungsfuzzis, Rechtsabteilungen.
Na gut, das wird aber noch ein paar Jahre dauern.
Ja, wenn sie überhaupt die Genehmigung dafür kriegen. Also wie gesagt, ich sehe da jetzt noch nicht das große Juhu und alles wird toll.
Also manche funktionieren, aber auf meinem Telefon mein Empfang wird auch nicht besser.
Ich glaube nicht.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn jetzt O2 E plus übernehmen würde, ich denke ja, so ist es ja gedacht, oder? Und aber gleichzeitig dieses E plus Netz abstoßen.
An wen? Und warum sollten sie es dann übernehmen?
Moment, weil sie Kunden übernehmen können. Dann hätte man potenziell einen neuen Player Markt, der potenziell den Markt aufrollen könnte.
Glaubst du, wie lange die E plus Kunden bei O2 dann bleiben, wenn die Wendet-O2-Netz jetzt schon nicht für die bestehenden O2-Kunden kapazitätsmäßig ausreicht?
Du, vielleicht ist es ja trotzdem noch besser als das E plus Netz.
Im Chat wird behauptet, das wäre alles gelogen. Was du da erzählst über E plus, die bauen sehr wohl aus.
Ja klar, damit ihre Presseabteilung was zu sagen hat, stellen sie ab und zu mal irgendwo was hin. Ich hab schon lange keinen neuen Quack mehr gesehen. Sie haben auch lange nicht investiert bei Netzausrüstern und sowas. Sie mussten jetzt mal ein bisschen was machen, weil sie echt durch diese iPhone-Geschichte dramatisch und bedrängnisgeraten sind. Die ganzen Leute, die früher so total hip auf Bass waren und so weiter und so fort. Und E+, und ist ja total geil. Die sind ja alle weggehupft nachdem Apple mal ein iPhone rausgebracht hat, was mehr als 2G konnte. Und dann hat der E-Plus ewig gebraucht, bis sie damit aus dem Tuff gekommen sind. Also so richtig golden ist das nicht.
Du weißt nicht, warum ich normalerweise Fenster zu habe.
Ja, das geht aber gerade. Vorhin war es krass, jetzt können wir wieder zumachen. Vorhin war es ein bisschen Saunamäßig.
Ich bin mit Hover hier auch schon über dem Kaufen. Es gibt ja so einen Luxus-Lüfter-Artikel, der war mir bisher immer zu teuer, aber bei der Schwitzerei werde ich langsam weich.
Du meinst so ein, wie heißt die Firma?
Das ist auch nicht leiser. Ich wollte gerade sagen, wo ist jetzt der Erfolg?
Na alle zumachen, da geht es auch kein Bock, zu viel. Bis dahin ist seine Batterie leer.
Du kannst auch rausgehen, dem Spacken auf die Nase hauen und sagen, soll ich face deine Anlage rausmachen?
Na, könnt ihr den Dyson...
Dann sagt er, die Big War zuerst da.
R-Multiplier, so heißt er.
AM01.
Du musst den länglichen angucken.
Den länglichen?
Den gibt es jetzt auch, Olypsoid?
Ja, das ist eher so...
Was?
Wie so eine Rennbahn mehr. Also so zwei Halbkreise durch... Da unten ist er doch, AM4.
Oh, Heizlüfter.
Heizlüfter?
2000 Watt.
Den gibt es aber auch ohne Heiz.
280 Euro für einen Lüfter mit einer bisschen anderen Form ist schon ein krasser Preis, oder?
Ja, der pustet aber auch geil.
Keine Bewegung, dafür macht er nicht den Rad auf.
Erstens ist er sehr leise, zweitens keine beweglichen Teile.
Doch.
Tut es nicht.
Klar, der bewegliche Teil hat einen Lüfter drin.
Ja, unten drin.
Aber keine Rotoren.
Dann haben wir einen Lüfter wie überall woanders auch, nur dass du ihn nicht sehen kannst.
Also wenn man ihn im Betrieb gesehen hat und weiß, wie laut er tatsächlich ist, dann muss man bei dem Preis schon fragen. Ja, Spielkram.
Weil er diese Räusche macht er schon auch noch, ne?
Jaja, klar. Also ein gut designter Lüfter mit Blättern ist lauter. Ja, ist lauter, aber nicht viel. Also, naja, die Dinger röhren schon auch, wenn du da ordentlich Stoff gibst.
Na toll. Jetzt kauf ich mir keinen und dann ist es hier immer heiß.
250 Euro, man!
Ja, die sind schon cool, weil du da halt...
Ich hab noch so wenig Platz, ich könnte das Ding jetzt hier mal so da in so eine Lücke reinstellen und hätte tatsächlich Belüftung, aber so ein Dreh, naja, wie auch immer. Ich hab ja auch nur mal eben mit dem Luxus mit dem Luxus geliebäugelt. Für euch hätte ich es ja gemacht, ja.
Also Luxus ist auf jeden Fall.
Mir wäre es ja egal.
Also aufrufen unsere Hörer, ne?
Schickt uns alle einen an, 013.
Können wir nicht so einen Sammel-Account machen, irgendwie? So einen, so einen...
Sammel-Account?
Ja, dass die alle mal ein bisschen zusammenlegen. Jeder Hörer ein Euro und schwupp, schon geht's.
Die legen sowieso am laufenden Meter zusammen, da müssen wir uns überhaupt nicht beschweren. Hörer sind schon toll.
Wer beschwert sich?
Sonst gibt's das hier alles schon lange gar nicht mehr.
Aber es stimmt natürlich, man kann da nicht in rotierende Teile reinfassen. Bei dem Ding. Und allein dieses Teil mal zu sehen, wie es pustet. Und du hast eigentlich überhaupt keinen Plan, wie das Ding funktioniert, so auf Anhieb. Das ist schon ganz cool.
Das ist wirklich sexy.
Also es ist keine super Sonderwundermaschine, aber...
Du hast das Ding schon mal erlebt, ja?
Das ist technisch die Begeisterung. In allen DB-Lounges stehen die auch irgendwie rum.
Der pustet schon ordentlich, also so ist es nicht.
Ja, der macht richtig Alarm. Ach, den gibt es auch als AM02.
Ja genau, den hatten wir. Diesen Turmventilator.
Der hat sich nicht verfügbar.
Mit Fernsteuerung, ne?
Aber macht das E-Plus-Netz jetzt auch nicht besser. Ist aber ein bisschen sehr groß hier.
Aber kühler.
Mehr Fernbedienung.
Watt, so groß sind die?
Das ist der Große, der Kleine ist nicht so groß.
Der Kleine ist nicht ganz so groß, ne.
Und die drehen auch?
Die drehen hin und her.
Der hat so einen Schwenk, ja.
Also der macht schon ordentlich Pust. Amtlich Pust könnte man sagen.
Also das würde jetzt die Situation hier schon nachhaltig verbessern.
Verändern.
Verbessern. Positiv denken. Ja, das ist quasi die Verschlüsselung des Luftstroms. Okay, fällt dir noch was ein zu E+, versus O2, sonst können wir das glaube ich auch eintüten.
Ich meine, es passiert oder es passiert nicht.
Der User hat nichts davon, Leute werden entlassen und die Firma verdient mehr Geld.
Ja, sonst würden sie es ja nicht machen.
Ich habe ja jetzt festgestellt, dass E+, tatsächlich das einzige 3G-Netz ist, in meinem Garten, wo ich irgendwie die ganze Zeit nach Netz schreie. Das ist das einzige, was ich gar nicht probiert habe, weil ich nicht im Traum damit gerechnet hätte.
Sie haben jetzt schon irgendwo Martin gebastelt aufs Land. Habe ich jetzt auch manchmal entdeckt, dass es da wieder so GSM-Basis-Stationen gibt, wo man die anderen so kaum noch kriegt. Aber das ist dann selten. Also ganz so schlimm ist das nicht. Wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, sie haben wirklich sehr, sehr lange Zeit nichts investiert in ihre Netze. Da war so voll der Abmelk-Modus und sie sind jetzt wieder ein bisschen dabei, weil sie den Druck auch jetzt haben durch die anderen. Weil wenn dein Netz nicht smartphonefähig ist, dann kannst du das auch sein lassen. Telefonieren war gestern.
Das stimmt.
Das wird sehr erstaunlich, ne? Wo sich doch alle nach der UMTS-Frequenzauktion der berühmten noch alle den Kopf gefasst haben und gesagt haben, was machen wir denn jetzt mit den Bits? Was ist denn jetzt die Killer-Applikation? Ja, um Gottes Willen, was machen wir jetzt mit diesen ganzen tollen Datendiensten? Also was bieten wir da jetzt an?
Da musste erst so eine angeschlagene Apfelfirma daherkommen. Und aufmischen. Gibt's Nokia jetzt eigentlich noch? Was?
Nokia gibt's noch.
Immer weniger, aber gibt's noch.
Aber die Gummistiefel sollen noch gut laufen, dachte ich mir.
Autoreifen hab ich gehört.
Autoreifen, voll der Knaller, ja? Weiß nicht.
So, jetzt gab's noch diesen bemerkenswerten GSM-Hack. Also ich denke, das ist bemerkenswert. Also es ist auf jeden Fall wert, hier mal bemerkt zu werden, sagen wir's mal so. Kurz gesagt, eine Sicherheitslücke, vielmehr eine Kaskade von Sicherheitslücken, wurde veröffentlicht. Das Ganze stammt ja auch aus Berlin.
Eine Verkettung unglücklicher Umstände?
Nö, das ist eher die Konsequenz aus jahrelanger, zielgerichteter Forschung in so Bereiche, wo es schon beim Betrachten der Standards gebröckelt hat. Also, kurz gesagt, das Ganze ist hier von SR Labs publiziert worden, dem halt dieser Karsten Nohl vorsteht, mit dem ich auch mal den GSM Security CAE gemacht habe. Und seine Truppe hat sozusagen das jetzt auch wirklich dahin gebracht, dann die unter anderem auch im CAE schon angedeuteten Schwachstellen auch mal wirklich zu exploiten. Kurz gesagt, so eine SIM-Karte ist mehr als man denkt, da läuft halt allerlei Fuh. Das ist halt schon so ein richtiger Computer. Das geht sogar so weit, dass da eine komplette Java-VM mit drin ist, in denen halt Applikationen nicht nur laufen können, sondern auch laufen und schlimmer noch, was halt dem wenigsten glaube ich klar ist, Netzbetreiber können halt bei Design, das sieht halt das Netz so vor, da so Over-the-Air-Updates reinspielen und dir irgendwelche Software in deine SIM-Karte hineinwerfen, diese SIM-Karte. Bitte?
Nicht bloß Software.
Auch Hardware?
Also die Mechanismen, die dahinter. Aber nicht bloß Programme, sondern auch Daten.
Ich hätte gern ein iPhone 6, können Sie mir das mal runterladen?
Ja, also diese Grundmechanismen gibt es schon sehr lange, weil diese sogenannte SIM-Karte-Provision, Over-the-Air-Provisioning hatte ich schon bei meiner ersten US-SIM-Karte und das war noch irgendwie Mitte der 90er. Man muss sich ja vorstellen, so eine SIM-Karte ist ja neben dem, was du gerade sagtest, also als Rechner, also ist das ja erstmal ein File-System. Ein cooles File-System, was doch nicht so gedacht ist, so für Menschen zum Bedienen, deswegen gibt es auch in dem Sinne keine File-Namen, sondern nur File-IDs und die stecken so in Ordnern drin, die auch irgendwelche IDs haben, aber vom Prinzip ist das ein File-System. Und das konnte man schon relativ früh, seit an Beginn der, ich würde nicht sagen, seit absoluter am Beginn der GSM-Zeit, also 1991 oder so, aber so seit Mitte der 90er Jahre, haben die regelmäßig diese Dinger verteilt, weil sie die over the air provisioniert haben. Und zwar durch eine SMS. Man kann SMS'e verschicken an einen Teilnehmer, die so designiert sind, dass sie nicht für den Benutzer gedacht sind, auch nicht für das Telefon, sondern für die SIM-Karte. Und die werden dann einfach an die SIM-Karte runtergereicht vom Telefon und die SIM-Karte macht dann irgendwas damit. Und da gibt es schon offiziell standardisierte Methoden, wie man diese Dateien auf diese SIM-Karte manipulieren kann. Unter anderem halt eben auch, kannst du ein Telefonbuch befummeln, oder die Rufnummer, die gespeichert ist, die eigene Rufnummer von der SIM-Karte, oder eben auch Schlüssel und all mögliche andere Zeug. Theoretisch lässt das Stand dazu, dass du jede scheiß Datei, also auch Kryptosachen auf dem Ding over the air umhacken kannst.
Außer dem KI, außer dem Kernschlüssel der SIM-Karte.
KI ist auch nur ein Pfeil, was normalerweise einen Pfeilmodus hat, wie zeig es mir nicht an oder rück es nicht raus. Aber KI ist auch nur ein Pfeil wie alle anderen auch. Das ist so der......primär Schlüssel sozusagen.
Dein privater Primärschlüssel. Der, mit dem deine ganze... Wenn du überhaupt Verschlüsselung machst beim Telefonieren, dann mit dem Schlüssel.
Also das ist der Schlüssel, den die SIM-Karte überhaupt ausmacht?
Ja, genau. Für den Krypto-Teil. Für die SIM-Karte.
Ohne den Schlüssel würde die SIM-Karte keinen Sinn machen.
Ja, das ist übrigens schon deshalb eben ein Pfeil, weil es gibt diese SIM-Karten, wenn sie frisch aus der Fabrik kommen, sind sie ja leer. Das heißt, man muss ihnen eh erstmal den KI und diverse andere Sachen dort einprügeln. Und deswegen kann man den beschreiben. Und dann gibt es so einen Mechanismus, wo man sagt, so, jetzt bin ich fertig mit provisionieren. Jetzt schalt mal bitte alle deine Geheimdateien so, dass du sie nur noch intern verwendest, aber nicht mehr nach draußen lieferst und so weiter. Es gibt, wie gesagt, so File-Zugriffs-Mode, ähnlich wie im Unix-Filesystem, wo du sagen kannst, wer darf lesen, wer darf schreiben. Und ob man zum Beispiel ein File einfach so lesen kann, zum Beispiel das simpelste File in der obersten Hierarchie ist die SIM-Karten-ID. Das ist nicht die IMSI, sondern das ist diese komische Zahl, die auch hinten drauf gedruckt ist auf die SIM-Karte, die mit 8, 9 anfängt und dann irgendwie lalalala. Das Ding ist immer lesbar, zum Beispiel ohne Zugriffsdinger. Und dann so was wie die IMSI, das ist eine Datei, die kannst du nur lesen, wenn du vorher mal einen PIN-Code, nämlich den PIN-Code, an die SIM-Karte runtergereicht hast. Wer sich jetzt sozusagen mit Telefonen oder PIN-Codes da immer mal rumärgert oder fragt, was da passiert, der PIN-Code wird nur vom Telefon an die SIM-Karte runtergereicht. Damit wird sie sozusagen aufgeschlossen. Und dann kann man halt eben an so Felder ran wie IMSI. Also dieser ganze Zoo, ich will jetzt gar nicht näher darauf eingehen, das gibt es alles schon ewig. Eine neue Qualität hat es bekommen durch zweierlei Technologien. Nämlich einerseits das sogenannte SIM-Application Toolkit. Auch das ist ein ziemlich altes Ding. Das definiert nämlich eine Schnittstelle, über die Telefonen und SIM kommunizieren können, und zwar in einer anderen Rolle. Normalerweise ist es so, dass für den normalen Betrieb ist das Telefon der aktive Teil und die SIM-Karte ist der passive Teil. Das heißt, der Telefon sagt immer, gib mir mal die Datei oder schreib mal was in die Datei, oder hier hast du mal ein PIN-Code, und die SIM reagiert nur. Beim SIM Application Toolkit ist es andersrum. Das heißt, der SIM kann zum Telefon sagen, ich kenne dir mal einen Spruch, kannst du den mal bitte anzeigen auf dem Display? Oder hol dir doch mal bitte eine Tastatur-Eingabe. Oder schick doch mal bitte eine SMS. Oder mach doch mal bitte einen Anruf. Da gibt es diverse Sachen. Auch das ist wieder standardisiert. Das heißt, ein SIM kann also auch dem Telefon bitten, was zu tun. Es gab mal Nokia-Telefone. Oder gibt es immer noch. Aber bei den alten Nokia-Telefonen, so in dieser mittleren Range, die so von vor zehn Jahren, gab es immer eine nette Einstellung. Bei den Telefoneinstellungen, ob man SIM-Application-Toolkit-Sachen einfach erlaubt oder ob man nachfragen soll. Ich hab das immer so einstellt, dass man nachfragen soll. Und immer dann, wenn ich so ein altes Nokia-Telefon mal benutze, um zum Beispiel mal während eines Urlaubs meine deutsche SIM-Karte abzuspeichern, merke ich, dass das immer noch benutzt wird. Also wenn ich zum Beispiel meinen T-Mobile-SIM oder sowas reinmache, kommt immer nach ein paar Minuten die Anfrage von meinem Nokia-Telefon, deine SIM-Karte möchte gerne eine SMS verschicken. Möchtest du das auch? Also das wird benutzt, dieser Mechanismus. So, das ist das eine Ding. Und der andere Knall ist natürlich, dass dann die Leute angefangen haben, wirklich richtig kleine Java-VMs in die SIM-Karten einzubauen. Das heißt, man kann also da richtig Software reinladen in die SIM-Karte, die dann auch irgendwie was macht. Es ist auch immer noch so, dass, ich weiß nicht, ich kann ja mal gucken, es gibt irgendwo ganz tief versteckt, beim iPhone gibt es auch eine Möglichkeit, noch mit diesem Ding zu interagieren auf diesem Level. Ich suche gleich mal danach. So, und das ganze Geschichte war natürlich immer super toll verschlüsselt und total sicher. Hat sich nie einer Gedanken drum gemacht. Weil du brauchst halt eben diesen Master-Schlüssel, brauchst du diesen KI oder einen äquivalent geheimen Schlüssel, den nur die SIM-Karte und dein Netzbetreiber wusste. Damit sozusagen der Netzbetreiber, der Einzige ist, der auf deine SIM-Karte rumfuschen kann. Der ist natürlich jetzt spannend angesichts von solchen vorhin erwähnten Themen wie Prism und Lara Pipapo und die Dienste gehen einfach hin zum Netzbetreiber und sagen, hier haben wir unser National Security Letter, jetzt gib mir mal bitte folgende Daten. Dazu gehören natürlich auch solche Daten. Damit kann man natürlich hingehen und schön aus der Ferne SIM-Karten provisionieren und damit alle möglichen Spaß haben. Und der SIM-Licht ist schon mal sehr interessant. Der zweite interessante Teil ist, dass sie bei der Krypto echt nicht aufgepasst haben. Erstens benutzen sie eine richtig alte kaputte Krypto-Algorithmen-Teile dafür. Und zweitens haben sie einen ganz fatalen Fehler gemacht. Das finde ich jetzt schon richtig böse. Wenn man nämlich dieser SIM-Karte einen Befehl zuschickt, einen solchen verschlüsselten Befehl, und einen Fehler hat er in dem Schlüssel, dann hält sie nichts Maul, sondern sie antwortet zurück und sagt, dass ihr das nicht gefällt und signiert diese Antwort. Was unsäglich dämlich ist.
Also signiert sie mit dem richtigen Schlüssel?
Wenn du das oft genug machst, dann kriegst du sozusagen Information von der SIM-Karte, genug Information, genug Keying-Material, die zusammen in Zusammenhang mit dem kaputten Krypto-Algorithmus und diesem Angriff dort, der da demonstriert wurde, halt eben dazu führen kann, dass du sozusagen den richtigen Schlüssel früher oder später errechnen kannst.
Genau, das sind Karten, die die ES als Verschlüsselung verwenden. Also es betrifft jetzt primär auch alte Karten. Es gibt so die Schätzung, dass es, also in Deutschland sind es die allerwenigsten, aber auch nicht keine. Und vor allem Länder, die jetzt sagen wir mal nicht so viel Turnaround haben und schon seit längerem irgendwelche alten Karten draußen haben und sich da nicht so sehr um Replacement kümmern, die sind halt massiv davon betroffen. Es gibt so die Schätzung 25% weltweit. Ob das so stimmt, kann ich nicht beurteilen, aber das war so ein bisschen die Aussage davon. Ja, so das ist also jetzt demonstriert worden. Auf der oben sind sie auch irgendwie rumgerannt und haben SIM-Karten gelesen und getestet, ob sie die irgendwie gekillt bekommen. Und es gab da wohl Karten von Zipgate, die teilweise anfällig waren. Ansonsten waren es wohl nur italienische Provider, die da jetzt auffällig geworden sind.
Nochmal, das betrifft aber nur, dass wir Dritte durchfummeln, erraten jetzt dein Krypto-Key. Das heißt nicht, dass die anderen nicht diese Fernsteuerfunktion drin haben. Das heißt nicht, dass die anderen nicht, wenn sie nicht mal ordentlich auf ihr HLR aufpassen bzw. auf das Authentication Center, die darin gespeicherten Keys oder die eben an irgendwelche Dienste rausgeben, dass dann nicht diese SIM-Kartenmanipulationen massenhaft durchgeführt werden können. Sondern es geht hier nur um das Erraten des Keys durch Dritte. Die Mechanismen sind bei allen da.
Genau, es sollte auch noch mal klar werden, was damit passiert ist. Das stand ja auch schon in diesem Heise-Artikel. Man konnte also einbrechen und letzten Endes auch den KI auslesen, was eigentlich nie gehen soll. Und damit konnte dann demonstriert werden, es gab dann ein Telefon, wo gar keine SIM-Karte drin war, die sich aber so verhielt, wie vorher, als die SIM-Karte drin war. Oder es war ein anderes Telefon.
Du kannst eine SIM-Karte klonen dann richtig.
Ja, bloß ohne SIM-Karte.
Ja, mit einem SIM-Karten-Demolator. Du hättest aber auch eine leere SIM-Karte nehmen können, da den KI reinschmieren können, dann hättest du den SIM-Karten klonen gehabt.
Ja, und jetzt haben wohl die Provider auch irgendwie erst mal reagiert, indem sie diese Nachrichten rausfiltern in ihrem Netz. Also das war so die kurzfristige Methode, um quasi erst mal Schlimmeres zu verhindern.
Und dabei lassen sie es auch, weil es funktioniert ja.
Naja, und sie werden halt auch die Karten aktualisieren. Es gibt ja halt weltweit so ohnehin im Wesentlichen nur drei oder vier Hersteller, die sie den Markt weitgehend unter sich aufgeteilt haben. Ich kann sie jetzt gerade nicht alle aufzeigen.
Diese Gimde-Variante.
Genau, das sind so die beiden.
Keine Ahnung, aber es gibt noch eine Handvoll. Kannst du auch glauben, dass die Chinesen ihre Karten selber stanzen?
Ja, stimmt. Aber es ist überschaubar, der Markt.
Aber nochmal, wer den Key hat, kontrolliert deine SIM-Karte, kontrolliert damit dein Telefon. Und wie gesagt, wie du um Key-Sicherheit bestellt bist, sehen wir jetzt gerade im Umfeld von Prism und Co.
Ja, alles nicht gerade besonders beruhigend. Und dann war es halt auch, jetzt muss ich gleich nochmal... Ja, ja, es ist ganz bitter, aber so ist es halt.
Wir brauchen mal was Fröhliches jetzt.
Was ich jetzt noch, ich versuche gerade noch ein Detail zu erinnern, was ich auf der oben erklärt bekommen habe, wo ich jetzt ein bisschen zu blöd bin, um das vollständig wieder zu rekonstruieren. Also es gab ja auch zwei Stufen in dieser ganzen Geschichte. Also man war halt sozusagen einmal erstmal in der SIM-Karte und dann hat man, um diesen KI dann auch noch auszulesen, ja auch noch eine Schwachstelle in dieser Java-VM ausgenutzt. Also es ist sozusagen nicht nur diese Over-the-Air-Geschichte, sondern eben auch das nächste theoretische Hindernis war halt keins, sondern man hat dann eben diesen VM-Bug benutzt, um dann eben dieser Karte erst so richtig auf den Leib zu rücken. Und wenn ich es jetzt richtig mitbekommen habe, gab es manche Telcos, die jetzt diese Java-VM-Lücke auch selber aktiv quasi als Exploit angewandt haben, um diese Karten over the Air zu patchen, damit sie diese Vulnerability nicht mehr haben. Sodass diejenigen, die an zwei Ebenen angreifbar waren, die sowohl diese Java-VM-Lücke hatten, als auch die Over-the-Air-Lücke, konnten das Problem dann per Exploit, wo sie jetzt ihre eigenen SIM-Karten over the Air hacken, damit sie damit gefixt werden. Und die, die schon etwas neuere Karten hatten, wo diese Java-VM-Lücke nicht mehr war, die stehen jetzt doof da, weil sie die Karten richtig austauschen müssen. Alles ist nicht so schön.
Und was lernen die Provider daraus? Ganz klar, sie brauchen immer eine Backdoor in die Karte, damit sie irgendwas patchen können.
Dafür wird der Ursprung nicht mal da. Sie haben wirklich angefangen, am Anfang haben sie sich gedacht, zum Beispiel für diese tollen Prepaid-Kunden wartet mal da. Da haben sie ja SIM-Karten wie Dumm und Nöcher verteilt, wussten aber teilweise die Rufnummer noch nicht. Zum Beispiel bei den Amis ist das so gewesen. Oder da auch, weil nicht Prepaid-Karten. Das heißt, sie haben erst in dem Moment, wo du dein Ding angemeldet hast oder Vertrag oder deinen Prepaid-Kunde eröffnet hast, dann haben sie erst deine SIM-Karte so weit provisioniert mit ihrer eigenen Rufnummer und so Zeugs.
Das hat garantiert mit dem iPhone ganz am Anfang auch gemacht mit AT&T. Mag sein. Weil die haben die iPhones ja damals auch mit SIM-Karte drin verkauft. Und du hast den Vertrag quasi dadurch abgeschlossen, dass du es an iTunes angeschlossen hast. Und du über iTunes das aktiviert hast mit Vertrag.
Dann haben sie die erste Rufnummer zugewiesen.
Wahrscheinlich.
Ja und wie gesagt, AT&T war noch die erste, die ich das gesehen habe. Das war wie gesagt Mitte der 90er. Naja, 95, 96, so in dem Dreh. Sehr schön. Ist das düster heute.
Wollt ihr was über die Omen wissen oder interessiert euch das nicht?
Sieh doch mal was lustiges.
Gibt es was lustiges von der Omen oder waren sie alle nur Frost?
War es dann cool oder war es zu viel Fox-IT?
Was ist denn Fox-IT?
Die ist nicht in der Debatte. Okay, lass mich kurz die Zusammenfassung machen. Also, Omen ist ja die nächste Iteration in dieser schon recht langen Historie von Open-Air-Hacking-Events in Holland, die sich immer wieder lustig dreibuchstabig benennen und dabei diesen Dreibuchstaben-Code jedes Mal wieder komplett neu zusammenstellen, während ja der Club immer alles CTC nennt, um es einfach zu machen. Maximal verwirrend. Da gab es die Heu, da gab es die Hip, die Hell, die WTH, die Har und jetzt die Oben.
Also man kann sagen, immer drei Buchstaben und immer ein H irgendwo mit drin.
Genau.
Bis auf die erste 89.
Die hatte auch ein H. Ja, die hieß aber Galactic Hacker Party, die wird bloß in der Regel nicht als GHP referenziert, aber die war ja auch nicht draußen, sondern die war ja drin. Also so läuft das da in Holland und das Ganze war halt immer so mit dieser Ur-Hacker-Szene verbunden. Ist es in gewisser Hinsicht auch noch, aber die Dinge ändern sich halt so ein bisschen und es gibt da halt mehr Generationsübergabe als im Club.
Die grauen Hacker kommen jetzt im Wohnmobil nicht mehr mit Zelt auf dem Fahrrad.
Ja, das schon länger und naja, das war jetzt das Problem. Naturgemäß gibt es ja eigentlich mal recht enge Bindungen zwischen Deutschland und Holland. Die gibt es auch nach wie vor, aber es gab halt jetzt das Problem und ich muss sagen, ich habe diese Debatte erst sehr spät mitbekommen, auch insofern, als dass ich aus technischen Gründen nicht auf der Haar dabei sein konnte. Das ist der erste und einzige Event, den ich mal ausgelassen habe. Und auch da gab es halt auch schon so Sponsoren und auch da waren halt Sponsoren aus dieser Security-Branche. Unter anderem eben dieses Fox IT, was halt so eine Firma war, die so als Hauptsponsor ein bisschen auffiel auf der oben. Mir ist wie gesagt nicht ganz klar, wie das auf der Haar gelaufen ist. Da habe ich das auch nicht so gesehen, da war ich halt nicht da war. Aber damals gab es auch noch nicht so diese Debatte. Und diese Debatte war halt dadurch ausgelöst, dass man eben von Fox IT meint zu wissen, dass sie eben auch mal Überwachungsequipment hergestellt haben. Hacker-Software quasi für Ägypten und auch noch andere Targets. Das kriege ich jetzt nicht alles so aufgezählt. Eine Division, die sie vor einiger Zeit wohl auch verkauft haben wieder, aber so oder so. Hat halt irgendwie alles so die Hände ins Spiel. Und dann gab es halt ein großes Aufhebens darum, ob denn das nun alles so vertretbar wäre oder nicht. Und ob man denn so eine Hacker-Veranstaltung, die sich so um Freiheits- und Unabhängigkeit bemüht, sich von so einem Unternehmen sponsoren lassen möchte.
Wo war so eine wichtige Debatte?
Ist eine wichtige Debatte auf jeden Fall. Die ist dann recht scharf geführt worden. Das eskalierte in einem Maße, wie es jetzt so zwischen diesen Szenen so bisher noch nicht gab. Das Gipfelte auch darin, dass das erste Mal der Club als solcher auch keine Präsenz da hatte. Es waren natürlich trotzdem viele Leute vom Club da, aus welchen Gründen und Motivationen auch immer heraus. Ich war ja auch da. Aber es gab halt jetzt nicht wie sonst so, dass CCC zählt oder so. Es ist ein bisschen schwierig, darüber zu urteilen. Auf jeden Fall fehlte meiner Wahrnehmung dieser Veranstaltung schon so ein gewisser Magic Sparkle. Der eigentlich diesen Veranstaltung war.
Wenn die Rakete nicht da war.
Da fehlte einfach der Elfenstab. Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt so sehr an der Rakete lag. Daran möchte ich es jetzt nicht so festmachen. Das hat aber auch mehrere Gründe. Und diese Debatte war das eine. Weil das hat auf jeden Fall schon mal eine ganze Menge Energie abgezogen. Es hat eine Menge Energie bei den Leuten abgezogen.
Aber auch berechtigt, oder? Also ich meine, man kann es ja nicht wegignorieren.
Ich will das auch gar nicht wegignorieren. Aber ich bewerte das jetzt auch mal nicht so, weil es gibt da viele Meinungen so. Und die prallen da natürlich alle aufeinander. Ganz unabhängig davon, was diese Firma jetzt als solche gemacht hat oder nicht gemacht hat, fand ich einfach die Art und Weise, wie sich dieser Laden dann auch auf dieser Veranstaltung präsentiert hat, einfach unwürdig. Also das war einfach scheiße und ich finde auch generell jetzt unabhängig von, ob Security-Business oder nicht, solche Firmen, Sponsorpräsenzen, eigentlich auf allen Veranstaltungen affig und fand es eigentlich immer eine großartige Errungenschaft.
Da hängen dann so ein paar Schlipsis ab.
So ist es jetzt nicht, weil die sind ja auch alle irgendwie die Szene und zwei der Veranstalter haben ja da auch gearbeitet und sind dann freigestellt worden und so weiter. Also diese Verquickungen sind ja auch sehr nachhaltig. Und natürlich, wenn du da irgendwie in diesem Universum bist und wenn du auch in dieser holländischen Realität, die immer auch schon eine andere war, als die deutsche bist, kommst du einfach zu anderen Bewertungen und anderen Schlüssen. Das ist einfach der Fall. Also ich sage nicht, es ist logisch, dass das so ist. Ich sage nur, so ist es. Die kommen zu anderen Schlüssen, als es die deutsche Szene hat. Die ist da auch sehr schnell mit der ethischen Keule unterwegs. Ich mag vielleicht andere Dinge jetzt nicht mit einrechnen, die dort eben alle irgendwie sehen. Natürlich erst einmal ausgehend aus diesen üblichen Zwängen. Na ja, wir brauchen ja das Geld, um solche Veranstaltungen zu machen. Und ist es nicht toll, dann aus so einem Business die Kohle zu nehmen, damit wir unseren Spaß haben können? Kann man ja auch so rumdrehen. Wir verbraten das Geld. Aber ich bin auch der Meinung, das passt alles nicht zusammen, weil Firmen auch grundsätzlich als Struktur dazu tendieren und das ist in der Security-Branche nochmal ganz besonders ausgeprägt, da einfach einen Dicken zu machen und sich einfach für die Geilsten zu fühlen. Und auch wirklich kein Gespür dafür zu entwickeln, wie man wirklich präsent da ist. Also wenn wir so Gespräche geführt haben mit potenziellen Sponsoren für den Kongress oder das Camp, bei Sponsor bei uns heißt immer, die Firma kann uns was geben, was wir brauchen. Sowas wie Switches, WLAN-Devices, Internetzugang. Also es ging immer und ausschließlich nur um konkrete Sachmittel, um das Ziel zu erzielen.
Also nicht einen dicken Scheck?
Nein, es gab keine finanziellen Sponsorings.
Es gab nur Sachmittelspenden?
Ja, in der Regel ja. Es lässt sich natürlich immer schwer zuordnen. Es ist immer die Frage, wer zahlt den Transport? Das ist jetzt eine finanzielle Zuwendung. Aber so oder so, niemals führt das dazu, dass wir jetzt so eine Tafel aufgestellt haben, mit hier sind unsere Goldsponsoren, Platinsponsoren oder sonst irgendwas. Wir erwähnen die Firmen, wenn sie es denn wollen, aber das findet extrem dezent statt.
Die haben schon aufs Dach bekommen, wenn sie angefangen haben, ihre roten Vodafone-Kugelschreiber zu vertreiben oder welche Firma das auch immer war.
Ja, oder ein Banner aufhängen oder so weiter. Da kommt dann sofort die Ästhetikpolizei und sammelt das ein. Und da gab es auch echt Stress deswegen, aber das ist halt so eine Linie, die wir durchgezogen haben und das fand ich eigentlich auch ganz richtig.
Und die wird auch weiter durchgezogen.
Ja, das denke ich auch. Ja, und da auf der Omen hast du dann halt so Zelte. Und es gab so mehrere Zelte, wo dann eben so Firmenlogos dran waren. Wo ich mich dann eben auch frage, bin ich jetzt hier auf so einem Hacker-Event irgendwie oder bin ich jetzt auf so einer Messe? Ich will nicht sagen, dass jetzt alles war wie eine Messe auf einmal, aber es war so ein Element, dass man manchmal das Gefühl hat, dass die Infrastruktur ist jetzt im Wesentlichen nur noch so die Kulisse für so ein Recruiting-Event. Und da finde ich, da muss man vorsichtig sein. Und ich weiß jetzt auch nicht, ob es so wichtig ist, dass man dann unbedingt noch im Flyer auch noch mal eine ganze Seite Werbung hat. Und dass dann auch auf jedem Scheiß-Golf-Card, was da durch die Gegend fährt, auch noch mal so ein Fox-IT-Logo drauf sein muss. Und selbst wenn das alles zu vertragen wäre, ob es denn wirklich unbedingt erforderlich ist, nachts mit einem Laser noch das Logo auf das Hauptveranstaltungszelt drauf zu machen. Das war so der Punkt, wo ich so ein bisschen auseinandergebrochen bin und dachte so, gab es eigentlich gar keine Diskussionen gerade so das letzte halbe Jahr? Gehen hier nicht gerade alle total am Stock? Und sind irgendwie nicht die Hälfte des Orga-Teams mental vollkommen am Ende? Also sie waren einfach am Ende. Sie waren einfach durch.
Nur durch diese Diskussion.
Ja, es war einfach hart für die auch. Also die haben da wirklich gelitten. Das hab ich denen auch angesehen. Ich hab mich mit denen unterhalten und so. Es war einfach hart. Die fühlen sich da betrogen und geschieden von der deutschen Szene irgendwie. Also das ist vielschichtig.
Weil sie der Meinung waren, dass die Deutschen sie zu hart angegangen sind?
Ja, weil sie da sozusagen zu anderen Bewertungen kommen und es dann teilweise auf so eine persönliche Ebene runtergeht und so weiter. Aber wie gesagt, ich will das gar nicht bewerten, wer jetzt da Recht gehabt hat oder nicht. Ich sag nur, am Ende gab es nur Opfer. Und die Firmen, die da vielleicht nicht unerheblich, aber letzten Endes auch nicht für mich, meinen Augen nicht unbedingt kritische Beträge gesponsort haben, sitzen dann irgendwie mit ihrem geilen Laserstrahler und wichsen sich da ein. Und es ist irgendwie scheiße. Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, dass die ganze Veranstaltung jetzt nur im Schatten dieser Sache war, aber das war jetzt, wie das Detail so rüber kam. Ein anderes Problem, was die Veranstaltung hatte, war, dass da durch diese bekloppten, durch diesen Sicherheitswahn, den die Holländer schon länger unterlegen sind. Die hatten da auch irgendwelche Brände auf Veranstaltungen, Großveranstaltungen und so. Und dann mit diesem allgemeinen Terror-Para, den sie auch schon seit längerem Zeit fahren, haben die in den letzten Jahren die Anforderungen für solche Open-Air-Events enorm nach oben geschraubt. Und abgesehen von Polizeipräsenz, die ich jetzt gar nicht so wahrgenommen habe, da hab ich ein bisschen vergessen, mal nachzuforschen. Aber allein schon so die feuerwehrtechnischen, baurechtlichen Voraussetzungen, die du da erfüllen musst für so ein Event, sind absurd. Und das Schlimmste ist, du musst dich halt relativ frühzeitig auf einen Teilnehmerzahl festlegen. Und dann musst du auf diese Teilnehmerzahl hin alles skalieren. Also es war genau festgelegt, wie viel Duschen pro Teilnehmer es geben muss, etc. Und sie haben dann halt irgendwann gesagt, 3000 Leute. Am Ende hätten sie wahrscheinlich problemlos 4000 bekommen können. Und wahrscheinlich auch gut gebrauchen können, weil da kommt zum Beispiel dann das Geld her, dass man keinen Sponsor mehr braucht. Und was das so konkret auch bedeutet hat, ist, auf der Veranstaltung waren am Ende nur noch Leute, die schon seit einem halben Jahr planen, dahin zu gehen. Und du hast so eine ganz kritische Masse nicht. Du hast nicht diese Leute, die dann so im letzten Moment noch gesagt haben, ach weiße Scheiß drauf, ich fahre jetzt nach Holland, ich fahre jetzt hier aufs Camp und hab irgendwie eine Woche Spaß. Dann gab es wohl viele, es gab eine Warteliste von 800 Leuten, die dann halt so nicht kamen, weil es waren halt einfach ums Verrecken, keine Tickets mehr zu kriegen. Zusätzlich sind natürlich dann auch ein paar Leute nicht gekommen, die dann ihre Tickets auch so nicht mehr verkauft haben. Die oben hat auch selber organisatorisch keinen Resale durchgeführt. Also da sind dann am Ende auch noch ein paar Leute runtergefallen. Das wird jetzt nicht so einen Großteil ausgemacht haben. Aber am Ende fehlte irgendwie so ein bisschen der Wahn. Was auch beim Camp immer der Fall ist, dass da so Tagesgäste sind. Es gab keine Tagesgäste, weil eine Tagesgäste-Regelung wäre generell nicht machbar gewesen. Also selbst wenn sie gewollt hätten, hätten sie das jetzt nicht durchbekommen vor dem Gesetz. Weil da kann man ja nicht sicherstellen, dass sie nicht da bleiben. Und dann zählt es dann doch wieder zu den Dauergästen und so weiter. Ja, können ja duschen, oder aus dem Klo gehen, was weiß ich. Oder irgendwie aus ihrem Zerahosentasche, so wie Gamma, so ein Zelt rausholen. Oder einen Hubschrauber, oder was weiß ich.
Das war Hermione. Egal.
Das war Gamma. Ergebnis, dir fehlten diese ganzen Leute, die so diesen Wahn reinbringen. Oder die Leute, die so staunen. Boah, was ist das denn hier? Ja, du mit deinem Hacker-Camp und so. Wir reden auch nur über Computer und so. Dann führst du die halt mal über diesen Acker und denen fallen halt die Augen aus. Weiß nicht, du warst auf dem Camp, Roddy?
Du warst hier auf dem Camp? Ja, ich hatte es verpennt, eine Karte zu kaufen. Also oben sowieso nicht, aber das letzte CCT-Camp, das war halt auch kurz vorher dann ausverkauft. Und Tageskarte hatte ich irgendwie keinen Bock. Zwei, irgendwie eine Woche vorher war es dann ausverkauft. Und ich hatte irgendwie so lange, da war ich unentschlossen.
Also Roddy, hier Pro-Empfehlung von mir, ja, du willst dieses Jahr auf dem Kongress sein. 30C3, das wird einfach nur rocken. Das kann ich dir versprechen.
Na dann, ich schließe mich an.
Naja, lange Rede, kurzer Sinn. Irgendwie fehlte dieser Obensaft. Dann hat es natürlich den ganzen Aufbau über und den ersten Tag rein geregnet. Und danach war 2 Tage 35 Grad Powerhitze. Und der letzte Tag ging, glaube ich, so.
Aber da bin ich dann gefahren.
Also es stand nicht unter dem besten Stern. Naja, dann ist halt auch so holländische Design immer so ein bisschen uninspiriert. Also hat es da irgendwie viele weiße Zelte, neben weißen Zelten, neben weißen Zelten. Es war halt kein Indianerdorf.
Und die alten Leteerflugzeuge haben auch gefehlt.
Wobei, um das jetzt vielleicht auch mal aus einer anderen Perspektive zu bringen. Das erinnert natürlich nicht an der Tatsache, dass da einfach viele coole Hacker da waren. Da konnte man eine Menge lernen, da gab es interessante Talks, alles möglich. Ich finde, die haben sich ein bisschen übernommen. Ein bisschen zu viel Talk-Content angeboten. Das war einfach...
Ich dachte, da war sogar ein Tag ohne Talk.
Nee.
Naja, der Sonntag war offiziell eigentlich nur noch ein Abbautag. Also es ging eigentlich von Donnerstag bis...
Das sollten sie mal machen in so einer Veranstaltung. Mitten in der Mitte ein Tag, wo keine Talks sind.
Ja, das hab ich mir auch überlegt. Wenn sie das schon so einen Tag machen, dann einfach mittendrin und nicht am Ende.
Mittendrin ein Tag, wo keine Talks sind.
Es würde schon reichen, einfach mal zwei Stunden lang keine Talks zu haben. Es sind auch so wichtige Elemente, die durchaus helfen.
Nee, zwei Stunden reichen nicht.
Ja, oder drei.
Hier fliegt ein Viech rum.
Ja, das soll passieren.
Ist Sommer. Es fliegt ein Viech herum.
Also das ist so ein bisschen mein Blick auf die oben. Und es ist so ein bisschen schade, dass man da in Holland so Reglementierungen unterliegt, unter denen man eigentlich so eine Veranstaltung in der gewünschten Form meiner Meinung nach überhaupt nicht durchführen kann. Also es sind einfach zu viele Zwänge. Weil man muss auch irgendwie ein bisschen Dynamik in dieser ganzen Geschichte drin haben. Na ja, und mal gucken. Also diese Auseinandersetzungen waren schon sehr spürbar. Weil es gab auch das erste Mal so richtig Gegenbewegungen. Es gab dann irgendwie dieses Noisy Camp, wo dann Leute rumliefen mit T-Shirts mit We are putting back the resistance into home. Wo schon so ein bisschen... Ja, und dann gab es halt Streit. Und dann irgendwie am zweiten Tag hat er auf einmal NSA auf das Fox-IT-Shit draufgesprüht. Und dann wurde das einfach alles...
Eigentlich wollte ich ja so ein T-Shirt machen mit so einer Marken-Verarsche, wo anstatt Fox-IT Fuck it steht, mit einem Fox halt daneben. Aber ich bin ja ein fauler Junge.
Naja, gut, das ist halt so dieses... Also ich meine, mit diesem NSA da drauf, das war dann auch schon wieder so weit hergeholt. Das war dann auch nicht... Also weder nicht... Also einerseits nicht belegbar, andererseits war das jetzt eh nicht der konkrete Kontext, um den es ging, aber was ich dort halt... Ausdruck, was er Ausdruck verdienen bekommen hat, ist einfach diese wegbrechende Solidarität. Solidarität ist nicht das richtige Wort.
Gemeinschaft?
Ja, also so ein wegbrechendes Wir-Gefühl. Ja, dass du schon so ein bisschen auf demselben Acker die und die hast. Und dass da einfach bestimmte Gruppen sich abtrennen und einfach das gar nicht mehr lustig finden. Und dann auch mit Aktionen kommen, die die andere Seite dann auch nicht mehr lustig findet. Also da ist dann so ein Golf-Cart mit Veranstalter und Journalistenbeteiligung irgendwie durch die Gegend gedüst. Das ist super auf diesen Veranstaltungen. Stand dann da irgendwo rum und dann nahm sich jemand Flatterband und hat diesen Wagen eingeflattert. Was jetzt vielleicht so noch als Joke durchgehen würde, würde es sich nicht dabei um dieses gelbe Flatterband mit Policeline, Do not cross handeln. Also das führt dann einfach zu Missverständnissen. Und irgendwann lagen dann auch die Nerven einfach blank. Und dann gibt es Geschrei und dann ist man sich einfach nicht grün. Und es ist einfach alles nicht schön.
Na gut, vielleicht ist da ein Lerneffekt da.
Das wäre zu hoffen, ja. Das wäre zu hoffen. Weil am Ende war das eine wichtige Veranstaltung. Da wurden irgendwie tonnenweise Whistleblower-Talks gegeben. Es gab allein diese eine Veranstaltung, wo sie ja irgendwie hier so alle vereinigten. Also alle Whistleblower, außer Manning und Snowden, das war dann gefühlt irgendwie alle auf der Bühne, die in den letzten Jahren da was gebracht hat. Also diese Annie Marchand aus England und noch ein paar aus USA.
Applebaum auf der ITF.
Bitte?
Ja, der war auch nicht auf der oben, weil es halt da auch sozusagen Spannung gab. Ich weiß zu wenig über die Details, als dass ich mir da eine Aussage...
Tell me more.
Der sollte auf diesem Wüsselblauertreffen da wohl mitmachen und ich glaub, der wurde ja ausgeladen. So hab ich das irgendwie gehört.
Weiß ich nichts drüber. Kann ich mich nicht so äußern.
Ja, ich auch nicht so genau. Nichts, was ich irgendwie wiederholen könnte.
Schwierig. Alles sehr schwierig und ich kann nur hoffen, dass ich zum 30. Kongress alle mal ordentlich an die Füße fassen und sich mal darauf konzentrieren, worum es geht, weil in gewisser Hinsicht, ja das finden sie jetzt richtig geil bestimmt bei den Geheimdiensten. So eine gespaltene Hacker-Szene. Gut, genug. Haben wir eigentlich noch irgendwelche guten Nachrichten? Ah ja, ich hab ja noch ein paar Kleinigkeiten. Wollen wir da schon zu kommen oder haben wir noch irgendwas Depremierendes?
Wir sind eh schon alle im Boden.
Nur Kleinkram.
Ja, Kleinkram.
Komm, jetzt geile neue Produktvorstellungen von Apple. Aber wär doch jetzt schön gewesen.
Wär schön gewesen, ja.
Oder von egal.
Apple mögelt sich mit Developer-Previews aus.
Ach komm, ja stimmt. Du bist doch Developer. Erzähl uns doch mal was zur Beta, iOS 7, Beta 5 oder so.
Verwälz auch mal ein MDA ein bisschen.
Genau, Mathe so. Das Design manifestiert sich.
Ich hab gesehen, es wär wieder bunter.
Und anders auch. Schneller ist es geworden, also scrollt einfach. Und Animation ist alle flutscht jetzt.
Same but different.
Nee, wirklich schneller, merkbar schneller.
Ansonsten, es ist nicht so, dass sie massiv im Design zurückrudern würden. Das Einzige, was auffiel, ist, dass wenn man angerufen wird, dann zeigt der Screen nicht mehr so Flächen, hier annehmen, ablehnen und so weiter, sondern es sind tatsächlich so Art Buttons.
Das ging einfach gar nicht ohne.
The Return of the Buttons.
Und Schatten sind wieder da.
Ich möchte es noch nicht als Sieg feiern oder so. Schatten sind wieder da?
Ja, also hier bei Settings irgendwie, die haben ja diese runden Kreise, das alles sehr flach aussieht, aber wenn du genau hinguckst, sind da schon so ganz leichte Schatten-Andeutungen unten drunter.
Von diesen On-Off-Diggern oder was?
Stimmt, da sind wieder Schatten. Ja, die waren vorher auch nicht. Das ist richtig.
Oder sie sind jetzt ein Stück stärker und waren vorher schwächer, weiß nicht, aber ist mir jetzt auch gefallen.
Diese ganzen Icons hier im Settings-Screen sind jetzt halt schön farbig.
Die sind farbig, ja. Ansonsten, naja, also nichts Grundlegendes, aber sie verfeinern es zurück in die Richtung, wo sie eigentlich mal her kamen, habe ich das Gefühl. Äh, keine Ahnung. Lass uns bei iOS 8 nochmal über Design reden. Vielleicht wird das dann spannend.
Aber so an diesen Standard-Icons haben sie nichts gemacht?
Nichts, was mir jetzt direkt aufgefallen wäre oder irgendjemand anderes da draußen, der schlaue Artikel über sowas schreibt. Also, keine Ahnung. Kann sein, dass sie den einen oder anderen Gradient angepasst haben und die jetzt nicht mehr so wie ein großer Sack, bunt gewürfelte, weiß ich nicht, aussehen. Aber mir ist nichts aufgefallen. Aber wie gesagt, es sind sehr viele Bugs raus. Es stürzt nicht mehr so oft ab.
Na gut, wird ja auch Zeit, wenn da jetzt demnächst mal was erscheinen soll.
Ich hab noch mal geguckt, irgendwie das iPhone, wie war das, 4S kam im Oktober und das iPhone 5 im September. Davor kamen die iPhones immer im Juni oder im Juli. Muss jetzt nichts heißen, aber ich glaube, September oder Oktober ist realistisch.
Ja, sehr viel später wird es nicht kommen.
Aber auch nicht sehr viel früher?
Also ich hab ja dieses Gerücht, was wohl nicht stimmt, dass es irgendwie Anfang September kommt und von daher rechne ich eigentlich auch später damit. Aber es kann halt auch sein, dass eine ganze Menge kommt. Also diese iPad Mini-Gerüchte gehen nicht weg und die fände ich auch mal interessant.
Ich kann mir das aber nicht so richtig vorstellen, dass wenn das iPad Mini jetzt in den nächsten zwei Monaten kommt, ein neues, dass es dann schon Retina hat. Das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Warum kannst du das nicht vorstellen?
Na ja, weil du musst ja letzten Endes, die Batterieleistung und die Grafikkarten-Power von einem jetzigen iPad 4...
Du hast den John Gruber-Dings da gelesen, ne?
Nee, hab ich nicht gelesen.
Na der meint halt auch, Retina würde mehr Batterie kosten. Das ist halt schlecht. Schwere machen kann man es halt aber auch nicht für eine größere Batterie. Das ist auch schlecht. Und was war das dritte? Und so lassen kann man es halt irgendwie auch nicht. Und das wäre auch schlecht. Und da meint er, er weiß auch nicht, was es wird.
Naja, sagen wir mal so. Wesentlich schwerer kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Und ich kann mir auch einfach nicht vorstellen, dass sie performancemäßig weit unter dem iPad 4. Generation bleiben. Und wenn du aber die Grafik-Power und die Processing-Power von dem iPad 4 in das iPad Mini reintun willst, und das ohne, dass du Batterielaufzeit verlieren möchtest, dann muss ein Wunder her. Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, denke ich mal.
Na gut, aber wenn Apple irgendwo in der Lage ist, Wunder zu vollbringen, dann auf Prozessorebene.
In Grenzen natürlich.
In Grenzen, aber es ist nicht so... Du müsstest ja den Chip, der im iPad 4. Generation ist, so schrinken, dass er um so viel weniger Akkulaufzeit verbraucht, wie du in dieses Ding Akku reinkriegst. Und das kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Gut, vielleicht weiß ich, was Apple weiß. Nicht, oder so. Aber wie gesagt, ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen. Deswegen meine Voraussage wäre, es kommt noch eine Generation mit Nicht-Retina. Und danach erst kommt eine Generation mit Retina. Was nämlich dafür spricht, ist, dass es iOS 7 auch für Nicht-Retina-Ipads gibt. Und wenn sie jetzt zur Eröffnung von iOS 7 ein retinafähiges iPad Mini hätten, dann würden sie nämlich das Nicht-Retina-Zeug alles zu dem Zeitpunkt rauskicken. Und dann bräuchten sie kein iOS 7 Nicht-Retina. iPad 3 ist Retina. iPad 2 ist Nicht-Retina. Aber das könnten sie ja hinten überfallen lassen.
Glaube ich nicht.
Ich sag nur, sie könnten. Also ich meine, wenn du dir anguckst, was die Speck vom... Warte mal, ich schmeiß jetzt mal kurz. Hier, die... Hab ich das... Irgendwo war doch... Hier. iossupportmatrix.com Da kann man sehr schön sehen, welche Geräte, welche... Was die so haben. Und wenn du dann da drauf guckst, dann fällt dir halt auf dieses Retina. Also das iPad haben sie jetzt rausgeworfen. iPhone 3GS, wie war denn das? Der... Nee, 512 MB Speicher ist das Minimum für iOS 7. Also... Ja, und alle, die es nicht können, sind raus. Was willst du mir jetzt sagen? Nee, ich wollte gerade eine Argumentation aufbauen, die sich bei kurzem Blick auf die Karte in Luft aufgelöst hat. Aber auf jeden Fall hast du... Ja, das iPad 2 und das iPad Mini sind die einzigen Nicht-Retina-Geräte, die halt von iOS 7 noch unterstützt werden. Wird das iPad 2 noch verkauft? Meine Argumentation ist, wenn sie ein iPad Mini mit Retina rausbringen würden zum Release von iOS 7, würden sie die Nicht-Retina-Dinger kippen. Das ist meine Argumentation.
Ja, aber das würde bedeuten, dass sie von heute auf morgen das iPad 2 aus dem Verkauf nehmen und einen Tag später gibt es ein Betriebssystem-Update, was das Gerät nicht kriegen kann, was ein Tag vorher dir noch verkauft wurde. So einen ähnlichen Stunt haben sie sich jetzt, glaube ich, gerade mit irgendeinem iPod Touch geleistet, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie das...
Das ist nur einem aufgefallen.
Doch, da wurde drüber diskutiert, aber der hat da jetzt auch nicht unbedingt... Das war halt so der iPod Touch, der, keine Ahnung, wie viele Generationen, den sie jetzt eine Weile noch als Lowend-Modell mitgeschleppt haben. Halt das selbe Ding im Prinzip, der aber bestimmt jetzt nicht auch nur annähernd dieselben Stückzahlen hatten. Da gab es nicht wirklich viel Aufschrei, aber ich glaube...
Wahrscheinlich ist es diese vierte Generation, Oktober 2011, der ist es wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ja, ich hab so ein bisschen vergessen, was die aktuelle Generation eigentlich ist. Fünfte. Ja, auf jeden Fall, da war das halt der Fall. Und ich glaub nicht, dass sie das machen, weil... Warum sollten sie? Wenn es ordentlich drauf läuft, dann läuft es da ordentlich drauf und gut ist.
Ich kann mir Retina einfach nicht vorstellen. Ich glaube, dass die dritte Generation Retina bringen wird. Aber nicht die zweite Generation iPad Mini. I stand corrected, aber...
Das werden wir sehen. Ich kauf mir auf jeden Fall vorher keins.
I will have to stand corrected.
Ich kauf mir auf jeden Fall keinen non-Retina iPad Mini. Das ist schon mal ganz sicher.
Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt würde ich auch keins mehr kaufen.
Andererseits kauf ich auch sofort eins, wenn's Retina hat.
Also, ohne meine Vernunft einzuschalten. Ja gut, die Argumentation kann ich jetzt nicht mehr brechen.
Na wieso? Vernunft ist generell sehr hinterüberbewertet.
Überbewertet. Nee, aber ich meine, wenn du dir anguckst, wie das iPad dritte Generation, was das eigentlich für ein Hack war. Schwerer, dicker, damit sie gerade noch das Teil irgendwie mit Retina befeuern können. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, wenn sie auf Biegen und Brechen jetzt ein Retina Mini bringen, dann ist es genau so was wie dieses iPad dritte Generation.
Und sie fahren eine Weile noch das normale weiter parallel für Leute, die kein Bock auf so ein Dickes haben. Haben sie aber bei dem 3er auch gemacht, oder? Da gab es da kurzfristig beide parallel noch ein bisschen.
Es gibt das iPad 2, glaube ich, immer noch zu kaufen, wenn ich nicht... Keine Ahnung, das ist halt jetzt das Low-End-Modell. Wahrscheinlich schleppen sie das... Also wenn es einen Retina gibt, dann werden sie das normale...
Das hängt demnächst hier als Uhr an der Wand.
Dann werden sie das normale Mini wahrscheinlich auch als Low-End-Gerät mitschleppen. Aber pff... Also es ist halt jetzt Kremlinismus hier, was wir da betreiben.
Gibt es das eigentlich auch als osxsupportmatrix.com?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste, aber du kannst ja mal ein bisschen googeln und gucken, ob du das findest.
Das fände ich ja mal cool.
Aber ich fand das, als ich das entdeckt hab, eigentlich ganz cool, diese iOS-Supportmatrix.
iPod 5S ist gar nicht drauf.
Ah, scheint es nicht mehr zu geben. Zumindest bewerben sie es hier nicht mehr, das iPad zweite Generation. Oder iPad 2 oder wie auch immer du es nennen möchtest. Shop iPad. Nee, iPad 2, da ist es. 399 Dollar.
Ja, das bewerben sie nicht, aber das haben sie sozusagen.
Das haben sie noch in der Hinterhand. Mit 3G immer noch 530 Dollar.
Die erste Generation kriegst du jetzt mittlerweile so für 100 Euro. Was ich auch noch ziemlich bemerkenswert finde, dass du wirklich noch einen iPad 1 überhaupt noch so viel Kohle dafür bekommst. Aber offensichtlich scheint es durchaus noch einen gewissen Value zu haben.
Klar.
Ihr habt es auch ähnlich so wie du hier so als Funktionsdisplay. Also hab ich es auch in einem Satz.
Das ist auch billiges Funktionsdisplay. Also alle anderen Funktionsdisplays sind einfach deutlich teurer.
Richtig.
Auch es macht sich auch gut als dediziertes YouTube-Device.
Oder so.
Wie gesagt, frag meinen Sohn.
Als Nuckel für die heutige Kindergeneration, ja. Hier heißt es, klick mal. Hör auf zu schreien, klick mal.
Also irgendwann, wenn das unter so einem bestimmten Wert sinkt, dann werde ich mir sicherlich mal eine ganze Box davon kommen lassen.
Wenn die Boxen ein bisschen kippt, ja klar. Momentan musst du aufpassen mit bestimmten Ups. Ich benutze meinen auf meinem Landsitz. Ich habe ja diese Homatik-Steuerung da, mit dem Tralala und hier noch ein bisschen was dran. Und da gibt es ja von verschiedenen Herstellern so iOS-Apps für, um das Zeug zu steuern. Dafür habe ich zum Beispiel Benutzung getankt. Das hängt aber jetzt bei mir da mit dieser App drauf. Solange ich da jetzt nicht Update drücken muss oder kann, solange ich das noch kann, solange dieser Entwickler diese App noch nicht die Schere gemacht hat, dass er sagt, hier nur iOS 6 an aufwärts oder iOS 7 an aufwärts, ist das super. Und das ähnlich wahrscheinlich auch mit deinem Osculator da und diese Zeugs, die du da benutzt.
Genau.
Oder halt dann irgendwann nicht mehr updaten.
Ja, das mit den Updates, das ist noch so ein bisschen so eine Sache. Noch irgendwelche Hinweise zu iOS und der Zukunft.
Hab ich erzählt, dass ich ein neues Telefon hab? Ich hab's in die Havel geworfen. Absichtlich? Nein, natürlich nicht. Na ja, hab mir halt ein Austauschgerät geholt. Beim freundlichen Apple Store um die Ecke.
Zu welchen Kulanzen?
Für 200 Euro.
Für 200 Euro hast du ein neues Telefon bekommen?
Ja.
Das ist diese Wasserschadenpauschale, ja?
Ach echt?
Jemand aus dem ITF-NOC?
Ich hab's wieder rausholen können.
Und lustigerweise, es ging noch. Das hat mich ja total verwirrt. Ich hab dieses Teil, das lag gefühlt 5 Minuten da am Grund. Und dümpelte da vor sich hin. Ich zieh das raus und was seh ich? Ein Display, wo steht, äh, was soll das? Wieder rufen?
Squeeze to unlock?
Nee, nee, wieder rufen. Weil das natürlich geschüttelt wurde, als es runterfiel und so ein bisschen über die Wiese kullerte, bevor es dann ins Wasser ist.
Die Andu-Taste für die Wasserfüllung.
Ja, aus dem Haus ein Kollege.
Dann tat es, äh, relativ einwandfrei noch. Also, die Lampen ging nicht mehr aus und der Akku ging relativ schnell alle. Aber ansonsten funktionierte eigentlich alles noch. Also, es war nicht mal zu sehen, dass da Wasser drin war. Also, dieses ganze Display-Laminierzweig scheint so dicht zu sein, dass man das halt mal fünf Minuten unter Wasser halten kann.
Das ist nicht dicht, sondern das ist ja eins. Da kann gar kein Wasser mehr dazwischen kommen.
Ja, beim Fünfer schon, aber beim 4S nicht.
Na wie auch immer. Der Kopfhöreranschluss unten.
Da ist immer noch kein Fünfer.
Wie gesagt, ein Kollege da aus dem ITF-Nok, der hat sein iPad mini auch mal richtig ordentlich baden geschickt, hat da rausgeholt, hat ohne Erleuchtung schlauerweise ausgemacht das Ding. Und dann ein paar Tage liegen lassen. Und dann hat wieder angemacht und gut ist. Es hatte das größte Problem, dass man bei den iPhone-Zeug die Batterien nicht rausnehmen kann. Du kannst ja die meisten dieser Geräte, die gehen ja nicht grundsätzlich kaputt, wenn du sie ins Wasser schmeißt. Das Problem besteht darin, dass wenn du sie ins Wasser schmeißt oder sie nass drin sind und du dann noch Strom drin hast, dann bilden sich nämlich durch Elektrolyse, weil du badest dein Telefon ja relativ selten in destilliertem Wasser, dann bilden sich durch Elektrolyse Salze auf der Leiterbahn und dann hast du verkackt. Aber wenn du irgendwelche Elektronik oder sowas ins Wasser schmeißt und du kannst sie herausfischen, ihr sofort den Strom entklauen und sie richtig schön trocknen lassen, dann hast du eine relativ hohe Chance, dass es danach wieder geht.
Und die zwei Schrauben kann man ja auch aufmachen, dann kann man zur Not auch ein bisschen Luft rankommen lassen und zur Not hier noch diese...
Ja, aber du kannst halt die Batterie nicht rausnehmen, du kannst halt nur versuchen, das zu weit möglich auszuschalten.
Das Problem ist die LED, die das Blitzlicht macht. Weil einem Freund von mir ist das passiert mit irgendeinem Android-Phone, das er im Regen hat liegen lassen. Die geht dann an und die geht nicht mehr aus. Das ist irgendein Schaden, der relativ schnell passiert.
Und beim Android kannst du die fucking Batterie rausreißen.
Trotzdem. Die leuchtet dann und die verbraucht dann halt so viel Batterie, dass es halt nicht mehr lange hält. Das war das größte Problem da dran.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, das bildet sich durch die Salze, die sich durch die Elektrolyse bilden. Wenn du eine Gleichspannung da drin hast auf einer Leitewanne und schmeißt das Ding ins Wasser, in dreckiges Wasser, in nicht destilliertes Wasser, dann bilden sich sofort, findet Elektrolyse statt, ein bisschen Wasserstoff, ein bisschen Sauerstoff und jede Menge lustige Salze sich da rumtummeln. Die sind teilweise leitend. Wenn du das lange genug machst, erzeugst du dann mit Kurzschluss auf der Leiterwand, die sind so mikroskopisch klein, die findest du nicht, kriegst du auch eigentlich nicht mehr weg. Dann müsstest du das Ding wieder irgendwie baden in anderen Lösungen, oder so wird die deine Salze wieder runterlösen. Aber wenn du das mit anderer Elektronik machst, wo du die Batterie rausnehmen kannst und das Ding hinterher schön trocken machst, dann geht es meistens wieder. Die Chancen dafür sind extrem hoch.
Tja, bei dem war das halt so.
Aber warum schmeißt man die Leute immer wieder in Wasser?
Na ja, es gibt da in Potsdam, gibt es so einen Fischer, der verkauft relativ leckeren Röcherfisch. Alte Fischereistraße, oder wie die heißt. Und der hat diesen Sommer neu direkt Bänke, direkt am Ufer. Ich war da so am tippeln, und war so, keine Ahnung, fahrig oder weiß ich was. Es machte Flub, es kullerte noch eine Weile auf dem Tisch, fiel dann vom Tisch runter, mit einem Hopp über die Wiese, halt direkt ins Wasser. Ich fasst mehr oder weniger hinterher. Also ich hatte irgendwie die Hand bis zum Schultergelenk im Wasser, und hab dann da versucht, das wieder zu finden, und hatte es dann halt nach ein paar Minuten. Aber das war halt dann schon zu lang. Und das Wasser da rauszunehmen.
Sehen konntest du es schon nicht mehr, oder wie? So dreckig.
Hallo?
Trafels? Zwischen dem Schilf und so, also ja, nee.
Ich war ja am Wochenende am Werbelinsee, und da kann man bis zum Becken ins Wasser gehen, und du kannst am Boden noch die Fische sehen.
Ja. Schlechtlinsee auch, kann ich empfehlen.
Voll sauber und so.
Da musst du mal dein iPhone reinschmeißen, da passiert bestimmt nichts.
Fast wie destilliertes Wasser.
Kann ich aber nur so mäßig empfehlen. Aber auf jeden Fall hab ich jetzt irgendwie wieder neue Devices.
Super, 200 Euro finde ich aber ein faires Angebot.
Und immer noch ein iPhone 4, Mann.
So viel Zeit muss sein.
Das ist stabiler als die iPhone 5.
Brauchst du einen Ram-Mount?
Ram-Mount?
Kennst du nicht? Es gibt so eine Firma, die heißt Ram-Mounts, die machen für Motorradfahrer, also für alles mögliche, wo man irgendwie Devices irgendwie festmachen will, machen die halt die Geräte, wo du zum Beispiel dein iPhone reinsetzt, dann so ein Stück Verbinder mit so einer Kugel und dann am anderen Ende das was irgendwie an dein Motorrad, Fahrrad oder was auch immer rankommt, damit du es dann an deinem Fahrzeug irgendwie befestigen kannst. Und die Firma heißt Ram-Mount und die machen auch ganz viel für Tom, Tom, Garni, was weiß ich nicht überall. Und ich habe halt noch einen Adapter für einen, wo ein iPhone 4S reinpassen würde, kannst du haben. Aber wenn du den Rest auch nicht hast, dann nützt dir das nicht allzu viel. Das ist halt so ein motorales System, du kannst dann das dir so zusammenstellen.
Ram-Mount.
Geil, der Laptop hat ja fett Auto.
Tja, ich hab für ein Motorrad diesen Ram-Mount, weil der war bei meinem Tom-Tom dabei. Und ich hab mir jetzt auch noch für einen iPhone 5 so einen Adapter geholt.
Ist das nur so eine mechanischen Klemme, wo du Kreti und Pleti reinklemmen kannst? Gibt es auch Dinge, die unten wirklich so einen Apple-Fuß haben, dass man da drüber laden kann?
Nee, das nicht. Also vielleicht gibt es auch einen, der auch so ein Ding macht, was man da irgendwie reinkriegt. Aber die sind erstmal so, um grundsätzlich die Geräte festzuhalten. Und die haben auch Apple-Mounts, genau.
Apple-Mounts, Mount Apple.
Und dann haben sie das mit Hülle und ohne Hülle und Variabel und auch sogar für iPads. Also ich meine, das musst du dir mal vorstellen, dass du ein Fahrrad mit so einem ganzen riesen iPad vorne dran als Navi-Gerät kannst, wenn du willst.
Taxifahrer habe ich neulich mal gesehen, der sich tatsächlich so als Navi ein iPad installiert hat. Ja, schön groß.
Also so wie ich das jetzt erlebt habe, war ich in Hamburg und der Taxifahrer hatte irgendwie, ehrlich gesagt, ich weiß nicht genau, aber der hatte irgendwie so gar keinen Plan und dann sind wir nach dem Navi von meinem Telefon gefahren. Also jetzt ist irgendwie so, dass die Kunden selber schon navigieren müssen für die Taxifahrer.
Ja, ja, demnächst muss man auch noch selber fahren. Achso, das gibt es ja schon als Car-Sharing.
Du kannst das Auto nur nicht am Flughafen abdroppen, oder?
So, ich guck grad mal, was die hier so für Preise aufrufen. iPhone 5.
Nur mit Case und ohne. Ja, aber es ist ja nur der Halter. Du brauchst halt halt noch so ein kleines, wie heißt das Ding bei denen, so ein Trapez, wo die Kugel dran ist, was du da ran schrauben musst. Dann brauchst du so eine längere Stange und dann brauchst du noch die Kugel, die irgendwie an deinem Fahrzeug dran ist. Also musst du das schon erst mal so ein bisschen zusammenstellen. Aber wenn man den Scheiß erst mal hat, dann kann man relativ billig von einem Gerät zum nächsten. Oder falls man mal Fahrzeug wechselt von einem Fahrzeug zum nächsten, dann wie die entsprechende Adaption und das dazwischen, kannst du immer alles irgendwie behalten, weil es halt modular ist. Also es ist schon ziemlich cool.
Ja, bring mal mit, dann steige ich in den Ram-Mount ein.
Die haben auch wirklich ganz viele verrückte Sachen. Also auch für Angler, haben sie so ein Teil am Boot. Irgendwie, wie hieß das Ding?
Theoretisch.
Wave-Dings, keine Ahnung, wo sie mit irgendwie anscheinend Schallwellen unter Wasser schicken. Keine Ahnung, ob die dann besser angeln können oder was die da machen. Also das ganz verrückte Zeug.
Ja, es gibt so Sonarsysteme, wo du Fische mit aufspüren kannst.
Ja, dann spüren sie die mit auf. Jedenfalls, ein Teil klappt sie vor dem Boot so 180 Grad runter, damit es unter Wasser ist und wenn du wieder an den Strand kommst, dann kannst du es wieder so hochklappen. Irgendwie habe ich hier so was gesehen. Hier, da.
Ja, ja, das sind so Sonarteile.
Verstehe.
Garmin hat die, glaube ich, mal verkauft auch. Machen sie bestimmt immer noch.
Ja, wie gesagt, die verkaufen ja nur die Halter und nicht die Geräte, sondern, ja.
Ram-Mount.
Gibt es hier auch in Deutschland problemlos zu shoppen?
Die gibt es ja auch zu shoppen. Ist ja natürlich ein bisschen teurer, aber ja, und da die ja, wie gesagt, einzeltimisch sind die gar nicht so teuer. Wenn man erst mal so eine gewisse Grundausstrahlung hat, geht es ab da easy und jahrelang weiter. Also ich habe jetzt seit fünf, sechs Jahren meinen Tom-Tom-Mount und jetzt habe ich mir halt ein, zwei Teile geholt, damit ich da auch mal mein iPhone rankriege.
Und du meinst, das taugt so richtig?
Das ist ein iPad Mini.
Wie gesagt, was mich interessieren würde, wäre so ein Ding, wo ich jetzt nicht noch die Kabel reinpippeln muss.
Kannst du mal deine Sachen, deine Sachen, die du da hast, mal irgendwie raus?
Mal gucken, ich kann ja mal nach Kids suchen. Es gibt ja irgendwie so Kids, wo schon gleich mehrere Sachen so zusammen sind.
Sprengst das mal in den Chat rein. So, ich kann ja auch noch mal ein paar kleinere Updates reinschmeißen hier. Das PodLav Projekt hat auch ein bisschen geliefert. Ich weiß gar nicht, das hatten wir, glaube ich, bei der letzten Sendung jetzt noch nicht. Da gab es irgendwie ein Update. Das ist ganz nice. Und zwar haben wir jetzt mal hier in den Publisher, also in unser kleines WordPress Plugin, mit dem man so schön Podcasts raushauen kann.
Kleines ist gut.
Na ja, fragt sich eigentlich, wer da wo reinplugt, ob jetzt WordPress noch in den Publisher reinplugt oder andersrum.
Na ja, aber ich meine, es ist schon so, das ist so eins der größeren WordPress Plugin-Projekte oder nicht. Also hab ich so das Gefühl.
Ehrlich gesagt hab ich da gar keinen richtigen Vergleich.
Na ja, ich bin auch kein WordPress-Profi, ganz im Gegenteil. Aber ich hab nicht das Gefühl, dass das kleine Plugin die richtige Beschreibung dafür ist.
Naja, das hat schon so ein bisschen Fleisch.
Läuft denn die Freak Show eigentlich auf dem Postlauf?
Alles läuft jetzt auf dem Publisher bei mir.
Deine ganze Metaebene?
Die ganze Metaebene ist umgezogen mit der einzigen kleinen Ausnahme von Bundesradio. Das kommt aber auch noch.
Kann man denn jetzt, wo ist jetzt dein Feed? Kann ich jetzt, benutzt du immer noch Feedburner? Oder kann ich jetzt inzwischen auch alte Episoden laden? Nicht bloß die letzten 30 oder so?
Als auch. Also das hängt so ein bisschen davon ab. Das Problem ist ja, man will ja eigentlich so kleine Subscription Feeds haben, die sich schnell parsen, lesen lassen und so weiter. Und gerade wenn du halt über solche Proxydienste gehst, wie Feedburner, die haben dann halt nicht selten so ein Size-Limit. Also Feedburner, ganz bekannt, hat so ein Size-Limit von 512 Kilobyte und wenn da irgendwie ein Byte zu viel drin ist, dann sagt er einfach, ich spiele nicht mehr mit. Und das ist ein echtes Problem. Und dann haben wir neulich so ein Standard ausgegraben in der Diskussion, RFC 5005, ganz tolles Zeug, was einfach mal eine Speck rausgehauen hat für Paged Feeds, was sich so gängiger Standards benutzt, wie so Atom, Link, Rail, Next und Previous. Das heißt, du machst einfach so eine Verkettung von einzelnen Feeds und sagst, dieser Feed ist die Fortsetzung von dem letzten Feed.
Das heißt, man kriegt immer den Schwanz, aber mehr kann man sich nach hinten hangeln.
Genau.
Und wenn du es darf, kannst du mal deine Maske nochmal wieder neu.
Pass auf, dass er nicht nach dir greift.
Er muss ja nicht, reicht ja.
Ja, genau, das Dumme ist nur, das müssen dann die Clients halt explizit auch unterstützen. Und das tun natürlich die meisten nicht, weil das ist halt mal wieder so eine frivole Idee von uns, so ein Standard nicht nur irgendwie im Internet rumliegen zu lassen, sondern den auch wirklich zur Anwendung zu bringen. Aber ich bin fleißig dabei, Podcast-Klient-Developer davon zu überzeugen, dass das eine ganz tolle Idee ist.
Das ist jemand, unser Haus-und-Hof-Developer Martin.
Naja, der Haus-und-Hof-Developer Martin, der ist da natürlich ganz vorne mit dabei. Und so haben wir halt Instacast auf dem Mac und Instacast auf dem iPhone das Feature. Das heißt, wenn du Instacast verwendest und Metaebene-Feeds liest, dann hast du jetzt immer das volle Archiv. Das heißt, du kannst bei CAE und jetzt hier auch bei Freak Show bis in die Ursuppe zurückblättern und hast das halt alles da.
Du brauchst keine Kassetten.
Du quetschst in die letzten X-Bytes deiner 512K noch den Link auf den nächsten Link rein und...
Naja, das ist jetzt einfach in dem Subscription-Feeds in die letzten 20 drin. Und dann kommt halt immer wieder eine Page mit nochmal 20, nochmal 20, bis dann halt irgendwie die wievielte Sendung aufgemacht. Der Feedburner sieht halt sozusagen nur das Erste und ignoriert dann diese nächste Page.
Ist klar, aber er kotzt jetzt auch nicht über diese Linkerei ab oder...
Nein, nein, nein, das ist für ein ganz normales Element, das lässt er einfach mit drin. Und das heißt, die zweite Seite wird dann eben direkt vom Blog ausgeliefert, ohne Feedburner-Voodoo und ja, im Wesentlichen funktioniert das. Also es funktioniert auch ehrlich gesagt besser, als ich dachte. Ich hätte mehr Ärger erwartet. So ein paar andere Sachen, die wir so uns mal überlegt hatten. Immer wieder sind da nicht häufig an solchen Realitäten gescheitert.
Anderen knirch ich eher, wie die iCatcher-Entwickler und so. Habt ihr die schon angefunkt, Ravi?
iCatcher habe ich jetzt noch keine diplomatischen Beziehungen aufgenommen. Wäre auch mal eine Idee. Auch Beyond Pod müsste ich noch mal aufnehmen.
Was ist mit der tollen Podcast ab von so einer kleinen Krödelbude? Downcast gibt es.
Wenn die anderen das machen, das Ding ist, man muss halt jetzt einfach vorneweg marschieren. Man muss einfach die unabhängigen Ups alle ins Boot kriegen. Dann ist eigentlich der Drops gelutscht.
Und ich setze halt jetzt auf so Buden wie hier, die die Pocketcasts machen oder.
Ich meine, was man jetzt merkt ist, Aufonik erzeugt gerade ordentlich Welle. Also dieses letzte Posting von Aufonik vor so anderthalb Monate oder so, wo mal diese ganze Kapitelmarkengeschichte für MP3 dargelegt wurde. Binnen kürzester Zeit, also nicht nur Instacast hatte ein Update, sondern jetzt hat Downcast das auch drin. Also die machen jetzt alle endlich Kapitelmarken für MP3. Ich dachte ja, ich erlebe das in meinem Leben nicht mehr. Diesen Standard gibt es seit sechs oder sieben Jahren. Und der ist komplett ignoriert worden. Klassisches Henne-Ei-Problem. Auf Phonik löst das aber jetzt in gewisser Hinsicht, weil du willst auf Phonik benutzen aus vielen anderen Gründen. Und wenn du Kapitelmarken hast, hast du dann einfach das als Abfallprodukt.
Eine große Henne.
Noch lieber wär es mir natürlich, sie würden alle PodLav Simple Chapters implementieren, weil das nämlich noch viel, viel, viel einfacher ist. Und auch noch den Vorteil hat, dass du diese Mediendateien nicht anfassen musst. Aber immerhin bedeutet das, dass das eben auch die, die eben auf der Basis arbeiten, durch relativ wenig Änderung auch solche Sachen mit reinbekommen. Und jetzt kriegt das Ganze auf jeden Fall Schwung. Also im Vergleich zu vor einem Jahr. Ja, also vor einem Jahr sah diese Podcastlandschaft schon echt anders aus. Also es hat sich innerhalb von einem Jahr eine Menge getan. Also mehr Metadaten da draußen, bessere Strukturen. Es nimmt einfach Fahrt auf. Es ist noch lange nicht alles gegessen und so. Und da gibt es auch noch viel zu tun, aber Dinge geraten in Bewegung. Das ist absolut sichtbar.
Und sie bewegt sich doch.
Und sie bewegt sich doch. Genau, die Podcastlandschaft, wer hätte es gedacht? Naja, unser Publisher, dieses kleine Plugin, das ich vorhin schon ansprach, das hat jetzt halt auch so ein neues Killer-Feature. Man kann halt jetzt diesen ganzen Euphonik-Mumpels direkt aus dem WordPress heraus fernsteuern. Das braucht noch der des einen oder anderen Schliffs. Das ist noch nicht ganz so, weißt du, dass du richtig so sagst, ja, aber für bestimmte Workflows funktioniert das schon ganz wunderbar. Weil du kannst halt sagen, hier ist die Datei. Du kannst auch hochladen über deinen Blog, aber du lädst trotzdem direkt eine Euphonik hoch. Aber du musst halt nicht das Euphonik-Interface benutzen, du kannst das so direkt da drin machen. Das heißt, du kannst auch für andere das einmal aufsetzen und die benutzen das dann automatisch und sehen dieses Euphonik sozusagen gar nicht. Auch wenn das natürlich von uns noch erwähnt wird. Also wir versuchen das jetzt nicht komplett zu übertönigen, sondern es wird halt klar, da benutzt du jetzt Euphonik, aber du musst halt nicht hybrid einmal zwischen zwei Webseiten hin und her wechseln, sondern wir nutzen eben diese ganze API-Power an der Stelle. Und das verschiebt auch viele andere Paradigmen. Das ist ganz nett. Ja, ich denke, das ist im Wesentlichen, was dazu zu sagen ist, die wenigsten von euch werden Podcaster sein und interessieren sich dafür überhaupt. Aber schön finde ich auch, dass das Projekt Zulauf bekommt. Also in letzter Zeit sind auch wirklich viele neue Kräfte dazugekommen und es wird auch an ganz netten Sachen gearbeitet, die demnächst auch wieder den Hörern mehr zugutekommen. Also es kommt ja alles den Hörern letzten Endes zugute, aber was zum Beispiel jetzt so am Horizont ist, ist so die Abstraktion von Personen. Also dass wir sozusagen, dass in diesem Publishing-Prozess auch die beteiligten Personen besser sichtbar und ablesbar und suchbar werden etc. Das ist noch ganz toll. Und auf dem Kongress, den wir vorhin schon erwähnt haben, plane ich auf jeden Fall auch eine Pot-Love-Ecke zu machen. Also wer Bock hat auf Four Days of Hacking Spirit, oder Lust hat sich da irgendwie anzubringen.
Pot-Love ist all you need. Na wie heißt das? Woodstock war. Three Days of Fun and Music oder so? Love, Fun and Music? Love, Peace and Music. Irgendwie sowas.
Ja, so ähnlich.
Pot-Love and Music.
So, und was ich auch noch erwähnt haben wollte, ich hab's schonmal erwähnt, aber ich erwähn's nochmal, weil es mittlerweile auch langsam Realität wird. Hier der David Skribane, der immer die schicken Privileges macht, jetzt auch für die Freak Show. Der hat ja jetzt seinen eigenen Podcast gestartet, den Schwarmtaler, der sich halt um Crowdfunding dreht. Und bisher sind so drei Prirelease-Ausgaben erschienen, die sich so im Meta-Kontext bewegen. Also da geht's sozusagen noch um das Projekt als solches. Ganz interessant, ich hab mir das aufmerksam angehört und festgestellt, und das hat mich wirklich beeindruckt, der David hat so eine Stimme wie Peter von Zahn.
Spiel noch mal, machst du uns noch mal irgendwelche Sound-Dinger hier.
Wer ist Peter von Zahn? Müsste ich?
Erkennst du wieder, wer er hört, wahrscheinlich.
Hier, ich kann das ja mal anspielen. Wir spielen das mal an.
In der dritten Vorab-Episode von Schwarmtaler geht es um den aktuellen Stand der Finanzierung, die Erfahrungen, die ich in diesem Projekt gesammelt habe und euer Feedback.
So richtig mit Hui und Hallo. Da können wir einpacken. Ich spule mal vor. So, hier mit Trennern.
Ich habe euch ja versprochen, über die Erfahrungen zu sprechen, die ich mit dem Crowdfunding selber gesammelt habe.
Ich weiß nicht, hat irgendjemand die Stimme von Peter von Zahn im Kopf?
Doch da ist was Ähnliches drin.
Also, im Ursprung wollte ich einen Podcast machen, der meinen eigenen Ansprüchen gerecht wird. Und es gab so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, dass durch das Crowdfunding, ich in die Situation komme.
Wie war das? Wie hieß noch mal seine Sendung? Irgendwie aus der neuen Welt war das, oder? Aus der neuen Welt...
Peter von Zahn reicht eigentlich.
Als die Welt noch groß war?
Mach dann nur Peter von Zahn, dann wird's doch schön kommen. Sie kennen sich da viel besser aus als du.
War das nicht außer... Ja, was ja geil, was das Internet nicht kennt irgendwie.
Als die Welt noch groß war.
So frühe Sachen. Ist das nicht aus der neuen Welt? Das war doch Peter von Zahn.
Ich guck erst durcheinander.
Ist doch warm. Bilder aus der neuen Welt. Genau. Mein ich doch hier. Bilder aus der neuen Welt. Aber es gibt Bilder aus der neuen Welt selber nicht auf YouTube?
Alles gesperrt.
Alles versteckt, verpackt.
Dedupliziert.
Ja, ja. Ich guck mal hier rein, ob das hier irgendwie...
Ich bin die Mutter oder vielmehr der Chauffeur dieser Familie. Ich sitze den ganzen Tag im Wagen. Jetzt zum Beispiel haben wir vergessen, Apelsinen bei Mr. Werner zu bestellen. Ich muss los und welche holen. Da hast du deinen Hund.
Also Fernseh war damals schon nochmal eine ganze Zeit...
Zuweilen ging es der Gemahlin schon auf die Nerven.
Die Frau braucht dringend ein bisschen Frauengold.
Google machen, Google machen, Frauengold.
Was ist das denn die Leute?
Was ist das, der Schar?
Soraya, noch ganz Kaiserin. Was macht ihr eigentlich jetzt?
Oh, wer ist das hier? Ein Moment.
Das ist auch irgendwie alles weit. Ich finde jetzt irgendwie kein gutes Beispiel. Da können wir uns jetzt hier lange...
Verstehe, auch wenn man schwer vergessen wird, wie der andere gesprochen hat.
Ich lasse das jetzt einfach mal so stehen.
Also wir freuen uns jetzt einfach über Davids Podcast.
Klickt mal. So, was noch passiert? Herr Besos hat sich eine Zeitung gekauft. Hat sich eine Zeitung gekauft. Gab es auch schon so geile Artikel mit irgendwie. I didn't put that in my card. I just wanted to buy a newspaper. Also Jeff Besos streitet ab, dass er gleich die ganze Washington Post kaufen wollte. Er wollte nur eine Washington Post kaufen. Ich schätze mal, er dürfte sich schon was dabei gedacht haben. Wer irgendwie unterm Stein gelebt hat, also Jeff Besos, der Chef von Amazon und Gründer von Amazon, hat sich privat die Washington Post, die zweitangesehenste Zeitung der USA, und ich das richtig wiedergebe, geschoppt.
Für 250 Millionen Dollar?
Für lächerliche 250 Millionen Dollar.
Wie viel haben sie gerade hier, die Hörzu und Zeug verkauft?
Mehr.
920 Millionen Euro, ne?
Also mehr als 250 Millionen auf jeden Fall. Ja, ist ein lächerlicher Betrag irgendwie.
Dann kann man mal sehen, wie der Dub nach unten geht.
Dann kann man sehen, wie schlecht es dem Printjournalismus geht.
Da ist der Springer noch einen guten Deal.
Also wenn dir das so gehört, dann hast du danach auf einmal 250 Millionen Dollar. Da geht es ja auch nicht schlecht. Aber weißt du, was ich, da stecke ich nicht drin. Tatsache ist, für den Betrag ist es wohl über den Tisch gegangen. Und jetzt ist so Bezos der, ja, der Owner, der ownt das jetzt. Und die große Frage ist natürlich, was in aller Welt hat er damit vor?
Was soll das ihr?
Also wohlgemerkt hat nicht Amazon das gekauft.
Sondern er selber. Das heißt, dem gehört jetzt Amazon und die Zeitung.
Und die Zeitung.
Und wahrscheinlich noch diverse anderen Klemme.
Naja, so eine Mini-Blätter sind natürlich auch dabei. Wahrscheinlich die ganze Umgebung, da es an Mini-Blättern hat er auch.
Kannst du mal auch glauben, dass der ein Investment in diversen Start-ups drin hat?
Ja, sicherlich ist er jetzt nicht investmentarm und er will ja auch so Raumfahrt-mäßig, das gehört ja zum guten Ton in der amerikanischen Internet-Tour. Raumfahrt ist das Stichwort.
Erzähl mal weiter.
Meister will mit der Washington Post zum Mond fliegen?
Nein, aber ich hab noch ein Raumfahrt-Thema, ein kleines. Aber ich fand's schön, ich fand's nett.
Ja, weiß nicht, was geht euch da so durch den Kopf? Also man könnte ja mal fast glauben, er hätte vielleicht eine Idee, wie man das mit den Zeitungen und mit dem Internet zukunftskompatibel gestalten kann.
Meinst du, er hat Ahnung vom Internet?
Na vielleicht will er die Internet-Ausdrucker bedienen, indem er das schon vordruckt.
Ich denke, dass Jeff Bezos wirklich Ahnung hat vom Internet. Nachhaltig, da spricht auch viel dafür, das zu glauben.
Und du meinst, er könne den Journalismus durch das Internet und so Vielleicht meint er das doch nicht.
Vielleicht sagt er sich einfach, ich hab scheiße viel Geld, ich finde es gut, dass es eine Zeitung gibt, die noch ordentlichen Journalismus, einigermaßen ordentlichen Journalismus betreibt, in denen er auf schönem Papier macht, damit sie sonntags morgens sehen kann, damit die doch noch die nächsten Jahre kann. Kaufe mir einfach diese scheiß Zeitung und gut ist.
Kann auch einfach sein, dass er den politischen Einfluss braucht, damit die nicht alle schreiben, Apple hätte mal in diesem E-Book-Streit nicht...
Es kann auch einfach sein, dass er das mag. Ich bin auch Tazienosse. Weil ich den einfach toll finde, dass es eine Zeitung gibt.
Du kaufst ja nicht gleich morgen die Taz.
Nee, ich hab ein Abo. Warte, ich verschenke, weil ich nie zu Hause bin.
Du meinst, dass du auch einfach mal ein Abo kaufen könntest?
Ja, aber dann weiß er trotzdem nicht, ob sie den Laden nicht morgen dicht machen. Wenn er die Patte hat, dann kauft er sich einfach den Laden und sagt, ich krieg dafür jetzt mein Abo umsonst und ihr macht weiter schön Journalismus. Okay, das ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen sehr naiv, aber ich will jetzt mal den düsteren Aspekt dieser Sendung ein bisschen anheben. Einfach mal sagen, warum nicht? Der Typ hat die Patte dafür, vielleicht gefällt ihm das ja und vielleicht möchte er einfach nur, dass eine schöne Zeitung existiert.
Glaub ich nicht.
Oder er will digitalisieren und hat da keinen Bock von vorne anzufangen.
Ich denke einfach, den Reiz, der Kick, und ich denke, dass er da einfach glaubt, den Ansatz zu haben, den vielleicht andere so zu verfolgen, bisher sich noch nicht getraut haben. Also überhaupt erstmal die Trennung von Journalismus und Distribution. Also einfach, weil die Leute, die halt mit Zeitung groß geworden sind und Verlage und so weiter, die sind halt einfach alle in so einer Printromantik gefangen.
Printromantik?
Na ist ja so. Und da diverse, also die verquicken das, was sie eigentlich mit Journalismus verbinden, sehr mit der Distribution. Das hängt dann irgendwie zusammen. Das ist auch so ein bisschen so ein Elite-Denken, was nicht unbedingt immer falsch sein muss. Aber es ist so, so war es halt bisher auch immer und deswegen bedingen sich die Dinge und deswegen kann man sie auch nicht weglassen, wenn man über Zukunft nachdenkt. Und der Bezos ist halt so ein radikal digitaler. Amazon, man muss sich mal diesen Laden mal vergegenwärtigen, was Amazon macht. Nicht nur, dass sie über Bücher und dann alles mögliche verkauft, zu einem der dominierenden Einzelhändler geworden sind. Sondern sie sind ja dann als Abfallprodukt haben sie aus der Technologie, die sie brauchten, um das zu tun, sind sie auch zu dem größten oder einem der größten Technologie-Dienstleister, wenn nicht der größte Technologie-Dienstleister im Internet geworden. Also ohne diese ganzen Amazon-Dienste, schalt mal Amazon CloudFront und S3 und diesen ganzen Mumpitz ab. Das sind mittlerweile 20 Dienste.
Amazon macht regelmäßig Server.
V4-Traffic um 10% runter.
Ja gut, aber es gibt dann fast kein anderes Start-up, was dann irgendwie noch läuft. Ich würde sagen, die einzigen Dienstleistungen, die ohne Amazon auskommen, sind vielleicht die Sachen von Apple und von Google. Bei Apple bin ich mir schon nicht so sicher.
Apple mietet sich auch alles.
Ja, noch.
Ihr tolles Rechenzentrum.
Microsoft mag auch noch ausreichend Unabhängigkeit haben, aber es sind halt wirklich auch nur die ganz Großen. Aber jetzt jede andere Bude fährt entweder oder auch in der Google-Infrastruktur. Natürlich gibt es das genauso, aber Amazon ist halt ein großes Ding. Aber diese Denke überhaupt erst mal zu haben, darauf wollte ich jetzt eigentlich hinaus. Von wir verkaufen Waren hin zu wir sind ein universelles Internet-Business. Und mit Büchern fing es an, aber mit Bites geht es weiter. Das finde ich macht Amazon aus.
Warum kauft er sich dann diese Zeitung?
Naja, er kauft sich wahrscheinlich diese Zeitung, weil er da für sich eine persönliche Herausforderung sieht. Weil er durchaus sieht, dass Journalismus etwas ist, was Dinge treibt. Ich meine, er verkauft Bücher. Warum will er jetzt nicht auch mit Zeitungen, mit Berichterstattung, mit Journalismus ähnliches probieren und schafft dafür aber Modelle, wie man das eben auch anders und effizient kommunizieren, verbreiten kann, aber eben auch refinanzieren kann. Und wenn ihm das gelingt, ob ihm das gelingt, das lasse ich jetzt mal ganz offen. Ich sage jetzt nicht so, jetzt kommt dir der Highland und der wird auf jeden Fall tolle Ideen haben. Aber ich gehe zumindest davon aus, dass er da eine Herausforderung für sich sieht. Eine persönliche Herausforderung. So wie die auch alle dann ins Weltall wollen. Zum Raumfahrt kommen wir ja gleich. Das macht er und ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass der da jetzt auch schon so einen Rudel an Ideen am Start hat, was in etwa er da gerne einleiten möchte. So einen technisch-kulturellen Wandel. Was ist es, kann ich nicht beantworten. Und mit Kindl und solchen Sachen.
Die Frage ist, ob sich das denn lohnt oder ob sich die Washington Post, beispielsweise diese Journalisten, die sich dort Qualitätsjournalisten schimpfen, ob die sich das gefallen lassen. Also die Frage ist, ob die Leute jetzt da alle bleiben und ihren Job weiter machen. Das werden sie natürlich tun, wenn die Post selber so weiter bestehen bleibt, wie sie ist. Und wer sonst da noch was andockt, wenn er versucht, das Ding umzubasteln, gehen die halt eben alle woanders hin. Dann hat er 250 Millionen für eine leere Hülle gekauft.
Klar. Aber nach seinen ersten Verlautbarungen steht das jetzt nicht unbedingt zu befürchten.
Man wird schon wissen, was er da macht, wenn er so eine Summe aus dem Tisch legt.
Das ist Peanuts, aber ich glaube auch nicht, dass man die jetzt mal summiert. Die sind nicht so aus einer Laune heraus. Ich hab mal gewettet und so. So was ist es nicht.
Wie viel hat er? Post ist kein Instagram, oder?
Der ist auf jeden Fall ja so Doppel-Milliardär. Wobei das halt auch teilweise so Buchwerte sind und so weiter, aber das ganze Amazon ist ja ein einziger Buchwert.
Aber ich meine, es ist kein Instagram. Das ist halt nur so eine Washington Post. Kostet deswegen nur 250 Mille und nicht. Was hat Instagram gekostet? Kann man mal machen.
Über 25 Milliarden haben, ne, hat er 15, glaube ich, oder?
Die ganzen Zeitungen berichten alle, das ist less than 1% of his net worth. Whatever. Ja, kann man mal machen, kann man sich mal geben.
Ein Internetpionier. Gibt noch welche. Ja, die anderen sind schon alle im Weltall hier. Der Vogel von der Elon Musk, der PayPal-Gründer. Der macht SpaceX. Das sind die einzigen, die im Weltall sind in den USA. Die NASA ist nicht mehr so richtig im Weltall.
Hatte der Bezos nicht auch schon so ein Space-Programm?
Was machen die am WCA jetzt von den Russen? Können sie sich schlecht noch mitnehmen lassen?
Doch, das ist das einzige, was sie tun können.
Ich dachte, zwischen den Amis und den Russen ist jetzt gerade die Stimmung nur so mäßig.
Ja, aber die Raumfahrt ist abgekoppelt davon.
Das hat die auch schon zu kalt. Kriegzeiten haben, die sie schon obenherüchthoffen.
Das Absurde an dieser Raumfahrt ist, an der Stelle ist die Welt bereits oder fast vollständig globalisiert.
Überhaupt in der Wissenschaftswelt.
Ja, und beim Raumfahrt halt auch nochmal ganz konkret so. Also weil da wird weitgehend kooperiert. Die einzige Ausnahme derzeit ist halt China. Aber auch die Chinesen werden sich das, glaube ich, nicht ewig so leisten können. Die wollen bloß derzeit, die wollen jetzt erst mal aufholen. Tun das aber auch wirklich schnell. Ich meine, die haben jetzt auch schon so ihre erste Raumstation am Start und Taikonauten für längere Zeit im All und so. Das kriegen die ja alles schon irgendwie hin.
Taikonauten, das ist ein bekloppter Name. Das klingt immer so nach Pizza, finde ich.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was heißt denn das eigentlich? Taikonauten.
Du bist jetzt selbe wie Kosmonauten und Astronauten. Jede Gesellschaft nennt ihre fliegenden Freaks anders.
Ja, aber nur die Russen haben ja bisher einen treffenden Namen gefunden. Ich meine, es gibt keinen einzigen Astronauten, der es bisher zu einem Stern geschafft hat. Während alle Kosmonauten erfolgreich im Kosmos gelandet sind. Also...
Und alle Taikonauten wahrscheinlich im Taik. Es gibt hier sozusagen... Ja, du musst ja gleich mal fragen, wenn wir das hier schon Crossover machen, und ein anderer Podcast drüber und Schwammtale und so, wann hören wir denn mal eine Raumzeit aus Peking?
Aus Peking!
Nicht gesponsert von der ESA, ne?
Weiß nicht.
Die brauchen auch ihr Geld um... Jetzt darf ich endlich mein Raumfahrt-Thema anreißen?
Ja, mach.
Die brauchen ihr Geld, um Humanmediziner nach Schweden in die Wallach-Heil zu schicken, damit sie dort Bärenforschern auf den Sack gehen. Ich war jetzt nämlich in meinem Urlaub in Schweden, bei Bärenforschern in the middle of fucking Norway. Wir haben dann auch nach Bären gesucht, haben aber keine Live-Bären gefunden. Entweder zum Glück oder... Bären oder Bären? Nicht die Himm, Blau, Brum und so. Die Braunbären. Was da so rumbährt. Wir haben nämlich ein paar davon. Die werden auch ordentlich erforscht und gemacht und getan. Und es ist nicht ganz so einfach, weil die Bevölkerung da lange Zeit ein Problem mit hatte. Der Typ, mit dem wir da rumgerannt sind oder so, meinte der Reifenhändler am Ort sehr sein bester Freund. Weil sie ihm häufiger mal sozusagen ein bisschen auf den Pez gegangen sind da. Die Schweden, die Bevölkerung, die rumhüpft, hätte nämlich am liebsten gerne alle Bären tot. Da hinten können wir den Song schicken, von alle Hunde tot, den basteln wir um, dann wird voll der Verkaufsschlager da oben. Aber jetzt seit ein paar Jahren ist da Frieden. Weil jetzt sind nämlich die Wolfsforscher da. Und seitdem haben die Bärenforscher ein bisschen Ruhe. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, die spannende Frage, was machen da richtig viele Humanforscher in the middle of fucking nowhere? Und warum werden die ihnen von der ESA hingeschickt? Jemand eine Idee? Musste auch echt eine ganze Weile drüber nachdenken.
Bärenforscher werden von der ESA nach Schweden geschickt?
Nein, Human, Biologen und Humanmediziner werden zu Bärenforschern geschickt. Nach Schweden. Und die Humanmediziner und Humanbiologen kriegen...
Winterschlaf.
Winterruhe beim Bären. Der Bär kriegt sich nämlich hin, in seine Höhle da reinzukrabbeln, die übrigens, ich hab eine entdeckt mit den Leuten zusammen, auch so im Wald. Das ist einfach nur so ein umgebauter Ameisenhaufen. Also Bärenhöhle ist nicht immer, wie man sie denkt, so im Gestein oder so was, sondern ist halt einfach so ein Hügel. Und da zieht der Bär dann ein und der pennt dann da, dreht sich auch zwei, dreimal oben oder so, verlässt diese Höhle nicht und krabbelt dann nach einem halben Jahr raus und seine Knochen, seine Muskeln sind so, wie an dem Tag, als er reingegangen sind. Ganz im Gegensatz zu einem Menschen, den brauchst du nur auf der Erde in ein Krankenhausbett zu schmeißen für einen Monat. Dann braucht er erst mal wieder ein Jahr, bis seine Knochen und Muskeln wieder fit sind. Geschweige denn, wenn du oben zur ISS hinfliegst. Und jetzt wollen sie unbedingt rausfinden, wie macht der Bär das? Nö, das ist noch relativ frisch, aber das war halt eben sehr spannend, weil die Bärenforscher waren immer da oben so ein bisschen einsam. Und gab da so ein paar Typen, die haben sich ja für interessiert. Ein paar Doktoranden immer mal von hier und da und dort.
So spinnen sie Leute und so, und plötzlich ist es interessant.
Und jetzt plötzlich sind sie interessant.
Fallen die Heuschrecken ein.
Jetzt fallen die Heuschrecken da ein.
Busseiser Hubschraubern.
Knattern durch die Alpen. War sehr nett da oben, hat mir gefallen.
Ja, aber das ist echt ein interessanter Aspekt, das hab ich noch gar nicht so bedacht.
Vielleicht sollten sie mal einfach ein Bär mit in den Weltraum nehmen und gucken, ob es dann auch noch funktioniert.
Bei Menschen kannst du doch schon auf der Erde probieren. Es gab ja Leute, die sich hier im Rahmen der Raumfahrtforschung mal freiwillig drei Monate ins Bett gelegt haben. Und die sind auch herrnchenklapperig wieder rausgekommen.
Was soll der das Gegentehrement machen, ob der Bär in den Weltraum noch funktioniert?
Und das richtig Böse dabei ist, dass der Mensch wahnsinnig schnell abbaut, aber nur ganz langsam wieder hinbaut. Also kannst du wie gesagt ein Monat oder drei Monate hier im Krankenhausbett und brauchst über einem Jahr wieder da hinzukommen, wo du vorher warst. Mit Training und so und so und scharf. Und das ist total wichtig für die Leute da oben, weil die verbringen ein Drittel ihres Tages auf einem scheiß Trainer. Die pennen acht Stunden, trainieren acht Stunden und wenn sie dann noch ein bisschen Zeit haben oder essen und wenn sie dann noch ein bisschen Zeit haben, dürfen sie noch was machen für die Forschung. Oder was auch immer. Das ist schon eine harte Nummer. Finde ich übrigens spannend, dass sie jetzt erst drauf kommen. Ja, ist mal wieder toll. Ist so simpel. Ihr seid sofort drauf gekommen, als er nachgedacht hat. Aber dass sie jetzt erst darauf kommen, da mal nachzugucken, wie so andere Lebewesen damit klarkommen mit solchen Themen.
Und die rosten wahrscheinlich.
Könnte sein, ja, weiß man nicht.
Bei uns macht jeder Astronaut Praktikum beim Bär. Die stinkt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen.
Nee, gar nicht. Der war jetzt auch schon Sommer. Der ist ja schon über der Rostseinehöhle. Der ist jetzt nicht wirklich so richtig Stand-by-Modus. Nee, nicht so Halber Nation-Modus, sondern Stand-by-Modus. Der dreht sich rum, bewegt sich auch ein bisschen und tut da an seiner Höhe. Der pennt richtig. Der pennt, aber ist jetzt nicht so richtig komplett offline.
Der isst ein halbes Jahr nix.
Nee, und scheißt auch nicht. Aber wenn er dann rauskommt, dann legt er eine ordentliche Wurst. Da war der Bärenfasche total stolz drauf. Der sagte ja, guck mal, ihr ist total schwer und so. Nee, klar. Ja, so hat jeder seine Freuden.
Gibt auch den Igel.
Oder Biber. Wir haben auch nach Elchen und nach Bibern geguckt. Allerdings, da, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob da dran noch geforscht wird. Wild Life.
Krass.
Das war übrigens auch einer der wenigen Punkte da oben, wirklich einer der ganz wenigen Punkte da oben in Schweden, wo ich mal irgendwie nur Edge hatte.
Schlimm. So, haben wir denn noch Themen?
Außer Bärenscheiße?
Außer Bärenscheiße.
Ach nö, ist auch gut.
Wie, dein Finder ist abgekackt?
Ist gerade abgekackt, ja.
Ich hatte noch so eine kleine Geschichte.
Alle, die WebKit benutzen, können ja mal irgendwie postbank.de aufrufen, nur so auf Spaß.
Mit Safari oder wie?
Und denn? Nach Sturz ab. Toll. Gesteigter Fehler, dann fixen die den schneller.
Die Cricket-&-Tumble-Read-Taste für Browser, die durch Besuch bestimmter Webseiten abstürzen.
Wir haben 2013.
Dann hab ich ja noch eine kleine Bitfine News kurz. Und zwar gibt es ja diese Firma Butterfly Labs, die ASICs bauen wollen und verliefern wollen und so weiter und so fort. Und lange war ja nicht klar, ob es die nun wirklich gibt und so weiter. Und okay, im Video, im Web kann man schon bei YouTube sehen, dass Leute so ein Ding auspacken, aber wer weiß, ob das alles stimmt und überhaupt und kennt man nicht die Leute. Aber ich kenne jetzt einen, den ich auch schon bei uns auf dem Camp gesehen habe, der irgendwie schon letztes Jahr, ich weiß nicht, im Juli oder August, also sehr, sehr, sehr früh so ein Ding bestellt hat und der hat es jetzt bekommen. Und ich kann es in meinem Pool sehen, er hat jetzt irgendwie einige Giga-Hashes, die jetzt bei meinem Pool aufgeschlagen sind. Also es wurde wirklich ausgeliefert an real lebende Personen, die man kennt, also es kann alles nicht so schlimm sein. Wollte ich nur mal gesagt haben für Leute, die noch unsicher sind, ob das funktioniert oder nicht.
Ist der Kurs so weit runter, dass sie die Teile jetzt tatsächlich verkaufen müssen?
Nee, der Kurs ist bei 80.
Hätte ich jetzt echt gedacht, dass da mal jemand vom Department of the Treasury auftaucht mit einem National Security Letter und sagt, lasst das mal sein.
Mit den Bitcoins? Nee, im Gegenteil. Die sagen jetzt immer wieder, es ist eine ganz normale, wird als Währung oder als Security anerkannt. Ja, die amerikanische Finanzbehörde haben noch gesagt, das wird so behandelt wie Gold. Deutschland übrigens auch. Wenn deine Bitcoins älter sind als ein Jahr, dann zählt es wie Gold und du musst sie nicht versteuern. Hat so ein FDP-Typie im Bundestag nachgefragt und wurde dann irgendwie so festgelegt.
80 Euro, naja. Besser als nix.
Gut.
Macht jetzt so, spiked jetzt nicht mehr so rum, ist jetzt eher so.
Wir sind ganz schön, wir sind ganz schön gerädert hier von dieser Hitze, ne? Merke ich gerade. Das ist...
Ja, wo ist denn das Eis?
Hart.
Äh, ich hab heute kein Eis bestellt. Ich hab noch Eiswürfe. Nicht? Warum nicht? Eiswürfe sind doch auch schön.
Gibt's hier nicht vorne an der Greifsweide irgendwie so eine Eisdiele, die jetzt noch auf hat?
Dann hab ich noch was, was sozusagen so ganz knapp an Bitcoin ranpasst. So zumindest geht's dann schick weiter. Leute, die Bitcoin...
Wie viele Leute der Themen hast du jetzt noch?
Nur noch so ganz kleine Dinge. Erstmal. Und zwar Leute, die Bitcoins benutzen. Die benutzen ja auch Mount Gox eventuell. Oder irgendwelche anderen Exchanges. Jedenfalls bei Mount Gox kann man jetzt auch seinen Zugang ein bisschen besser verschlüsseln, weil nur Passwort ist ja ein bisschen unsicher. Besonders wenn es einen irgendwie abfischt oder wie auch immer. Oder keine Ahnung, was auch alles so geht. Deswegen bieten jetzt öfter Firmen so Two Factor Authentication an. Und die bei Mount Gox...
Nach HOTP?
.benutzen den... Da kann man den Yubi-Key benutzen. Das ist so ein kleiner USB-Stick. Den machst du in deinem USB-Port. Der tut so, als wenn er eine Tastatur ist und macht aber erst mal nichts. Der hat so einen Sensor. Wenn du den berührst, nutzt er sein Tastatur-Feature und printet direkt in den Passwort rein, was auch jedes Mal ein anderes ist. So kannst du dich auf Seiten authentifizieren. Da ist jedes Mal ein anderes, kann der nicht abgefischt werden. Du musst es auch physikalisch erst drücken, sonst passiert dann nichts. Kannst du auch machen, aber der Yubi-Key ist nicht verkehrt. Du kannst auch rausziehen. Du musst es auch wirklich erst draufdrücken, sonst geht dann nichts.
Du nutzt das hier mit der von dir empfohlenen App.
Mit der Google Authenticator.
Wie gesagt, ich mag das Google-Ding, HDE macht genau dasselbe, nur ich mag das Google-Ding nicht, weil zumindest die Version, die ich damals hatte, nicht noch mal nach einem Pin-Code oder irgendwas fragt. Das heißt, jeder, der dein iPhone hat, gerade im ungelockten Zustand, kann Spaß haben damit. Fand ich nicht lustig.
Ich wollte nur diesen Yubi-Key, ich hab mal nachgefragt, ob das okay ist, und die sagen, ja, wenn man es richtig benutzt, ist es eigentlich ganz cool.
Zeig mal den Chat noch mal bitte, dass du ein bisschen Platz hast.
Ach so, ich kann ja mal, damit alle wissen, wie das Ding heißt und so weiter, kurz mal posten hier.
Der Chat fragt nach dem Serverausfall.
Wovon? Ja, fand statt.
Fanboys fragen, die wissen, wenn bei Apple was ausfällt, gar nicht.
Will hier der Einbruch da, oder was, oder wie?
Ja, war hochpro, war ein bisschen nervig, wenn man Entwickler ist und halt gar nichts mehr geht. Lustig an der Sache war, es gab irgendwann ein Mavericks-Update und die schicken ja immer so eine Mail raus, hier, lieber Entwickler, es gibt jetzt wieder ein neues Update und lad doch mal bitte runter. Und das war das erste Mal, dass sie zu diesem Update tatsächlich die Release Notes als Anhang mit der Mail verschickt hatten, weil man konnte sich ja nicht anmelden. Also du konntest irgendwie dieses Update per in-App-Update, quasi einfach updaten, so 2Gig oder was das waren. Und die Release Notes gab es halt in der Mail dazu. Das fand ich mal ganz nett, aber das haben sie dann, ich weiß nicht, ob sie das beherrschen. Ja, du installierst, also es gab halt die, also wenn du Entwickler bist, dann kriegst du quasi so ein Gutscheincode, den tippst du im UpStore ein, als Gutscheincode und dann kannst du den Installer runterladen. Ganz normal, wie du ein Betriebssystem runterladen würdest. Und sämtliche Updates gibt es halt dann ganz normal, also muss es dann natürlich installiert haben, dann gibt es die Updates als Auto-Update über den UpStore. Das jetzt, ich glaube bei Mountain Lioner war das noch nicht so, aber jetzt ist das ganz normal. Lustig ist hier in dieser Server-System-Status-Page, dass immer noch Program Enrollment and Renewals da drüben als offline steht. Ich kriege jetzt irgendwie alle fünf Tage eine Mail, ja, Ihr Developer-Programm würde ablaufen, aber weil das gerade offline ist, haben wir es nochmal für Sie zwei Wochen verleckert. Irgendwann, wenn es wieder geht, kann ich dann offiziell verlängern, aber momentan laufen keine Program Enrollments ab, weil man sie nicht verlängern kann.
Technische Support gibt es auch nicht.
Was kann man mit diesem Member-Center machen? Ja, da kannst du glaube ich dieses Enrollment and Renewals machen. Bin mir nicht so recht sicher, vielleicht kannst du da auch irgendwie deine Adresse ändern. Also ja, alles andere geht ja jetzt wieder.
Ich frage mich, was eigentlich so lange gedauert hat. Ich habe so eher den Eindruck, Sie haben sich durch diesen Bug generell vorgenommen, jetzt einfach nochmal alles komplett durchzuauditieren.
Ich weiß nicht, wo ich es gelesen habe, aber irgendwo habe ich gelesen, dass so ein Security-Typ da ankam, mit über einem Dutzend Bugs, die er gefunden hätte. Dann haben sie panisch alles offline genommen, außer, ich glaube, den Bug-Reporter und... Und? Ich weiß gar nicht. Ich glaube nur den Bug-Reporter, der war noch online. Und naja, dann haben sie halt teils aus den Sachen, die wichtiger waren oder einfacher zu fixen waren, die Sachen zuerst rausgebaut. Also interessant ist die Xcode Automatic Configuration, die funktioniert auch erst seit gestern oder so wieder. Da konnte man zwar seine komischen Profile und Zeug, was man da braucht, um fürs iPhone zu entwickeln, konnte man sich zwar dann online zusammenklicken, musste es dann aber runterladen irgendwie. Und dieses Xcode mach einfach ging halt nicht. Bisschen blöd.
Na ja, ich kann mir das nicht anders erklären, als dass sie da halt wirklich nochmal sozusagen alles, was jetzt nicht irgendwie einem extensive Audit standhält, geht auch gar nicht erst wieder online.
Da muss irgendjemand den ganz, ganz großen roten Notbutton gedrückt haben, die große Notbremse gezogen. Und sie haben ja auch echt lange gebraucht. Also es ist ja jetzt schon zwei Wochen her, oder drei oder so, ich weiß es nicht genau. Und es ist immer noch nicht alles wieder im Start. Warum Program Enrollment and Renewals nicht funktioniert, ist mir völlig unklar. Also das scheint, ist mir jetzt irgendwie nicht so was...
Man steckt da nicht drin.
Man steckt da nicht drin. Also...
Wir werden es sehen.
Die Forums waren auch offline, das war auch ein bisschen blöd. Nee, ich glaube, das mit den Enrollment and Renewals, das hat irgendwie auch was mit den Verträgen zu tun gehabt, die man da abklicken kann und so. Aber vielleicht ist das auch ein Members Emblem, ich weiß es nicht genau. Also es ist so... Die ganze Website ist, wenn man da erst mal drin ist, so ein bisschen labyrinthin. Sie haben zwar ein bisschen aufgeräumt, aber es ist nach wie vor so... Es ist nach wie vor so, dass man das Gefühl hat, ich klick erst mal dreimal im Kreis, bis ich gefunden hab, was ich eigentlich gesucht hab.
Führen wir durch? Dann können wir hier mal dem Ganzen ein Ende setzen. Das gibt's jetzt nämlich auch mit Ausklängen. Denn das war's. Die Freak Show. Die erste, aber eigentlich auch die 115. Und der nächste machen wir wieder weiter. Tschüssi.